foreign
and welcome back to our Channel if you
are new here don't forget to hit that
subscribe button and the notification
Bell so you won't miss any of our
exciting content today we have something
special for all you python enthusiasts
out there we are diving into the world
of python libraries a full course that
will take you from beginner to Pro
whether you are just starting or looking
to level up your python skills this is
the place to be so let's get started so
first we'll see what our python library
is and before we delve into the details
let's understand about it in Python
libraries are sets of predatin code that
provide various functionalities making
it easier for us to perform tasks
without having to reinvent the wheel
they are like two boxes filled with
functions and modules designed to handle
specific tasks such as data manipulation
visualization web scraping and much more
and now we will see some of the
essential built-in libraries that is
python comes with a rich collection of
built-in libraries that provide
fundamental functionalities here are
some essential ones you need to know the
first is math Library this library is
essential for mathematical operations
including complex arithmetic
trigonometry and more than date time
Library it allows you to work with dates
times and time intervals making it handy
for various applications then we have
string Library this Library offers a
wide range of string manipulation
functions making working with text a
breeze then we have random Library need
random number generation or shuffling
the random library has code to cover
then we have data manipulation libraries
data manipulation is a crucial part of
any python project especially in data
analysis and machine learning here are
some powerful libraries for data
manipulation the first is numpy short
for numerical python this Library
provides support for large
multi-dimensional arrays and matrices
along with high level mathematical
functions to operate on these areas
efficiently then we have pandas pandas
is the go library for data manipulation
and Analysis it offers data structures
like data frames and series making data
handling and cleaning a breeze then we
have data visualization libraries
presenting data visually is key to
understanding patterns and insights here
are two popular data visualization
libraries the first is matplotlib this
Library provides a flexible and
comprehensive set of plotting tools for
creating static interactive and animated
visualizations in Python then we have C
board built on top of matplotlib c-bone
offers a high level interface for
creating stunning statistical Graphics
then we have web scraping libraries web
scraping is a technique used to extract
data from websites these libraries help
you gather data from the web effectively
the first is request this Library allows
you to send HTTP request effortlessly
making it easy to fetch web pages then
we have beautiful soup beautiful soup
helps pass HTML and XML documents
extracting valuable data from web pages
then we have machine learning libraries
machine learning is an exciting field
and python has some fantastic libraries
for it the first is scikit-learn this is
a powerful library that provides simple
and efficient tools for data mining and
data analysis it's great for
implementing machine learning algorithms
then we have tensorflow and Keras if
deep learning is your thing tensorflow
and carers are your go to libraries they
are widely used for building and train
neural networks and after this we have
GUI development libraries creating
graphical user interfaces is made easier
with these libraries the first is kinter
kinter is python standard GUI Library
simple to use and allows you to create
basic windows dialogues and buttons then
we have Pi QT and Pi site these
libraries offer more advanced GUI
capabilities and perfect for building
complex desktop applications and before
we start with all the python librarys if
you are one of the aspiring python
enthusiasts looking for online training
and graduating from the best
universities for a professional who
elicits to switch careers in Python
while learning from the experts and try
giving a short to Simply learn's
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning in collaboration with Purdue
University and IBM the course link is
mentioned in the description box below
that will navigate you to the course
page where you can find a complete order
of the program being offered now let's
take a minute to hear from our Learners
who have experienced massive success in
their careers hey I'm Sharia Jaleel I
live in Ontario Canada
I have been in I.T sector for the past
20 years I recently took the
professional certificate program in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning the course has changed the way
I look at things and helped me back some
amazing freelance projects I started my
career in 1999 and over the years I have
worked with many companies my last tenor
was with IBM Canada my aim was to
restart my carrier and learn something
that would help accelerate my career
I thought artificial intelligence can
make me Future Ready
the course in artificial intelligence
and machine learning is provided by
simply learn in association with Purdue
University which is why I chose the
course I did not have high expectations
from online course but my experience was
simply awesome the quality of
interaction within the course was simply
amazing the course faculty was also very
experienced and knowledgeable
after the course my knowledge has grown
manifold I have immensely benefited from
Python and coding skills I am able to
get some new freelance projects
I am planning planning art
start up with my brand where I feel that
the learning from the course to be very
helpful I am really delighted and happy
time I try to try to create many
10 on YouTube and I talk about new
technologies and what kind of courses
professionals should be taking along
with many other topic I definitely
recommend this course to everyone after
all when it comes to new skills to
advance your career there should be no
compromise you should always learn from
the band now over to our training
experts python is the most widely used
programming language today when it comes
to solving data science tasks and
challenges python never ceases to
surprise its users most data scientists
are already leveraging the power of
Python programming every day
it's an easy to learn easy to debug
widely used object oriented open source
high performance language and there are
many more benefits of Python Programming
python has been built with extraordinary
libraries for data science that are used
by programmers every day in solving
problems Master Python and other core
data science topics to help you
Kickstart your data Journey with a
professional certificate program
delivered in partnership with Purdue
University and IBM this data science
certification features master classes by
Purdue faculty and IBM experts exclusive
hackathons and AMS sessions by IBM
experts this course covers tools and
techniques like numpy pandas Python and
sci-fi along with industry projects like
uber Transport service provider Amazon
e-commerce and Retail in Walmart
choosing this course can get you hired
in renowned companies like Netflix
Amazon Facebook Adobe and average salary
hike of 70 percent so what are you
waiting for join the data science
professional certificate program and
Excel your Caribbean data science the
link is in the description box below if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
now before talking about top python
libraries let's take a look at what a
library is python has produced a number
of Open Source libraries each with its
own root Source a library is a
previously combined set of code scripts
that may be utilized iteratively to save
time now in contrast to languages such
as C plus plus or C python libraries are
not context specific now a library in
this context refers to a collection of
essential components a library is a
collection of modules that can be
installed with the help of a package
manager such as pip now that we know
what libraries are let's take a closer
look at some of the most popular
libraries in Python first on the list we
have numpy numpy is an open source
python Library used for scientific
Computing and data analysis it provides
powerful numerical and mathematical
functions that enable efficient
computation of large multi-dimensional
arrays and matrices
numpy is an essential library for data
manipulation and Analysis in fields such
as machine learning image processing and
scientific Computing now some of the key
features of numpy include
multi-dimensional arrays numpy provides
a powerful n-dimensional array object
that can be used to store and manipulate
large data sets mathematical functions
numpy provides a wide range of
mathematical functions that can be
applied to arrays and matrices as well
including linear algebra Fourier
transforms and random number generation
numpy is widely used library in the data
science and machine learning communities
and is often used in conjunction with
other libraries like pandas scikit-learn
and tensorflow second on the list we
have pandas pandas is an open source
data manipulation and Analysis library
for the Python programming language it
provides easy to use data structures and
data analysis tools for handling and
manipulating structured data pandas
provides two main data structures one is
series and other one is data frame now a
series is a one-dimensional label array
that can hold any data type while a data
frame is a two-dimensional label data
structure with columns and potential of
different data types some of the key
features of Partners include data
cleaning Partners provide tools for
cleaning filtering and transforming data
such as filling missing values removing
doing duplicates and replacing values
data manipulation pandas provide
powerful tools for manipulating data
such as grouping merging and reshaping
data integration with other libraries
pandas integrate with other popular
libraries such as numpy scipy and
scikit-learn to provide a complete data
analysis and machine learning
environment pandas is widely used in
data science and Analysis and are
particularly useful for working with
tabular data such as data in CSV and
Excel files next on the list we have
matplotlib matplotlib is a python
Library used for data visualization it
provides a wide range of tools for
creating graphs plots charts and other
visual representation of data it is a
highly customizable library that allows
you to control every aspect of
visualization you create you can
customize the style color size
appearance of elements such as lines
markers access titles and legends it
also offers several types of plots in
loading line plots Scatter Plots bar
plots histogram plots pie chart and many
more
matplotlib is built on top of numpy
which makes it easy to work with arrays
and other numerical data matwardlib also
integrates well with other python
libraries such as pandas for data
manipulation sci-fi for scientific
Computing and c-bond for statistical
data visualization
fourth on the list we have psychic learn
psychic learn also known as sklearn is a
popular open source machine learning
library for python it provides a wide
range of algorithms and tools for
building and evaluating machine learning
models scikit-learn is built on top of
numpy scipy and matplotlib which makes
it easy to integrate with other
scientific Computing libraries in Python
it provides a comprehensive set of tools
for various machine learning tasks such
as classification regression clustering
dimensionality reduction model selection
and pre-processing it also includes
popular algorithms such as decision
trees random Forest support Vector
machines logistic regression K nearest
neighbors and many more scikit-learn
provides a consistent API for all
algorithms making it easy to switch
between different models and algorithms
scikit-learn also provides a wide range
of pre-processing tools for cleaning and
transforming data such as scaling
normalization and feature extra action
fifth on the list we have Scrappy the
next one python libraries for data
science is Scrappy Scrappy is one of the
most popular fast open source web
crawling framework written in Python it
is commonly used to extract data from
web pages with the help of selectors
based on XPath and talking about its
application Scrappy helps in building
crawling programs that can retrieve
structured data from the web
Scrappy is also used to gather data from
apis and follow a don't repeat yourself
principle in the design of its interface
influencing users to write universal
codes that can be reused for building
and scaling large crawlers sixth on the
list we have Keras similar to tensorflow
Keras is another popular library that is
used extensively for deep learning and
neural network modules Kera supports
both tensorflow and piano backends so it
is a good option if you don't want to
dive into the details of tensorflow
talking about such features Keras
provides vast pre-labeled data sets
which can be used to directly import and
load it contains various implemented
layers and parameters that can be used
for construction configuration training
and evaluation of neural networks next
in the list of top python libraries for
data Sciences Pi torch which is a python
based scientific Computing package that
uses the power of Graphics processing
units pytorch is one of the most
commonly used preferred deep learning
research platforms built to provide
maximum flexibility and speed
talking about its application pytorch is
famous for providing two of the most
high level features first one is tensor
computations with strong GPU
acceleration support and building deep
neural networks on a tape based
autograph system eighth on the list we
have beautiful soup beautiful soup is
the next python library for data science
this is another popular python Library
most commonly known for web crawling and
data scraping users can collect data
that's available on some website without
a proper CSV or API and beautiful soup
can also help them scrape it and arrange
it into required format now beautiful
soup is widely used in web scraping
applications and is considered as one of
the most popular and Powerful web
scraping tool available in Python
ecosystem next on the list we have Pi
game pie game is a set of python modules
designed for writing video games it
provides functionality for working with
Graphics sound and user input as well as
tools for handling events and timing now
python game is built on top of the sdl
library which provides a low level
interface for accessing hardware and
input devices some of the features
provided by pi game include support for
2D Graphics rendering including image
loading and manipulation Sprite handling
and drawing Primitives support for
playing sounds and music including
playback control and volume adjustment
support for handling user input
including keyboard mouse and joystick
events Pi game is often used for
prototyping and developing small to
medium sized games as well as for
educational purposes its ease of use and
flexibility makes it a popular choice
for game development beginners and
hobbyists and finally on the list we
have piano Tiano is a python library for
numerical computation designed for deep
learning and machine learning
applications it allows users to Define
optimize and God's mathematical
Expressions which includes
multi-dimensional arrays the fundamental
building blocks of many machine learning
algorithms now talking about features
piano is designed to efficiently perform
numerical computations on both CPU and
GPU which can significantly speed up the
training and testing of machine learning
models Tino provides automatic
differentiation functionality making it
easy to compute gradients and optimize
parameters while training machine
learning models and some of its
applications are scientific Computing
simulation optimization and deep
learning in addition to these top 10
python libraries for 2023 there are many
other helpful python libraries ones that
deserve to be looked at if you are
interested in learning and mastering
data science with python head on to
Simply learns professional certificate
program in data science do explore the
frequently Asked data science interview
questions and unlock your career as a
data scientist python GUI Frameworks the
first question that should arise in your
mind should be why to use Python GUI
Frameworks python GUI Frameworks are
used to create graphical user interface
for applications guis make it easy for
users to interact with an application
and their critical component of modern
software there are several reasons to
use Python GUI Frameworks for building
Geo applications the first reason is
cross-platform support python GUI
Frameworks are often cross-platform
which means that they can run on
multiple operating systems including
Windows Mac OS and Linux this makes it
easy to build applications that can be
used by a wider audience without having
to create separate versions for
different platforms second is rapid
development python UI Frameworks can
speed up the development process of
building UI applications many Frameworks
comes with pre-built widgets such as
buttons and text boxes that can be
easily customized and incorporated into
an application this can reduce
development time and allow developers to
focus on the functionality of the
application third easy to Learn Python
is a popular programming language that
is known for its Simplicity and ease of
use many python UI Frameworks are also
easy to learn and have extensive
documentation and tutorials this makes
it easy for beginners to get started
with building GUI applications and the
fourth is large community python has a
large and active community of developers
who create and maintain jio Frameworks
this means that there are many resources
available such as forums and libraries
that can help developers solve problems
and add new features to their
applications and the next feature is
integration with python libraries python
jio Frameworks can integrate with other
python libraries which makes it easy to
add functionality to an application for
example a developer can use a GUI
framework to create a user interface for
a data analysis application and
integrate it with a data analysis
Library like numpy or pandas in summary
python UI Frameworks Provide
cross-platform support speed of
development time and easy to learn and
have a large community and can integrate
with other python libraries these
benefits make python UA Frameworks an
excellent choice for building modern
applications now we will explore some of
the popular GUI Frameworks there are
numerous GUI Frameworks available for
python each with its own advantages and
disadvantages we will start with kinter
kinter is a python library for creating
graphical user interfaces that is
included in the standard Library it
provides a set of tools and widgets for
building applications with a graphical
user interface and is based on the TK
GUI toolkit which was originally
developed for the TCL programming
language kinter provides a wide range of
GUI components including buttons labels
text boxes menus list boxes check boxes
radio buttons and more these components
can be used to build complex user
interfaces with multiple windows
dialogues and panels one of the key
features of Quinter is event driven
programming model when a user interacts
with the printer application events are
generated by the user's actions such as
clicking a button or selecting an item
from a list these events are then
handled by the application code which
can update the user interface or perform
other tasks in response Canter also
provides support for creating custom
widgets and dialogues as well as
photoing graphics and animations using
the canvas widget additionally printer
can be extended with third-party
libraries and modules such as
matplotlink for floating data and below
for image processing and if we talk
about the advantages the First Advantage
is it is easy to learn and use the
second is cross platform and the third
is it has large community and has many
resources available and now we will talk
about some of the disadvantages so the
first disadvantage is default look and
feed is not modern the second is limited
set of widgets and the third is does not
support threading now we have our second
UI framework that is piquity piquity is
a python binding for the QT GUI
framework which is a popular and
Powerful cross platform GUI toolkit that
provides a comprehensive set of widgets
and tools for creating modern and
responsive desktop and mobile
applications by QT allows developers to
use use Python to create qt-based
applications and user interface with
ease piquity is distributed under the
gpn and Commercial licenses which makes
it suitable for both open source and
Commercial development it provides a
wide range of modules that cover
everything from basic UI programming to
Advanced multimedia Network and database
functionality here are some of the key
features of piquity the first feature is
cross-platform support yqt supports
multiple platforms including Windows Mac
OS Linux and mobile platforms like
Android and iOS second is easy to use
piquity is easy to learn and use
especially for developers familiar with
python its API is well documented and
provides a high level of abstraction
that simplifies Geo development third is
rich side of widgets piquity provides a
wide range of widgets and tools that
allows developers to create Advanced and
modern guis some of these widgets
include buttons labels text boxes tables
menus and many more the fourth is
customizable Styles piquity allows
Developers to customize the appearance
and behavior of widgets using style
sheets this makes it possible to create
unique and Visually appealing user
interfaces signals and Slots piquity
uses the signals and Slots mechanism to
handle events and communication between
widgets this mechanism allows developers
to create complex interactions between
widgets with minimal code now we'll talk
about the advantages of piquity the
First Advantage is modern and
customizable look and feel and the
second Advantage is large set of widgets
and tools the third is well documented
with many resources available and if we
talk about the disadvantages it has the
Steep learning curve and the second
disadvantage is not as lightweight and
fast as some other Frameworks third is
requires licensing for commercial use
and the third UI framework is kiwi kiwi
is an open source python UI framework
designed for building multi-touch
applications and user interfaces it
allows developers to create
cross-platform applications that can run
on Windows Mac OS and Linux kiwi is
based on a natural user interface and
you is a graphic engine to render user
interface that are touch enabled this
makes it ideal for creating applications
that use touch gestures and other forms
of natural user interaction one of the
key benefits of using kiwi is that it
enables rapid development and
prototyping it has a straightforward
syntax that is easy to learn and it
supports a wide range of widgets and UI
elements developers can use kiwi to
create Rich interactive applications
that incorporate multimedia graphics and
animations kiwi also includes support
for a wide range of input devices
including touchscreen mouse and keyboard
it also includes support for multi-touch
gestures such as pinch to zoom swipe and
rotate TV is built on top of opengl
which provides Hardware acceleration for
the graphics engine this means that TV
applications can be highly performant
and responsive even when running on low
power devices in summary TV is a
powerful GI framework for building
multi-touch applications and user
interfaces it is easy to learn supports
a wide range of input devices and
enables red rapid development and
prototyping its use of opengl provides
Hardware acceleration and high
performance making it an excellent
choice for developing cross-platform
applications now talking about the
advantages of kiwi the First Advantage
is it is designed for building modern
and dynamic user interfaces the second
is easy to use with a large community
the third is cross-platform and runs on
Windows Mac OS Linux IOS and Android and
now talking about the disadvantages the
first disadvantage is node is widely
used as some other Frameworks the second
disadvantage is widget set is not as
extensive as some other Frameworks and
the third disadvantage is some
performance issues on all that hardware
and our next UI framework is pi side Pi
side is a GUI framework for python it is
a set of python bindings for the QT
application framework and runs on all
major platforms including Windows Mac OS
Linux and mobile platforms such as
Android and iOS buysight allows python
developers to create sophisticated and
interactive graphical user interfaces
for their application patients with ease
it provides a rich set of libraries
widgets and tools that allow developers
to create applications with complex and
intuitive user interfaces the framework
includes a number of features such as
the first feature is close platform
support Pi side is designed to work on
all major platforms so developers can
write code once and deploy it on
multiple platforms the second is high
performance Pi side applications are
fast and responsive even when dealing
with large data sets or complex
visualizations and the third feature is
extensive widget Library Pi side
provides a rich set of widgets including
buttons labels text boxes sliders and
many more that can be easily customized
and arranged to create intuitive user
interfaces and the next is easy to use
designer tools Pi side includes a visual
designer tool that allows developers to
drag and drop widgets onto a form and
then customize their properties Styles
and behaviors and the next feature is
MVC architecture buysite follows the
model view controller MVC architecture
which helps developers separate the user
interface from the application logic
making it easier to manage and maintain
code and the next feature is support for
internationalization pi side provides
built-in support for
internationalization allowing developers
to create applications that can be
localized to different languages and
regions in summary Pi site is a powerful
and flexible dual framework for python
that provides a rich set of libraries
tools and widgets for creating
sophisticated and interactive user
interfaces on multiple platforms and
talking about its advantages the First
Advantage is it has similar set of
widgets and tool size by QT the second
is lgpl licensed and the third is cross
platform now talking about the
disadvantages the first disadvantage is
smaller Community than Pi QT the next is
test documentation and resources and
third is some performance issues on
online Hardware now we have our next UI
framework that is WX python WX python is
a popular open source dual framework for
Python programming language it is a
rapid around the C plus base WX widgets
library that provides a native look and
feel to GUI applications across
different platforms like Windows Linux
and Mac OS WX python is a cross-platform
toolkit which means that you can create
GUI applications that can run on
different operating systems it provides
a wide range of widgets that can be used
to create complex UI applications and
some of commonly used widgets include
buttons text boxes check boxes radio
buttons list boxes and combo boxes
additionally it also supports creating
custom widgets to suit specific needs
now we'll talk about some of the
features of WX python the first is
native look and free WX python provides
a native look and feel to UI
applications across different platforms
it supports the standard look and feel
of each operating system the second
feature is object oriented WX python
follows the object oriented approach
which makes it easier to write and
maintain code and the next feature is
event driven WX python follows an event
driven programming model which means
that the code is executed in response to
user events such as button clicks or key
presses the next feature is customizable
WX python allows you to create custom
widgets dialogues and Frames to suit
specific needs and the next feature is
extensive documentation WX python has
extensive documentation including API
references and tutorials and the next
feature is Rich set of widgets WX python
provides a rich set of widgets that can
be used to create complex UI
applications now talking about the
advantages of WX python the First
Advantage is native look and feel on all
platforms the next is last set of
widgets and tools and the next one is
easy to use with a large community and
now we will talk about the disadvantages
of WX python the first is node as
lightweight as some other Frameworks the
next is documentation is not as
extensive as other Frameworks and the
third is widget set is not as modern as
other Frameworks why gtk is a python
binding for popular Geo toolkit gtk
which is used to create graphical
applications for desktop environments Pi
gtk provides a set of python modules
that allow developers to create Duo
applications in Python programming
language jtk provides a set of widgets
that can be used to create user
interfaces such as buttons labels text
boxes sliders and menus these widgets
can be combined to create more complex
interfaces by gtk also includes support
for event handling which allows
developers to respond to user input such
as Mouse clicks and key presses event
handling is done through callbacks which
are functions that are called when an
invent occurs another important feature
of Pi gtk is its support for
internationalization pi gtk provides
tools for translating applications into
different languages and for displaying
text in the appropriate language it is
based on user's local Pi gtk also
provides support for theming which
allows developers to change the look and
feel of an application by changing the
visual styles of the widgets by gtk
applications can be run on multiple
platforms including Linux Windows and
Mac o x the gtk toolkit and Pi jtk
Library are born open source software
and are freely available for anyone to
use and modify overall Pi gtk is a
powerful jio framework that allows
developers to create Rich graphical
applications with python its ease of use
flexibility and cross-platform support
make it a popular choice for developers
to develop desktop applications now
we'll talk about the advantages of Pi
jtk the first is a tableau can feel on
knee lens and Unix based systems the
second is easy to use with a large
community and the third is large set of
widgets and tools now we'll talk about
the disadvantage of Pi gtk Library the
first disadvantage is limited
cross-platform support the second is
limited set of widgets compared to some
other Frameworks and the third is
documentation is not as extensive as
other Frameworks now we have our next UI
framework that is pipe forms Pi phones
is a python based GUI framework for
creating desktop applications with
effort it is a powerful and flexible
tool that simplifies the process of
creating graphical interfaces for data
management and visualization
platforms offers a range of features
that make it an excellent choice for
developers looking to create desktop
applications quickly and efficiently so
these features include the first is
cross-platform support biforms is
compatible with multiple platforms
including Windows Linux and Mac OS
pyforms offer a drag and drop GUI
Builder that enables developers to
create user interfaces quickly without
writing code and the third is
customizable widgets pyforms includes a
wide range of customizable widgets their
developers can use to create Advanced
graphical interfaces and the next is MVC
architecture performs follows the model
view controller architecture pattern
which separates the user interface logic
from the data management and application
Logic the next feature is data
visualization tools pythons include
powerful data visualization tools that
make it easy to create charts graphs and
other visual representation of data and
the next feature is multi-language
support perform support multiple
language supports including English
French and Spanish which makes it a
popular choice for international
Developers team and the next feature is
built-in testing tools platforms include
built-in testing tools that enable
developers to test their applications
easily and the next feature we have is
active Community performs has an active
community of developers who contribute
to the framework and provide support
through forums and other channels
performs is a great choice for
developers looking to create desktop
applications with minimal effort it's
cross-platform support drag and drop GUI
Builder customizable widgets MVC
architecture data visualization tools
multiple language support built-in
testing tools and active Community make
it a powerful and flexible tool for
creating desktop applications now if we
talk about its advantages the First
Advantage is easy to use with a modern
look and feel the second is large set of
widgets and tools the third is close
platform now if we talk about its
disadvantages the first disadvantage is
smaller Community than some other
Frameworks the second is less
documentation and resources than other
framework overall each of these
libraries has its own strengths and
weaknesses so it's important to choose
the amount that best fits your needs and
skill set long story short the best UF
framework for you depends on your needs
for absolute beginners Pi simple GUI is
a great starting point while those
looking for more advanced features might
prefer WX python or Pi qd5 if you need a
touchscreen UI kiwi is recommended and
for form driven applications perform is
a good choice if you are still using
python 2 you can try Pi GUI Pi side 2 or
WX python but you should be aware that
python 2 is no longer supported this
session will introduce you to the tech
inter module its widgets and their users
after that using these widgets we will
create a dollar to Rupee converter
I will move to C drive
and in Python projects I will
create a folder with the name
taken to tutorial
and inside I will open the command
prompt
and write the command code space period
and press enter to open my ideally that
is I am using the visual studio code you
can use any idea you want or you have
your hands on
so now we will make a file
and name it as
TT dot t y
you would be amazed to know that there
are various GUI Frameworks for python
but only take enter is included in the
standard library that is if you install
the python it would come along with that
only you don't need to install it again
or write any command to install it again
and tkinter has a number of advantages
the same code prints on Windows Mac OS
and Linux since it is cross-platform
oriented
and in contrast to other Frameworks Peak
inter is lightweight and generally
simple to use this makes it an appealing
option for creating GUI apps in Python
so starting with first we'll import take
intermodule for that we will write a
command import
click into
and will use an Lis here
and we'll import it as TK
so first we need to create a taken term
window
and we will add a single widget in that
and show you guys how we will create
that window
so
first you will get your python ideally
open
and just import The Tick enter module as
we have imported here
and now to make the window we will write
a command
window
equal to
TK what we have imported
and
we'll write TK
and enclosed Circle brackets
here window is an instance of Taken test
TK class
now we will create a new window and
assign it to the variable window
so this is the TK class
now when we write window dot main Loop
so it will repeat the loop and when we
add widgets in it it will keep on
repeating and it will show you the
window with all the widgets so first
we'll save this file and run it
you can see that we have the tick enter
window here
so this is how you create a taken to
window
now moving on
now we will set the title for the think
enter window
I will show you again as it was showing
TK
it's showing TK so we will change the
title for the take into window and to
change that we will write a command
window
Dot
title
and in the circular brackets we will
write the title we want for a ticket to
window
I will write
simple learn tick enter tutorial
so yeah
I will save this and run this file for
you guys
so you can see that
it has shown the title so we'll just
stretch it
and you can see
the title here so we can stretch the
take into window
till we have not set the resizable
method false folds if we set it as false
or zero it would not be able to stretch
The Tick into window
as we are able to stretch it now so this
Arrow it won't be available after we set
it as false
now moving on
after setting the title now we will set
the geometry that means that dimension
for the take into window for that we'll
use the geometry method and it's a
fundamental method which decides the
size position and some other attributes
of the screen layout we are going to
create
so for that
we will write a command window Dot
geometry
and inside
you could write the dimensions first we
will set the width that is x-axis we'll
set it as 600 pixels then we'll write
small X
then the y-axis or the height of the
window will set it as 500. and after
that
we will add Plus
what this indicates is 290 pixels that
is the window will appear on the screen
290 pixels from the x-axis
and
for y axis we will add 10 so it would
appear 10 pixels from the y-axis
so save this and run it
you could see that 290 pixels from the
x-axis and 10 pixel from the y-axis and
we've set the geometry that is 600
pixels that is the width or the x-axis
and 500 that is the y-axis the height
so now moving on
now we have created the window now we'll
add a widget and
show you guys how we add a widget before
that
let us know what kind of widgets we have
in tikento so in this tutorial we will
be learning around five widgets so we
will start with label
and label it's a widget that is used to
display text on the peak inter window
audio screen
and next we would be having the button
widget that can contain text and can
perform an action when clicked it could
have any action or it could have just a
text without any action
then we will have the entry widget
it's used to get any entry from the user
or a single line of text it also get
multi lines of text for that we have to
set
other attributes
and next we will be seeing the frame so
a frame it's a rectangular region used
to group related Widgets or provide
padding between widgets
so these are the five widgets that we
would be learning so I counted you four
but here you will learn other widgets
that would be canvas
and you'd see the photo image object and
other things so moving on we will use
many widgets
first we'll create a single widget and
show you guys how we will create it and
we'll start with the label widget
so for that we will call the label class
for that
and I will set you
greeting for you guys
so creating equal to label
so
here we'll use TK dot label class to add
some text to a window we will create a
label widget with the text hello
Learners Welcome To techinder tutorial
and assign it to a variable greeting as
we have assigned started assigning it
and the window you created earlier
doesn't change you just create a label
widget but you haven't added it to the
window yet there's several ways to add
widgets to a window right now we can use
the label widget
and then we'll use the grid method or
the pack method or the place method to
show that widget on your windows screen
or on the taken to window so starting
with creating the widget
no we will set the text for it
and text
that would be equal to
hello learners
and welcome to take into tutorial
and by the way guys uh some people call
it as kinter I quality said take into
and many colleges t k Intel
so you guys can pronounce it at any way
okay so welcome to take into tutorial
no
here we will use the place method so for
that
we'll use greeting
the dot place
and here we'll use TK
dot level
and we will place it at
here we will assign the coordinates as
we have created a window with x axis and
y axis here we will assign our x
coordinate as 190.
and y coordinate
as 210
as we have the window
and in that we have x axis at full
length of 600
and y-axis with 500 so we are placing it
at 190 and at y-axis at 210
and similarly with the place widget we
have like take inter has three built-in
layout managers that use geometric
methods to position widgets in an
application frame
first you have pack widget
that organizes widgets in horizontal and
vertical boxes that are limited to Left
Right top bottom positions and many
other positions each box is offset and
related to each other
and here we are using the place so Place
places widgets in a two dimensional grid
using X and Y absolute coordinates then
we have the grid
so grid method locates widgets in a two
dimensional grid using row and column
absolute coordinates
one thing is important when you use this
back place or grid you should not be
combined these all in the same master
window instead choose one and stick with
it
further you will know why we should
stick with one only
so here we have created a label and
placed it in a variable grading so we'll
save this and run the window
you can see that we the taken term
window has appeared and we can see
in the text that is placed on a label
and the text says hello Learners welcome
to the take into tutorial
now moving on
we will comment this
and now we will add some functionalities
to the label widget only
so for that
we will
create label
and here will not assign it to any
variable
like we will assign it to a variable and
name it as label only
TK dot label
and it should be capital for label
and inside
we'll add the text
and that would be same
that would be hello Learners welcome to
TK enter tutorial
after setting the text for our level
here we can
set the foreground and the background
color
so for that we will write
FG
that is foreground
and that would be equal to white color
and we'll set the background for the
label as green
for that we'll write the command BG
equal to
green
and now
now to
get this label
stored on your tick enter window you
have to use any of the three methods
that is packed place over it
so now we will use the place method only
so first we'll write the variable name
that is label
and the place method
and inside will set the coordinates that
is x equal to 190
y equal to
now we'll save this and
run the file for you guys you can see
that the label has got the background
colorless screen and the foreground
color for text as white
so now moving on we can add other
attributes to the label widget
and that would be the width and the
height
so
for that
will write width
that would be equal to 30
and height
we'll set it as 10.
so now
we'll save this
and run the file again you can see that
it has expanded itself
so we have set the
width equal to 30 that is the x-axis it
has expanded to 30 pixels and height
equal to 10 pixels
so uh I have told you that label widgets
are used to display text or images
and the text displayed by labeled widget
can't be edited by the user it's for
display purpose only
label widgets display text with the
default system text color and the
default text background color these are
typically black and white respectively
but you may see different colors if you
have changed these settings in your
operating system
and you can control sorry control label
text and background colors using the
program and background parameters as we
have seen that
so moving on
as you have set the color with the words
here you could also set them with the
hexagon
so to set them with the hexa code you
could just write the hexagon for the
color
and here I will
use this purple color or
what there would be a specific
like the dark to magenta
but you pull this color so I will save
this and
run it for you guys first I will close
this so here you can see
then I'll set the color with the hexa
code
and like the text it's
coming out of the bed so
that will set the width as 50
well let's set it as 500.
so it has 50 close the previous window
save the file
and run it again
here you can see that we have set the
width in s50 and y-axis that is I test
10.
so moving on we will start with button
widgets
so we'll close this tick enter window
and command comment down this
now
let's start with button widget
so button widgets are used to display
clickable buttons like there would be
text and those buttons would be
clickable you can configure them to call
a function whenever they are clicked
and in many ways a button is just a
label that you can click so as we have
set the height and width for the label
we can set it with the same parameters
and the difference is you can just click
and that turns out to be a pattern
widget
so
to make the pattern widget
and we will start with
variable
and to
set the button
we'll use TK dot button
and inside
we will set the text
that would be click me to say hi
so when you click it
I will
have to set a function to get its
functionality
so
click me
to say
hi
so this would be the text that would be
displayed on the button
and then we'll set the width
for the button and we'll set it as 25
pixels and then the
height and that would be two pixels
so width that would be equal to 25 and
height that would be equal to
I will say to test two pixels only
and then we'll set the background color
that would be white and we'll set the
foreground color as
black
background color is white
and for foreground we will use FG
and that would be equal to
black
and now if you want to add some
functionality you can add it in the
command
so first we will declare the function
and add the functionality for a button
and after that we can use the command
so
we'll just pack it and see how a button
looks in a ticket window
so for that we will use
okay we have written it here
sorry for that
so we are set with the button
yeah
we'll save this file and click on the
Run button you can see that uh the
button is displayed on the taken to
window
so it's clickable soap
that's what make it differentiate from
the label
it's clickable now we will add
functionality so that
we can have some text when we click on
this
so for that
first will create a
and we'll create the function here
and name it as hello
in here
we will create a label
in this function
and inside we will place a text
and that would be
I Learners welcome to
take into
tutorial
and now
in this function only we will
set like in the label for the label will
set the foreground color
will set it as
White
and background color we will set it as
green
okay now
we will pack it so that it
gets visible on a ticket window so
we can also pack it here
we will just use the back method and it
will
get showed up in a tick enter window
so now we have created a
method or a function and
we have that functionality now we have
to set the this functionality to a
button
so for that
we will
write command
and that would be equal to
the name of the function
that is hello
and it's Capital H
okay
and we have backed the button
so no need to do it again
so we'll save this
and run it
so you can see that we are seeing a
button here and that says click me to
say hi that is going to set the text for
it when we click it we see the
functionality that is it has displayed a
label with background color that is
green and foreground color that is white
and it displays the text as high
Learners welcome to Tech entire tutorial
so
this is about the button widget
now moving on
now we'll start with the entry widget
so for that
oh sorry
first we will comment this
and it will also command this function
so now we'll start with the enter widget
so why we use enter widget when we want
to get text from a user like a name or
an email address we use an entry widget
it's
a display that displays a small text box
that the user can type some text into so
creating and styling an entry widget
works pretty much exactly like the label
and the button widgets so we will start
with the enter widget
for that first we'll create a label only
and on that label we will place the
enter widget
foreign
go with this
like creating a level and
then we will add some text to the label
that would be
it will ask
oh what is your name
or we'll just add name to it
and here we will create the enter widget
for that we will create a variable and
named as entry and now we'll create the
attribution
so
this is the simple method to create any
enter widget we have created that and
now we have to place or pack or credit
to get a display on a tick enter window
so here we will use pack
level dot pack
and will also pack the enter widget
so we are done
now we will save it and run it you can
see that we have created a label and
place the text here that is name and
beneath that we have packed an enter
widget and inside we can enter anything
that's my name is
and you can enter anything
so these are the basic functionalities
for the introverted
you could see our other videos too
get the hands on this entry widget and
other widgets to get the other
attributes and functionalities
and use them in any app you want to make
so moving on we will comment this
or I will give an another example for
the entry widget
so for that
first we will create a label only
and
inside
we will place the master that is the
window
and assign text to it and that would be
name only here we'll create a form and
it won't be having some functionalities
to store the information but it would be
a form for name email password
for that we'll use the enter widgets
so we have created a label here
and
here you will
so we will
use the place method
to get it displayed on the decanter
window and we'll set the x coordinate as
30 and by
as 50 pixels
and moving on
we will set the entry widget and a label
first we'll check the label for email
so that will also create a label
and inside
will pass the master that is window
and
set the text as email only so
it get displayed on the label
now
he'll use the place method only
two
get a displayed or not take into window
and
hold this
I will use x equal to 30 and y equal to
19 that would in the same
x coordinates
and in y direction it would be shifted
downwards and that would be y equal to
90.
now
I will create another level and store it
in a variable that would be password
and to create it I will write TK Dot
label
so again here
it's a small
and for label and inside we will pass
the master window that is
window and set the text
as password only
and now we will place this
level
and we'll set the exponent as 30 and y
will shift it downwards and set it as
130.
yeah
so these would be the labels
and now
see these levels like how they are
placed so you can see name email
password and now we will place enter
widgets in front of them
so to get the entry widgets first we
will
assign a variable and inside that we
will create an entry widget
that would be TK dot entry
and inside we will pass our master
window
and now
we will
place this at
x equal to 80 like it would be
sufficient I think so now we will see
when we will get the display now
okay so we have set the x coordinate as
80 and Y is 50 now we will make another
enter widget for email and then for
password
so for this we will name the variable as
E2 and here we will
Orange
juice okay
[Music]
dot entry
and it would be capital for that
and that would be the master window
and we'll place this
at x equal to 80.
and Y will shift it downwards that would
be same
for the label email that was 90.
and
now we will create another variable that
is E3
and for that
per data entry widget
and now we will place this and set the
exponent as 80 only
and y coordinate that would be the same
for the label that was 130
so
we will save this
and run it
you could see that name email password
that are the labels and we have go to
enter widgets and it's
overwriting
so we will set this as 100.
we'll save it and run it
you could see that
it has shifted
20 pixels apart from this from its
previous position
so this is about the entry widget so
this is a basic tutorial so I won't be
getting into the get method delete
method or the insert method so there are
three main operations that you can
perform with entry widgets that is
retrieving text with get method that is
dot get method and deleting text that is
with delete method and inserting text
that is with insert method
we will
do this much only in this basic tutorial
and moving on
now we will create some frames so frame
widgets are important for organizing the
layout of your widgets in an application
like you have many widgets and you have
used around three to four widgets and
you want to organize them so you have to
create widget that is frame and inside
that frame widget you can organize all
the other widgets
so an empty frame widget is practically
invisible you won't be able to see that
if you haven't placed any widget in that
so frames are best thought of as
containers for other widgets you can
assign a widget to a frame by setting
the widgets Master attribute as we have
set the master attribute as window in
the enter widget and in the
level as we have seen in the entry
widget example so here we will start
with creating frames
and for that
first
we will
assign a variable
frame underscore a and that would be
equal to TK dot frame we will create a
frame
sorry
and now we will create a label for that
and we will
assign the variable as label underscore
a and that would be equal to
TK Dot
level
and inside
we would
get this label fixed into the frame
so for that we will set the master as
frame
so we have set the variable as Master
here and this variable contains the
frame
no
now we will add the text to the label
and that would be
this is
frame a
we will name it as a and here we can set
the background color also
so here we will use the hexa code for
that you won't write
the simple name of the color so here we
will write the hexa board and
taken its inverted comma
so now we have to set the background
color and that would be in the inverted
formas only
so we will start with hash and we'll set
the colors
also set to B4
hello
so you will get the background color
and now we will pack this label so that
it gets displayed
window
foreign
and now we'll create another frame and
store it in a variable
frame underscore B
and inside we will create a frame TK Dot
frame
and
here we will create another label that
would be labeled underscore B
and that would be equal to
TK Dot label
and here we'll set the master
as frame only
as we would be setting this label into
the frame suppose that we'll write frame
underscore B
now we'll set the text that would be
this is
frame
B
okay
now we'll set the background color
and we will set the background color
different from the above
so you can differentiate that
so in 99
x 7 a
and for the hexa code you have to use
hash
so what you call this color like light
red net orange or anything
so just
get that sorted
so we'll back this widget for that we'll
use the variable labeled underscopy
we'll use the pack method
and we have packed it
now
we will save this
[Music]
okay
we have not placed inverted from here so
we'll save this
and run it
can development is not defined so we
have written label okay
so so for my same mistake
so we'll save this and run it again for
you guys
so here we are not able to see it
so what oh we have not packed the frame
View
so
we would not be able to see that
so we'll pack it here only so first
we'll Bank
payment underscore a
Dot
back
and then frame underscore the key dot
Bank
now we'll save this and run it again
you could see there is two frames
displaying that is this is the frame a
and this is the frame B and this is the
label on above the frame
and if we just
swap these packs what would happen let's
see
you can save this
and run the file again you could see
that the frame has been shifted so the
back method it just packed the widgets
line by one line by line
in a layer form
so you must be careful with that
okay
so now we'll see some
appearance for the
frames
we have seen how to create a frame now
we'll see
how these frames can be displayed how
how its appearances are like we have the
five appearances we will discuss it
and we will adjust these frames
according to their appearances and these
appearances can be called out with the
method or with the attribute that is
relief so frame widgets can be
configured with a relief attribute that
creates a border around the frame you
can set relief to be any of the values
that is the flat value that we have seen
that has no border effect the default
value then there is sunken that is h u n
k n in the capitals that it creates a
sunken effect I will show you like what
that effect is then we have the raised
then Groove and the ridge so for that we
will see a simple example
and one important thing to apply this
border effect we must set the border
with attribute to a value greater than
word greater than one this attribute
adjust the width of the Border in pixels
so for that
we will create the frames
and we will start with
border
and that would be equal to
we will create a dictionary here
so for the flat keyword
we will
create a
in the capital letters we have to write
flat
okay and for the sun can
we will create
second
okay
and actually we have to place the Pumas
and after sunken we have raised Groove
and Ridge
so for that
we'll write raised
and we will create TK I have Dynamics
take above
so this would be TK Dot
second comma
and now we will have the group border
that SDK Dot
Groove
comma and after that Reg
that is TK
dot rich
okay
so
no
we will
run a loop four
relief underscore name
comma
relief
and
yes at the order
um
that is Will iterate these items one by
one
and now we will
create a frame that would be TK Dot
beam and set the master
as window
and
relief
equal to
and set the Border width
that's also the point and we'll set it
as five okay
and no
we will back this Frame
so for that we'll use the back method
frame load
back
and now we will create a label
that is TK Dot
label
and inside
and set the master as
frame
and
text
we'll set the text as
relief underscore name
and then we'll pack this label
okay now we'll save this
and display it for you guys
so you could see that first we have the
flat frame then Sun can then base then
grow then Rich
okay
so if you want to set these frames on
the left side
for that you can
use TK Dot
left attribute
we'll save this
and run it for you guys
we have to assign it inside sorry
I will save this and run it for you guys
so you can see that it has shifted to
left like all these are packed in the
left
Direction
all the frames
so now moving on
now we will see the frames with
different colors
I'll just comment this down
and now we will get the frames we'll
start with
a variable and name it as frame 1 and
create a frame
TK Dot
frame
with capital f
and inside we'll set the master as
window
and
width as 100
height as 100
and background color
we will set it as
red
and now
we will back this Frame
so this Frame would be of the red color
so to pack this we will write frame 1
that is the variable in which the frame
has been stored and we'll use the back
method
so we have packed it
now
we will use
fill
to fill this frame in the whole window
well that will write fill equal to
TK dot capital s x so it will get this
Frame fulfilled in the window in the X
Direction
and similarly we will create another
frame
I will copy paste it and name the
available as variable as frame 2. and
inside I will change the color
and I will set the width and height now
okay I will show you like
how it will work
and now we'll also
set another frame and named as frame 3.
okay
and for this also we have to set another
color
so that we can differentiate that which
frame is this
so inside it as blue now we'll save this
and run it so you can see that we have
set the width and height but we have
use the fill attribute to fill it in the
whole external
extraction so it has good buildup
so these are the three frames we have
created
now
we have seen the basics or the beginner
for the take into module
Now using these modules we will create a
simple project that would be Dollar to
Rupee converted as I have told you
earlier
in the starting in the introduction
for that
it will just create a new file and named
as
dollar
to Rupee
converter Dot py
so if
like rupee
so here we will use the current value
of
what one dollar is equal to Rupee we
will set it as current value so we will
search it in the web and
use it in a function okay
so we'll make this project a simple one
or just a simple app
to get your hands on with these widgets
say okay
so starting with importing
so first of all import T enter
and as we have seen earlier a views
allies for that and here also we'll use
that and after that we will
create window that is equal to TK both
TK class
and
window Dot
main Loop
okay
now we will set the geometry of the
window so for that we will write
and we will set the x-axis with 300
pixels
and small X and Y axis as 250 pixels
okay
and we won't be adding some pixels to
the x or the wire Direction it will just
come in the default section that uh
this ideally would get it up here too
okay now we'll use the configure
function
and set the background color so with
configure you could set the background
color and other attributes so for that
we will write window
config
and inside we will set the background
color BG
equal to
and I remember the exact code for that
here we will use hexagon or you could
just write the name of the column okay
we have used it previously the light red
color
okay
now uh I have discussed with you that
the resizable function but we haven't
used it
in the form of
that is the py file but here we will use
so for that we will write window dot
resizable
and inside we will set the width
equal to false
and height also as false
so you won't be able to adjust its
widthood height
width or height
and you won't be seeing any arrow for
that okay like if you place
the cursor on the border of the window
now you won't be able to see any error
to get it stretched out in the x or y
direction
so we have
use the resizable function for that now
we'll set that title for this window
put that we'll write window.title
and inside we'll write the title that
would be dollar
to Rupee converter
converter okay
now
first we will start with a label
and we will add the heading as
Dollar to Rupee converter only
so for that we will create a label and
place it inside the variable L1
TK Dot
table and inside
we will pass the master as window
and
set the text
as Dollar to Rupee converter
and we can set the font also okay
so that will just use the font attribute
and inside we have to place these
in a circular braces
so for that we will write we have
in its inverted comma
we'll use area here
okay
and set the font size as 15. now we'll
close the globe bracket
okay
we have to close one more
and we will set the foreground color as
white
okay
then we'll also set background color
and that we would set as example
B
C 0.
0 okay
and that would be in the inverted
Compass answer it would be
termed as the comment only
and now we'll close the circular bracket
okay
and we will pack it at the last only
now we will create another label
and
put that
will store it in
L2 variable
for that we'll write TK Dot
label and inside will pass
window as master
and text
and here we will
set the level as enter dollar amount
okay
well that will be quite text
enter dollar
amount
okay
now we will add some functionality and
after amount we will write the colon
now we'll set its font
in the
circular basis and
we will set this also as heavy
and set its size
just smaller than the heading that would
be Dollar to Rupee converter
which I did S10
okay
and
we'll set it as bold
this way I have to place it in inverted
commas
and after the font we'll set the
foreground color
and that would be equal to
White
and then we'll set the background color
we have taken the inverted comma the
white
now we'll set the background color
and for that we'll write the hexagon
and that would be a
five
six nine BD
so let's see
this purple color
so I call it popper
I am bad with color so you can see
what you want to call this color or like
what's the fundamental name of this
color
so now we have created two levels and a
dollar amount and now we create we will
get another label and that would be
or amount in rupees like after we will
execute the Dollar to Rupee so that
would be displayed in that level that
would be displayed just beneath this
label that we will be creating that
would be L3
and for that we will write TK dot level
and inside we will pass the master as
window
and set that text
as amount in rupees
okay
and now we will set its font
and
we'll set it same only
yes
area
and with the font size
10 and also set it as bold
so send this font
we will set the foreground and
background color
and that would be foreground color
White
and background color
we'll write the hexa code for that only
then that would be same A5
69 BD
okay
now we will create enter widgets
so
first time to visit that would be four
entering the amount enter dollar amount
so
in the center widget would be beneath
the enter dollar Mount label
so for that we will create a variable
even
and
enter widget TK Dot
entry
and we have
E capital for the entry and inside we
will pass
Master as window
and we'll set the font
as area
in the circular basis
okay
and set the font size as 10. and no bold
for it
okay
and
in the window first we have created the
heading that was in the label that is
Dollar to Rupee converted then we have
created a labor enter dollar amount and
beneath that we have created an entry
widget in which we will enter the dollar
amount
and then
we will create a button to convert this
taller amount into the Ruby
so now we will be creating a button
so we will name the variable as button
one
normal pass the window as master
and set the font
as area
and
phone says 10 only
[Music]
um
but for button first we have to set the
text name what it should display
so
it should display
convert
to dollar
convert to Rupee
yeah
okay
so we have
set the text
and we have set the font and now
we have to place a command and that
command we have to place a function so
that it should convert the dollar amount
into the rupee
so we have to create a function
we will create it
create it here
okay
and name it as convert only
so for that
convert
and inside we will
set a variable
and integer type
and here we are using the get method
to get the text that we have imported in
the entry widget that is stored in the
even variable
and after that
we will create a variable F and inside
we will write the dollar value against a
rupee that is
80.71 Rupees is equal to one dollar
so that would be multiplied with the
dollar amount
that would be C
but we will
get it
oh sorry
okay
so now
now we will
now we will create a text widget
so for that we will
create a variable that is T1
and create a text widget
TK
Dot
text and inside we will pass the window
as master
and set the state
as disabled
I will tell you why
disabled
and set its width
as
and
right yes zero okay
so you will also configure this in the
function
okay
so we'll configure this and write as T1
Dot
config
and we'll set its state
equal to normal
okay
and T1 Dot
delete
that is
if you want to delete you can delete a
test
one by one
TK Dot and
and T1 dot insert
and set it as its state as disabled
okay
now we will pack all these
widgets
first we'll start with labels
L1 load pack
then L2 Dot
back
and then
enter widget
that is stored in even even node
back
and then
button
dot back
and then L3
and then
P1 Dot
back
okay
now we'll save this
and run it
okay
so we have to create
empty text
like empty labels
we will create it here
empty
underscore L1
and create a label that is TK Dot
label
okay
and inside we will pass
window and set the background color
equal to
it would be e
nine nine
six seven oh sorry
e9967 a that is the light red color okay
and here you will create an empty level
that is TK Dot
label
and
now we will
pass the master as window
and background color
as light red only
we'll write the same example e99
so AI
press shift also with that
so
okay
now
now we'll save our program
and run it
so we are getting an error that is
defined at State equal to normal
okay
yeah so we'll just run it again only
we encode that
so you can see that it's not resizable
we have created the convert method to
create the dollar amount that is we have
entered
the dollar amount that is one and we
click on the button that is convert to
dollar it would reflect us to 82.71
and if we get it deleted and enter the
dollar amount as 56 and click on the
button that is convert to dollar it
would display us as 56 into the value
that is 82.71
so this is the small project that we
have created using the widgets that is
the teak into widgets
so I hope like you got these all the
widgets so this was the basic tutorial
if you want to learn more you can just
see the other videos that is in the I
button
if you are one of the aspiring python
Enthusiast looking for online training
and graduating from the best
universities for a professional who
elicits to switch careers in Python by
learning from the experts and try giving
a show to Simply lens postgraduate
program in Ai and machine learning in
collaboration with Purdue University and
IBM the course link is mentioned in the
description box below that will navigate
you to the course page where you can
find a complete audio of the program
being offered C born library in Python
in today's video we will learn how to
visualize data and draw insights with
different charts and graphs using the c
bond Library
these visualizations are often referred
to as plots in Python
so what is C born in Python the c-bond
library in Python is a widely popular
data visualization library that is
commonly used for data science and
machine learning tasks
it is built on top of the matplotlab
data visualization Library
and allows you to perform exploratory
data analysis
using c bond you can create interactive
plots to answer specific questions about
your data
it helps you find Trends in your data
that you can't notice just by looking at
the reader
now to understand the C1 library in
detail and how to create different plots
and know the data better we'll be using
two data sets in our demo
the first one is the empty cast dataset
and the second is the popular Iris
flower data set
now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook and start with our
demonstration
so I am on my jupyter notebook let me go
ahead and rename the notebook I'll say
c bond
demo
will rename it
all right
you can see I have the first two cells
already filled in so while working on an
exploratory data analysis project using
python you will need numpy pandas
matplotlib and c-bone libraries for data
manipulation and visualization
so let's import these libraries first so
I've already written import numpy as NP
pandas SPD matplotlib dot Pi plot splt C
bonus SNS
all right so I'll hit shift enter to run
this first cell
all right
Now using the read underscore CSV
function that is present in the pandas
Library I am importing my data set that
is empty cars I'll tell you what empty
cars is about this is a CSV data set and
here I have given the location where my
data set is present
let's run it
all right
now
let me go ahead and print the first
five rows
of my empty cars
data frame
for that I am using the head function if
I run it
okay you can see here it has given me
the first five rows the index starts
from 0 till 4 so total five rows of
information and
you can see these are the columns that
are present in the empty cast data set
the first is the
model of the car
now just let me give you a background
about this data set so the data is taken
from the 1974 Motor Trend Us magazine
it has information about fuel
consumption and 11 different aspects of
automobile design and performance of 32
cars
all right
so here we have the First Column as the
model of the car and then we have MPG
which is miles per gallon
then we have C by L which stands for the
number of cylinders in the vehicle or
the car
then we have disp which is displacement
in cubic inches so these all values are
in cubic inches
after that we have HP which is cross
horsepower
then we have something called as drat
which is basically the rear axle ratio
then we have WT which is the
weight of the
car in pounds
so think of it as weight multiplied by
1000 pounds
all right and then we have q SEC which
is one fourth mile time this is a
measure for acceleration then we have
something called as vs this is
the type of engine for each of the
vehicles so 0 stands for v-shaped engine
and one stands for straight engine
then we have am which is basically
the mode of transmission so 0 is for
automatic transmission and one is for
manual transmission
then we have the number of
forward gears present in the vehicle and
then we have something called as carb or
carb
this stands for the number of
carburetors so carburetors is a device
for supplying uh spark ignition engine
with a mixture of fuel and Air
all right
now
we'll use the info function to print the
summary of the data frame so the info
function returns information regarding
the index data type column data types
then we have the information about
nominal values and memory usage
so I'll write my data frame name which
is empty cars
dot I am going to use the info function
let's run it and here you can see we
have
all the columns there are total 32
entries from 0 to 31 so data about 32
cars
then here you can see the data types
and the memory usage
now moving ahead
let me just print the shape of the data
frame that will give you the number of
rows and columns present
I'll use the shape attribute
you can see here there are total 32 rows
and 12 columns in my data set now the c
bond Library provides a range of
plotting functions that makes the
visualization and Analysis of data
easier
so we'll cover some of the crucial plots
that are available in c-bond
so let's start with a bar plot I'll give
a comment as
bar plot
now
first understand what a bar plot is so a
bar plot gives an estimate of the
central tendency of a numeric variable
with the height of each rectangle it
provides some indication of the
uncertainty around the estimate using
error bars now to build this plot you
usually choose a categorical column in
the x-axis and a numeric column on the
y-axis
so
we'll create a bar plot between the
number of cylinders and the miles per
gallon
so let's start
I'll declare a variable called res which
essentially stands for result
then I'll use SNS
which is for the c bond Library
I'll say SNS Dot
followed by my bar plot function
and inside the function
I'll pass in my
data frame name that is empty cars
and then
for x axis within the bracket using
quotation I'll give my column name
as cylinder so this is going to be my
x-axis
and for y axis I'll say my data frame
name empty cars
then the square bracket followed by my
y-axis column that is miles per gallon
now to display I'm going to use the Mac
plotly function I'll say PLT dot show
let's run it and we'll see the result
there you go
so here you can see on the
x axis we have the number of cylinders
so in our data we have vehicles with 4 6
or 8 cylinders and on the y-axis you can
see the miles per gallon
now what essentially this graph tells us
is that when the number of cylinders in
the vehicle increases my miles per
gallon on MPG for the vehicles decreases
and you can see these black lines
so these lines indicate
the uncertainty around the estimate
using error bars
all right
now you can create the
same bar plot using another V now we
will exclusively Define the X and Y axis
columns and also pass the name of the
data frame using the data argument let
me show you how to do it
I'll use the same variable name res
which stands for result I'll say SNS Dot
bar plot
now inside the
bar plot function
I am going to exclusively Define my x
axis I'll say x equal to
I'll pass in my column as
cylinder
then I'll say y-axis
which is miles per gallon
and then using the data attribute
I'll pass in my data frame name that is
empty cars
and finally we'll write PLT dot show
let me run it
you see here we have the exact
same bar plot as the above one so this
is another way to create a bar plot now
python c bond allows the users to assign
colors to the bars
so the bar chart that we are going to
create will convert all the bars to a
particular color
so for that I am going to use the color
argument
so I'll say res equal to
sns. my function that is bar plot
I'll say X
equal to
cylinder
my y axis
will have
MPG
and then I'll say data
is empty cars
give a comma and my final attribute I'll
say
color
equal to I'll say yellow
close the bracket
and then
I'm going to write PLT dot show
if I run it you can see here
all the bars have been converted to
yellow color now
you can change the color
argument let's say I'll make it to red
if I print it you can see here all the
bars have been changed to red color now
all right
now C bone Library also has the
palette argument
which you can use to give different
colors to the bars so if you go to
Google and search for
Seaborn palette
you have a nice link here
so here you have there are different
pallets provided by
C bone you can see here SNS dot color
palette and these are the
names of the palette
you can use whichever palette you want
all right
so
I'll say res equal to
sns.bar plot
we'll use our first method of
assigning
a bar plot so I'm using my data frame
empty cars this time we are going to
change the accent by labels let's say
I'm using
my X label as
transmission whether
automatic or manual transmission
and then in my y-axis I'll have
miles per gallon
then
I'm going to say
palette
equal to
I made a spelling mistake here
let's say our palette is
set to this is the name of the palette
I'll write PLT dot show
if I run it you can see here
we have the
two modes of transmission zero is for
automatic transmission of the vehicle
one is for manual transmission and you
can see the miles per gallon for each of
the modes of transmission if you want
you can change the palette colors let me
just copy this
I'll paste it in my new cell
and instead of set to let's see we'll
use
another palette
called as Rocket
and I'm also going to alter
my X and Y labels let's see in my X
label I'll have gear
and my valuable will be horsepower
if I run it
you see here we now have a different
palette and the bars are of different
colors on the x-axis you have the gears
three gear 4 gear or five gear vehicle
and on the y-axis you have the
horsepower
so from the graph you can see
the horsepower is low for vehicles that
have four gears while it is high
for the vehicles that have five gears
now let's understand how to create a
count plot so the count plot function in
the python c bond Library Returns the
count of total values for each category
using bars we will create a count plot
that Returns the total number of
vehicles for each category of cylinders
I'll just give a comment here as
count plot
all right
so I'll start
sns.
I'll use the count plot function
and I'll Define my x axis as
cylinders
my y-axis won't have any label or any
column because y-axis will only show the
count
then I am going to
use my
data parameter or the argument and pass
in my data frame name that is empty cars
let's say I'll set the
palette
to
set one
let me run it
okay there is some error let's debug the
error
says Str object has no attribute get
okay so this should be
without the single quotes
make sure the data frame name is without
the single quotes let's run it again
there you go
so you can see here this is a nice count
plot that shows the number of cylinders
on the x-axis and on the y-axis you have
the count you can see here
there are more number of vehicles that
have eight cylinders and there are
less number of vehicles or cars that
have six cylinders
and actually you can count it as well so
you can see here there are 14 cars that
have 8 cylinders that are 11 cars that
have four cylinders and there are seven
cars that have six cylinders
all right
now moving ahead
the next count plot will show the number
of cars for each carburetor
so for that I'm going to say
sns.
count plot
my x axis will now have
the variable carburetor
LC data equal to empty cars
and
my palette
I'll set it to
set one
or let's say set two now let me run it
you can see it here
on the x axis we have the different
number of carburetors one two three four
six and eight and you can see we have
more number of cars that have 2 and 4
carburetors and there are very few
vehicles that have
six and eight carburetor
cool now moving ahead
so the python c bond Library allows you
to create horizontal count plots where
the feature column is on the y-axis and
the count is on the x axis let me show
you how to create a horizontal count
plot
I'll say SNS Dot
count plot
I am going to Define my y label or the
y-axis as
gear
I'll say data equal to
empty cars and
set my
palette to
let's say rocket
let me run it
okay you see here this is a
horizontal count plot if you compare it
with the above one these were all
vertical
count plot as in the bars where
vertically aligned but here you can see
the bars are all horizontally aligned
and
on the y-axis you have the gear column
and on the x axis you have the count so
if you Mark here properly you can see
there are 15 vehicles with three gears
there are 12 vehicles that have four
gears and there are total five vehicles
with five gear
now you can also create a grouped count
plot using the Hue parameter so the Hue
parameter accepts the column name for
color encoding
now let's build a count plot that shows
the number of cars for each category of
Gears grouped by
the number of cylinders
so we are going to group based on the
number of cylinders let me show you how
to use the Hue parameter for that
I'll say
sns. count plot
in the x-axis I'll have my
gear column
then I am going to pass my Hue parameter
that will have the cylinder column or
the number of cylinders for each vehicle
I'll pass my data frame using the data
argument
as empty cars and say palette
I'll set my palette to set one
let's run it
if I scroll down you see here we have
account plot
on the x-axis you have three four and
five gears of the different vehicles and
for each gear you have the bars that
represent the number of cylinders so for
vehicles that have three gears we have
majority of the vehicles Having Eight
cylinders
similarly for vehicles that have four
gears we have most of the vehicles with
four cylinders
and if you compare for the
cars that have five gears
so we have equal number of vehicles that
have
four and eight cylinders and then
we have
one vehicle that has
six cylinders
cool now moving ahead
so the seabon library supports the dist
plot function that creates the
distribution of any continuous data
let's create the distribution of miles
per gallon of the different vehicles or
the cars
the mpg Matrix measures the total
distance the car can travel per gallon
of fuel so here I'll give
a comment as dist plot which stands for
distribution plot
I'll say SNS Dot
dist plot
I'll pass in my
data frame name that is empty cars
give a period and say
MPG which is my column name
then I am going to
Define the number of bins that I want
let's say 10
and then I'll use the
color argument
and I'll see let's say G which is for
green
let's run it now
there you go
if I scroll down you can see we have a
nice
distribution plot
so these are all histograms and
you can see we have a smooth curve
and this shows the distribution of
miles per gallon that is present in our
data set all right
now moving ahead
you can also create heat Maps using the
c bond Library
so the heat Maps will let you visualize
metrics like data
the values of the variables are
contained in a matrix and are
represented as colors
you can create a correlation heat map
which is a graphical representation of a
correlation Matrix representing the
correlation between different variables
so in our example we'll create a heat
map where you can find the correlation
between each variable in the empty car's
data set
just give a comment as heat map
I'll say SNS and
I'll use the heat map function
I'll pass in my data frame name that is
empty cars followed by
a function called
Corr which is for correlation
then I'll see c bar
is equal to true
so the
c bar argument is used to draw the color
bar
then I'll say
line widths
I'll
pass it as 0.5
let's run it
there you go here you can see we have a
nice heat map and on the right side you
can see the color bar that starts from
minus 0.8 and goes up to plus 0.8 so
this ranges between
-1 and plus 1
and
the bars or the cube you can see that
have
a lighter color have a positive
correlation
and the ones that are
dark have a negative correlation
so for example
you can see here
for cylinder and MPG
the color is really dark which is around
this region minus 0.8 this means when
the number of cylinders in the car
increases your miles per gallon
decreases and this
we also had seen in our first
bar plot this one you can see here
whenever
the number of cylinders increased your
miles per gallon had decreased
and this is what has been depicted
in our correlation map or the heat map
but if you see for
cylinder and displacement there is a
positive correlation
which comes around this
color bar range
similarly there are other features in
the data set for example if you compare
for the weight of the vehicle and
the number of cylinders
there is a positive correlation which
means when the
weight of the vehicle increases the
number of cylinders present in the
vehicle also increases
and the others you can also compare and
find out the correlation based on this
color bar choose from over 300 in-demand
skills and get access to 1000 plus hours
of video content for free visit scale up
by simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more okay now let's
move ahead
the c bond scatter plot function helps
you create plots that can draw
relationships between two continuous
variables so to understand about Scatter
Plots and other plotting functions
henceforth we are going to use Iris plot
data set so let's go ahead and load the
iris flight data set I'll say Irish
equal to so SNS Dot
load underscore
data set
so this is our data set is already
inbuilt into the SNS or the c-bond
library
now we'll go ahead and
print the first five rows from the data
set
there you go
here you can see here
there are total
four feature variables you have the
Supple length Supple width petal length
and petal width of the three species of
flour
that is satosha
Virginia and verticaler
so using this data set we are going to
see the rest of the c bond plotting
functions first let me go ahead and
print the different pieces of flower and
the
count for each of the species of flowers
that we have in our data set
I'll say Irish
within square brackets I'll pass in the
output or the target variable that is
PCS and I'll use the function that is
value underscore counts
let's run it there you go so we have
50 flowers of Sentosa type
again 50 flowers of versicolor species
and then
we have another 50 flowers of type
virginica so there are total 150 flowers
present in our data set
all right
now we'll create a scatter plot to show
the relationship between Supple length
and petal length for different species
of Iris Plus
so I'll say SNS Dot
followed by the
scatter plot function in the x axis I'll
say
Supple length
column
give a comma
I'll pass in my
y-axis with
petal length
then I'll say
data
equal to Iris
now let's run it
you can see here
this is my scatter plot between Supple
length and petal length
now you can classify the different
species of flowers using the Hue
parameter as species in the function
so what I'll do is
I'm going to copy my
above
code I just paste it here
and we are going to edit in this cell
itself
I'll add a last parameter called hue
and this will have my species column
let's run it and see the difference
there you go here you can see
we have a nice scatter plot
the blue dots are for satosha
the orange dots R4 4C color and for
virginica you have the green dots
from this scatter plot you can see that
for virginica flowers the Supple length
and the petal length are higher than
your vertical around
satosha
and this region is completely for status
of Las so you can see that the status of
flowers have
lower Supple length and better length
all right
now you can also
use another
parameter known as the size
that will
differentiate
the different species of flower in terms
of the size of the dots
I'll say size as species
let's run it you can see the result
there you go
so here you can see the
virginica
floss add in Green Dots
the size is small
followed by versicolor with medium sized
dots and then we have satusa whose sizes
large okay
now the python c bond Library lets you
visualize data using pair plots that
produces a matrix of relationship
between each variable in the data set
so let me show you how to create a pair
plot I'll say SNS Dot
peer plot which is the function
then I'll pass in my data frame name
that is Iris
I'll put this
Iris data frame Within
double quotes
and we'll run it
okay there is some error here let's
debug the error
data must be pandas data frame okay
what I'll do is I'll just remove
the double quotes and we'll run it
this might take some time to create the
pair plot so just wait for a while there
you go
here you can see we have a nice pair
plot on the
y-axis you have the
Supple length Supple width petal length
and petal width similarly on the x axis
also you have the same feature columns
all the diagonal plots are histograms
and the rest of the plots are
Scatter Plots so you can convert the
diagonal visuals to
KDE or kernel density estimation plots
and the rest of the Scatter Plots using
the Hue parameter this makes the paid
plot easier to classify each type of
flower so
I'll just copy this
cell of code
paste it here
and
I'll say hue
equal to
species then
I'll say
palette
equal to
set one
let's run it and we'll
see the new pair plot now
this might take some time
there you go
so here you have the paired plot ready
and on the
right side you can see the different
species the red color dots represent
setosa flowers the blue color dots
represent versicolor
and the
green color
dots represent virginica flowers
now if you
look at this graph you will find that
your petal length is the best feature to
classify the three different species of
flowers if the reason being you can see
here
they are very well categorized and they
are separated
all the red dots present here in The
Petal length represents atosa flowers
around this range
all the blue dots represent
versicolor flowers and the green dots
are all
virginica flowers so out of the four
features petal width petal length Supple
width and supple length
you can take better length as the best
feature to
differentiate between the three species
of flowers
all right now
coming to LM plot function
so the LM plot function in the C born
Library draws a linear relationship as
determined through regression for
continuous variables
so let's create the plot to show the
relationship between petal length and
petal width of the different species of
Iris flowers
I'll just give a comment here as
LM plot
I'll say SNS Dot
in the x axis we'll have
better length
give a comma in the y axis
I'll pass in
petal width
and I'll pass in my data frame using the
data argument or parameter which is Iris
let's run it
you can see it here
we have a nice
plot
the line you see here is a linear
regression line
now in this LM plot you can use the Hue
parameter to differentiate between each
species of flowers and you can set
markers
for different species let me show you
how to do it
I'll say SNS Dot
LM plot
we'll say X
as our
petal length
give a comma
I'll write y
as
petal
width
then I am going to pass the Hue
parameter
in here I'll say
my column as PCS
then I'll give data equal to
my data set name that is Iris and now
you can pass in
markers argument
to differentiate the different
types of flaws let's say I want to
represent setosa with
dot or o
then my next species which is versicolor
should be represented with a
star symbol
and the final
virginica species of flowers should be
represented with let's say this Arrow
mark
now let me go ahead and run it
there you go
you have three different
linear regression lines
and the circle dots in blue color
represent satosha
the orange color stars represent
versicolor flowers and
the triangles represent virginica
flowers so this is how you create
a linear relationship between the
different
types of flowers using the regression
line all right
now let's
take a look at the final plotting
function
where we will create a box plot
a box plot also known as a box and
whisker plot depicts the distribution of
quantitative data the Box represents the
quartiles of the data set
the whiskers show the rest of the
distribution except for the outliers
now let's see the distribution of the
three species of flowers
based on their Supple width
I'll just give a comment as box plot
is the final plot that we are going to
see in our c bond
demo
I'll say sns.box plot
in the x axis we'll have the species
column
in the y axis we'll have
supple
width
then I'll pass my
data
as Iris
let's run it
there you go
we have this box plot created
at the bottom in the x axis you can see
we have
the box plot for
Sentosa flowers
orange for vertical flowers and green
for virginica flowers
now this line represents
median which is inside the Box
so this is also the median for vertical
Applause you can compare the
median sepal width for each of the
flowers from the y axis
this line represents the
maximum
Supple width value for cetusa flour
and this line at the bottom represents
the minimum
length of the Supple width or cetusa
Plus
now these dots that you see outside the
box plot are called as outliers
the extended lines that are outside the
box plot are known as whiskers
all right
so that brings us to the end of this
demo session on
seabon
librarian python so first we imported
our empty cast dataset
then we saw how to create a bar plot
we learned how to use the color argument
or the parameter inside bar plot
we also saw how to use the palette
attribute or the palette parameter
then we learned about
creating count plots
then we saw how to create horizontal
count plot
now moving ahead
we saw how to create distribution plot
then we saw
correlation heat map
after that we analyzed the other
functions
such as the scatter plot
then we had the pair plot
and we had the
LM plot for
finding the linear relationship and
later we saw the
box plot using the iris flood data set
if you are one of the aspiring python
Enthusiast looking for online training
and graduating from the best
universities for a professional who
elicits to switch careers in Python
while learning from the experts and try
giving a show to Simply learn's
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning in collaboration with Purdue
University and IBM the course link is
mentioned in the description box below
that will navigate you to the course
page where you can find a complete
overview of the program being offered so
let's start with
multi-dimensional array object and tools
for working with arrays and I'll go a
step further and say there are so many
other modules in Python built on numpy
so the fundamentals of numpy are so
important to latch onto for the python
so you can understand the other modules
and what they're doing numpy's main
object is a multi-dimensional array it's
a table of elements usually numbers all
of the same type indexed by a tuple of
position integers in numpy dimensions
are called axes take a one-dimensional
array or we have remember dimensions are
also called axes you can say this is the
first axis 0 1 2 3 4 5. and you can see
down here it has a shape of six why
because there's six different elements
in it in the one dimension array and
they usually denote that as six comma
with an empty note on there and then we
have a two dimensional array where you
can see zero one two three four five six
seven and in here we have two axes or
two dimensions and the shape is two four
so if you were looking at this as a
matrix or another mathematical functions
you can see there's all kinds of
importance on shape we're not going to
cover shape today but we will cover that
in part two did you know that numpy's
array class is called ND array for numpy
data array now we're going to take a
detour here because we're working in
Python and two of my favorite Tools in
Python is the Jupiter notebook and then
I like to use that sitting on top of
anaconda and if you flip over to
jupiter.org that's j u p e y t e r dot
org you can go in here you can install
it off of here if you don't want to use
the Anaconda notebook but this is the
Jupiter setup the documentation on the
Jupiter Jupiter opens up in your web
browser that's what makes it so nice is
this portable the files are saved on
your computer they do run an IPython or
iron Python and you can create all kinds
of different environments in there which
I'll show you in just a minute I myself
like to use Anaconda that's
www.anaconda.com if you install Anaconda
it will install the jupyter notebook
with the Anaconda separate and you can
install Jupiter notebook and it'll run
completely separate from anaconda's
Jupiter notebook and you can see here
I've now opened up my anaconda Navigator
what I like about the Navigator and this
is a fresh install on a new computer
which is always nice I can launch my
Jupiter notebook from in here I can
bring other tools so the Anaconda does a
lot more and under environments I only
have the one environment and I can open
up the terminal specific to this
environment this one happens to have
python 37 in it the most current version
as of this tutorial and then you open a
terminal if you're going to do your pip
installs and stuff like that for
different modules you can also create
different environments in here so maybe
you need a python36 python35 you can see
we're having a nice framework like
Anaconda really helps so you don't have
to chat track that on your own in the
Jupiter notebook in your different
Jupiter notebook setups we'll go ahead
and launch this Jupiter notebook and
then I've set my browser window for a
deep fault of chrome so it's going to
open up in Chrome and you can see here
this opens up a folder on my computer we
have a couple different options on here
remember I set the environment up as
python 3.7 you would install any
additional modules that aren't already
installed in your python on this and it
keeps them separate so you do have to
for each environment install the
separate modules so they match the
environment on there and in here we have
a couple things we can look up what's
running do you have your different
clusters again this is I just installed
this on a new machine so I just have the
one a couple things in here that were
run on here recently and what we go on
here is we then have on the upper right
new and from the pull down menu you'll
see python3 and this will open up a new
window
and now we're in Jupiter python so this
is a python window and we'll just do a
print
and this of course is this little hello
world
and we'll run that and it prints out
hello world in the command line there's
a couple special things you have to know
we're not going to do today which is on
Graphics if you've never seen this
one of the things you can do is you can
also do a equals hello world and if you
just put the a in there now if you do a
bunch of these we have a equals hello
world b equals goodbye world and you put
a b a then return B it'll only run the
last one but you can see here if you put
the variable down here it will show you
what's in that variable
and that has to do with the Jupiter
notebook inline coding so that's not
basic python that's just jupyter
notebook shorthand which you'll see in a
little bit so back to our numpy numpy
array versus python list python list
being the basic list in your python why
should we use numpy array when we have
python list well first it's fast the
numpy array has been optimized over
years and years by multiple programmers
and it's usually very quick compared to
the basic python list setup it's
convenient so it has a lot of
functionality in there that's not in the
basic python list and it also uses less
memory so it's optimized both for Speed
and memory use and let's go ahead and
jump into our Jupiter notebook since
we're coding best way to learn coding is
to code just like the best way to learn
how to write is write and the best way
to learn how to cook is cook so let's do
some coding here today and just like any
modules we have to import numpy we
almost always import it as NP that is
such a standard so you'll see that very
commonly we can just run that and now we
have access to our numpy module inside
our Python and then the most common
thing of course is to go and create a
number array and in here we can send it
a regular list
and so we'll go ahead and send this a
regular array let's go one two three to
make it simple and then I'm just going
to type in a and we'll run this
and so you can see down here the output
is an array of one two three and we
could also do
print just a reminder that this is an
inline command so that wouldn't work if
you're using a different editor you can
see that it's an array one two three but
we'll go and leave it as a
kind of a nice feature so you can see
what you're doing really quick in the
jupyter notebook and just like all your
other standard arrays I can go a of zero
which is going to be a value of one of
course we do a of one you go all the way
through this
if one has a value of 2 in it so whether
using the numpy array or the basic
python list that's going to be the same
that should all look pretty familiar and
be pretty straightforward remember the
first value is always zero
and when we set on there so let's take a
look why we're using numpy because we
went over the slide a little bit but
let's just take a look and see what that
actually looks like and what we want to
look at is the fact that it's fast
convenient and uses less memory so let's
take a glance at that in code and see
what that actually looks like when we're
writing it in Python and what the
differences are
and to do this I'm going to go ahead and
import a couple other modules we're
going to import the time module so we
can time it and we're going to import
the system module so that we can take a
look at how much memory it uses and
we'll go and just run those so those are
imported and so we'll do b equals a
range of one yeah 1000 is fine
and so that's going to create a list of
100 0 to 999 remember it starts at zero
and it stops right at the 1000 without
actually going to the 1000. and let's go
ahead and print
and we want system dot get size of
and we'll pick any integer because we
have you know zero to a thousand we'll
just throw one in there five it doesn't
matter because it's gonna whatever
integer we put in there is going to
generate the same value because looking
the size of how how much memory it
stores an integer in
and then we want to have the link of the
B that's how many integers are in there
and if we go ahead and execute this and
run this in a line we'll see Oops I did
that wrong comma if we multiply them
together
we'll see it generates 28 000. so that's
the size we're looking at is twenty
eight thousand I believe that's bytes
that sounds about right
so let's go ahead and create this in
numpy and we'll go with C equals NP and
this is a range
so that's the numpy command to do the
same thing that we were just doing in a
list
and we'll also use the same value on
there the 1000
. once we've created the C value of C
for NP dot a range let's go ahead and
print and we can do that by doing C dot
size
times C dot item size
well that's very similar we did before
we did get the size of so the C size is
the size of the array and each item size
just reversed so the size of an integer
five item size is going to be the
integers and C size now let's just take
a look and see what that generates
and wow okay we got 4 000 versus 28 000.
that's a significant difference in
memory how much memory we're using with
the array and then let's go ahead and
take a look at speed let's do oh let's
do size we trade this with lower values
and it would happen so fast that the
npra kept coming up with zero
because it just rounded it off so size
and let's create an L1
Bulls range of size
and we'll do an L2
I'll just set up to the same thing it's
also range
of size on there there we go
and then we can do on A1
equals NP Dot
a range size
and then let's do an A 2 equals NP dot a
range we'll keep it the same size
and what we're going to do is we're
going to take these two different arrays
and we're going to perform some basic
functions on them but let's go ahead
actually just load these up now we'll go
ahead and run this so those are all set
in memory
except for the typo here
quickly fix that
there we go so these are now all loaded
in here and let's do a start equals
time dot time
so it's just going to look at my clock
time and see what time it is and it will
do result equals and let's do oh let's
say we got an array and we're going to
say
let's do some addition here X Plus y
for X comma y
in and we'll zip it up here
two different arrays so here's our two
different arrays we're going to multiply
each of the individual things on here L1
L2
there we go so that should add up each
value so L1 plus L2 each value in each
array
and then we want to go ahead and print
and let's say python list took
and then we'll do
time
dot time
we'll just subtract the start out of
there so time whoops I messed up on some
of the quotation marks on there
okay there we go
time minus the start
and we'll convert that to seconds so
we'll go to this in milliseconds or
times 1000.
and let's hit the run on there it's kind
of fun because you also get a view while
we're doing this of some ways to
manipulate the script
and as you can see also my bad typing
there we go okay so we'll go ahead and
run this
and we can see here that the python list
took 34
actually I have to go back and look at
the conversion on there but you can see
it takes roughly 0.34 of a second and we
can go ahead and print the result in
here too
let's do that
and we'll run that just so you can see
what the what kind of data we're looking
at
and we have the zero two four six eight
so it's just adding them together it
looks pretty straightforward on there
and if we scroll down to the bottom of
the answer again we see python list took
46 a little different time on there
depending on what um core because I have
this is on an eight core computer so it
just depends on what course running on
what else is pulling on the computer at
the time and let's go back up here and
do our start time paste that into here
and this time we're going to do a result
equals and this is really cool notice
how elegant this is It's So
straightforward this is a lot of reason
people started using numpy is because it
can add the two arrays together by
simply going A1 Plus A2 makes a lot of
sense both looking at it and a system
very
convenient remember this slide we're
looking at fast convenient and less
memory so look how convenient that is
really easy to read real easy to see and
I don't know if we don't need to print
the result again so let's just go ahead
and print the time on here and we'll
borrow this from the top part
because I really am a lazy type
this isn't the python list this is the
numpy list or numpy array
and let's go ahead and see how that
comes out and we get 2.99 so let's take
a look at these two numbers 46 versus
2.99 so we'll just round this up to
three that's a huge difference that's
that's like more than 10 times faster
that's like 15 times roughly at a quick
glance I'd have to go do the math to
look at it and it's going to vary a
little bit depending on what's running
in the background the computer obviously
so we've looked at this and if we go
back here we found out it's much faster
yes there's different going to be
different speeds depending on what
you're doing with the array very
convenient easy to read and it uses less
memory so that's the core of the numpy
that's why a lot of people base so many
other modules on numpy and why it's so
widely used
so we did glance at a couple operations
when we were looking at speed and size
let's dive into a little bit more into
the basic operations
and these are always nice to see I mean
certainly you want to go get a cheat
sheet if you're using it for the first
time you know look things up Google is
your friend we did this where the most
basic numpy dot array or NP dot array
and we'll go ahead and create an array
let's do pairs one comma two
and then let's do a three comma four and
if we do that let's do five comma six
there you go and if we go ahead and take
this and run this I can go ahead and do
our a down here so it's in line it'll
print that out
you can see it makes a nice array for us
so we have a and if you look at that we
have three different objects each with
two values in them and hopefully you're
starting to think well how many
dimensions or indexes is that and you'll
see three by two so let's go ahead and
take a look and let's go how about a dot
in Dimensions speaking of which we'll
run that and we have two dimensions for
each object
and then we can do the item size so a
DOT we saw this earlier we looked up how
many items it was up here where we
wanted to multiply item size times the
actual size of the object so the memory
is being used versus the item size
and we should see four there
memory is compressed down that's always
a good thing
and then the shape the shape is so
important when you're working with data
science and you're moving it from one
format to another
so we have our shape we just talked
about that we have three by two three
rows by two objects in each one
generally I don't look too much at the
size but the dimensions I'm always
looking up this is nice you can automate
it so you might be converting something
you might need to know how many
dimensions are going into the next
machine learning package so that you can
automatically just have it send that
information over
so we looked at a shape let's go and
create a slightly different array NP dot
array let's go ahead and just do as our
original
set up here
and one of the features we can do which
is really important is we can do D type
equals in this case let's do NP
float 64. and so what we've done is
converting all of these into a float and
we type in a
and now instead of having one two three
four five six you see they're all float
values 1.0 there's no actually 0 in
there just there's a one dot or the one
period two three period four period five
period six period
and this again data science I don't know
how many times I've had to convert
something from an integer to a float so
it's going to work correctly in the
model I'm using so very common features
to be aware of and to be able to get
around and use
and we'll also do let's just curiosity
item size
we'll go and run that
and we see that it doubled in size so
it's not a huge increase well doubling
is always a big increase in computers
but it's not a huge increase compared to
what it would be if you're running this
in the python list format
and then we did the shape earlier
without having it set to the float 64.
let's go ahead and do a shape with it
set to 64. and it should be the same
three common two so it all matches so
we've gone through and remember if you
really if this is all brand new to you
according to the Cambridge study at the
Cambridge University if you're learning
a brand new word in a foreign language
the average person has to repeat it 163
times before it's memorized
so a lot of this you build off of it so
hopefully you don't have to repeat it
163 times but we did manage to repeat it
at least twice here if not a little bit
more and let's go ahead and take this
we're going to go look at one more setup
on here and let me just take this last
statement here on the converting our
properties of our data and instead of
float 64
let's do complex let's just see what
that looks like and let's go ahead and
print that out and run it
and so we now have a complex data set up
and you'll see it's denoted by the one
dot plus 0 dot j
and if we flip over here and do a basic
search for numpy data types better to go
to the original web page but pull up a
bunch of these you can see there's a
whole list of different numpy data types
shorthand complex we have complex
complex 64 complex 128 complex number
represented by 264-bit floats real and
imaginary components
one option on there float 16 float 32
float shorthand for float 64 most
commonly used and of course all the
different ones that you can possibly put
into your numpy array so we covered a
basic Edition up there we're comparing
how fast it runs but some very basic
components how to set up a numpy array
how many dimensions it has item size
data type item again we went to item
size and there's also the
shape probably one of the more used I
used a shape all the time very commonly
used
and then down here you can see where we
actually created a numpy complex data
type
so let's look at some other features in
numpy one of them is you could do numpy
Dot
zeros
and we're going to do three comma four
there we go and we'll go ahead and run
this and you can see if I do NP dot
zeros I create an empty array of zeros
this is really important I was building
my own neural network and I needed to
create an array where I initialized the
weights and I want them all to be the
same weight in this case I want them to
start off with zero for the particular
project I was working on and there's
other options that you can do mp1s
and we'll do the same thing three comma
four we'll run that and you can see I've
created a an array of numpy ones in this
case it comes out as a float array
and this is an interesting to note
because we have let's go back to our
Python and do L Range Five
and we'll print the L so there's our
list and if I run that
it doesn't create the range and tell
after the fact until you actually
execute it that's an upgrade in python
python 27 actually created the array
zero one two three four this one
actually creates the script and then
once it's used it then actually
generates the array and if we do that in
numpy a Range remember that from before
and if we do a numpy a range 5
and let's do a
l or we can just leave it as numpy
that's right there we go just run that
you can see there we actually get an
array 0 1 2 3 4 for the value of the
numpy arrange a range five generates the
actual array
and for part one we're going to do just
one more section on basic setup
and we're going to concatenation
concatenation out example
there we go we're gonna do strings let's
take a look at strings and what's going
on with there and let's do
oh let's see print
Let's do an NP character something new
here and we're going to add and then
here's our brackets for what we're going
to add
oh and let's say
um let's do
hello
comma High
and in the brackets on there let's
create another one
and this one's going to be
ABC and we'll do
x y z so we're just creating some
randomly making sum up on here and then
we'll go ahead and just print this
if we run that and come down here and of
course make sure all your brackets are
open and closed correctly and then you
can see in here when we concatenate the
example in numpy it takes the two
different arrays that we set up in there
and it combines the hello with the ABC
and the high with x y z
and if we can also do something like
print oh let's do NP character dot
multiply so there's a lot of different
functions in here again you can look
these up it's probably good to look them
all up and see what they are but it's
good to also just see them in action
let's do hello space comma three
and we'll run this one
and run that without the error and
you'll see it does hello hello hello so
we multiplied it by three and we can
also let's just take this whole thing
here instead of retyping it
and we can do character Center so
instead of multiply this to Center
and over here keep our hello going
to space out of there and let's do
Center it 20.
and fill character
equals we'll fill it with dashes
so if we run this
you can see it prints out the hello with
dashes on each side and we keep going
um with that we can also in addition to
doing the fill function we can play with
capitalize we can title we can do
lowercase we can do uppercase we can
split split line strip join these are
all the most common ones and let's go
ahead and just look at those and see
what those look like each one of them
so we're going to do the hello world
all-time favorite of mine I always like
to say Hello Universe and you can see
here we do Capital H with the world but
so we want to capitalize so capitalize
is the first one in the array so we get
Hello World on there and we can also
take this and instead of capitalizing
another feature in here is title and
let's just change this to how are we
doing
how are you doing instead are we able to
do you and let's run that
and you can see here because we created
it as a title it capitalizes the first
letter in each word
and in this one we're going to do
character lower
two different examples here we have an
array we have Hello World all
capitalized and we have just hello and
you can see that one is an array and one
is just a string if we run that you get
a an array with Hello World lowercase
and hello lowercase and if we're going
to do it that way we can also do it the
opposite way there's also upper
and let's paste those in there and you
can see here we have character Dot Upper
opposite there
python.data and we'll do python is easy
hopefully you're starting to get the
picture that most of the Python and the
scripting is very simple it's when you
put the bigger picture together and
starts building these puzzles and
somebody asks you hey I need the first
letter capitalized unless it's the title
and then we have you start realizing
that this can get really complicated so
numpy just makes it simple and we like
that and so in this case we did python
data it's all uppercase python is easy
like like shouting in your messenger
python is easy and then if you're ever
processing text and tokenizing it a lot
of times the first thing you do is we
just split the text and we're just going
to run this in P dot character.split are
you coming to the party if we do that it
returns an array of each of the
individual words are you coming to the
party splitting it by the spaces
and then if you're going to split it by
spaces we also need to know how to split
it by lines
and just like we have the basic split
command we also have split lines hello
and you'll see here the scoop in for our
new line
and when we run that if you're following
the split part with the words you should
see hello how are you doing the two
different lines are now split apart
and let's just review three more before
we wrap this up commonly used string
variable manipulations we have strip and
in this case we have Nina admin Anita
and we're going to strip a off of there
let's see what that looks like and then
you end up with nin dominate it
basically takes up all leading and
trailing letters in this case we're
looking for a more common would be a
space in there but it might also be
punctuation or anything like that that
you need to remove from your letters and
words and if we're going to strip and
clean data we also need to be able to
reformat it or join it together so you
see here we have a character joined
we'll go ahead and run this
and it has on the first one it splits
you so letters up by the colon and the
second one by the dash and you can see
how this is really useful if you're
processing in this case a date we have
day month year year month date very
common things to have to always switch
around and manipulate depending on what
they're going into what you're working
with
and finally let's look at one last
character string we're going to do
replace if you're doing misinformation
this is good pulling news articles
replacing is and what in this case we're
just doing his a good dancer and we're
going to replace is with was
and you can see here he was a good
dancer hopefully that's not because he
had a bad fall he just was from like you
know 1920s and it's gotten old
so there we go we've covered a lot of
the basics in numpy as far as creating
an array very important stuff here when
you're feeding it in how do we know the
shape of it the size of it what happens
when we convert it from a regular
integer into a float value as far as how
much space it takes we saw that that
doubled it item size you have your in
dimensions and probably the most used is
shape I will cover more on shape in part
two so make sure you join us on part two
because there's a lot of important
things on shaping in there and setting
them up we also saw that you can create
a zeros based array you can create one
with ones if we do a range you can see
how it is a lot easier to use to create
its own range or a range as it is in
numpy you saw how easy it was to add two
arrays we saw that earlier just plus
sign then we got into doing strings and
working with strings and how to
concatenate so if you have two different
arrays of strings you can bring them
together we also saw how you can fill so
you can add a nice headline dash dash
dash we saw about capitalize the first
letter we saw about turning it into a
title so all the first letters are
capitalized doing lowercase on all the
letters upper for all the letters just
lower and upper nice abbreviation we
also covered how to split the character
set how to strip it so if you want to
strip all the A's out from leading A's
and ending A's or spaces you can do that
very easily also how to join the data
sets so here's a character join option
for your strings and finally we did the
character replace now let's go ahead and
dive in there since we're going right
into part two which is getting some
coding going under our belt and here in
our Jupiter notebook we can go under new
and create a new folder python3 I think
I forgot to do this last time but we
could just do the control plus plus
which in any browser enlarges a page
makes it a lot easier to see always a
nice feature another beautiful benefit
of using jupyter notebook and let me go
ahead and show you a neat thing can do
in Jupiter this is nice if you're
working with people and you're doing
this as a demo on a large screen I'm
going to do the hashtag or pound symbol
array manipulation kind of a title that
we're working on and then I'm going to
call this cell cell type markdown as
opposed to code and you'll see it
highlights it here and then if I run it
it just turns it into array manipulation
and then we're specifically going to be
working on array manipulation changing
shape to start with and we'll go ahead
and Mark this cell also a markdown so
has a nice little look there and then it
comes up and you can see it just like I
said it just highlights it it makes it
very bold print just making it easier to
read not a python thing but a Jupiter
thing that's good to know about
especially if you're working with the
shareholders since they're investing
money in you of course the first thing
you want to do is import we're going to
import numpy
as in p and that should be standard by
now by now you you start a Python
program you're doing some data science
numpy is just something you bring in
there and let's go ahead and create our
array and we're going to do that as the
NP dot a range remember that's uh zero
well we're going to do 0 to 9.
and uh we'll print
a little title on the original array
we'll just print that array a remember
from the first lesson so we have our
array which is zero one two three four
five six seven eight and let's add a
print space in between
let's create a second array B but we
want this to reshape array a and what
does that mean
and the command is simply reshape and
then we have nine items in here and this
is so important right now so be very
aware if I did some weird numbers in
here it's not going to work
and we want multiples of nine we know
that three times three is nine so we're
going to reshape our a array by 3 by 3
and then we're going to print well let's
give it a title oops I had too many
brackets in there modified array and
then let's go ahead and print
RB and let's see what that looks like
and as we come down here you can see
we've taken this and it's gone from 0 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 to an array of arrays and
we have 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8. and so we
split this into three by three and you
can guess that if I tried to reshape
this let's just do a five by three which
is 15. that's going to give me an error
so it's not going to work you're not
going to reshape something unless the
shape all the the data in there matches
correctly
so we can take this nine this flat 9 and
we call it a flex it's just a single
array and we can reshape it into a three
by three array and first you might think
matrixes which this is used for that
definitely I use it a lot in graphing
because it'll come in that I have an
array that's X Y comma X Y one white one
comma X2 Y2 and so the shape of it might
be two by the length of the number of
points and I need to separate that into
X flat array and a y flat array and you
can see this can be very easy to reshape
the array doing that and we can of
course go back we can do B and print
and we'll do B dot platin remember I
said it's called a flatten array
and if we run that you'll see this goes
back to the original one it takes this
zero one two three four five six seven
eight and flattens it back to a single
array
and then one other feature to be aware
of is if we flatten it one of the
commands we can put in there is order
let me just go ahead and do that order
equals
F strangely enough F stands for Fortran
they hold fourtran days I remember
actually studying Fortran programming
language in this case you'll see that it
uses the first like zero three six is
the order so instead of flattening it
like we had before zero one two three
four five six seven eight it now does
zero three six one four seven two five
eight and if you go to the numpy array
page you can see here that they have the
flatten and you just open up the numpy
and D array flatten setup to look it up
and they have three different options
they have c f and a and it's whether to
flatten in C which was based on how the
C code works for flattening originally
worked which is row major
Fortran which is column major or
preserve the column Fortran ordering
from a so whatever it was in the default
is the C version so the default that you
saw you could put orders equals c and
it'd have the same effect as we saw
there before you could even do order
equals a that would also have the same
effect because that's the default so
really the only other thing you need to
change on here is to change it to C if
you need it and you can see right here
or F I mean not C the only thing you
really want to change it to is to your f
for the Fortran order which then does it
by column versus by row and let's look
at here we go reshape so let's create a
range of 12
and let's reshape it
I will do 4 comma 3 for this one and
remember this is numpy I forgot the NP
there
NP dot arrange
and we can type in just a for print or
you can do full print a and of course a
jupyter notebook you even have a little
extra print at the beginning we run this
we'll see we create a nice array of 0 1
2 it's reshaped it so we have four rows
and three columns or you could call that
three columns and four rows zero one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven
but this one is so important we'll do NP
transpose
a let's go ahead and run that
and it helps if I get all the s's in
there and don't leave an S out and
you'll see here we've taken our array if
you remember correctly we had 0 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 and we've swapped it so
we've gone from a three by four or a
four by three to a three by four
and this really helps if you're looking
at like a huge number of rows and the
data all comes in like let's say this is
your features in row one your features
in row two and this is x y z well when
you go to plot it you send it all of X
in one array all of one another one
array and all Z in another array
it's really important that we can
transpose this rather quickly
this is kind of a fun thing I can
highlight it and do brackets around it
if you remember correctly
because we're in Jupiter it doesn't
matter where we do the print or not
it'll automatically print it for us and
you see if I hit the Run button it comes
up at the same exact thing
and let's play with the reshape and you
don't want to zoom this up a little bit
here
make that even bigger so you can really
see what's going on and let's play with
the reshape just a little bit more we'll
do b equals
in P dot a range let's do eight
reshape we'll do two comma four
let's go ahead and print B
and then run that and you'll see we have
now the two rows this is a bit more like
so we have four maybe two rows of four
things so this might be all of our X
components and our y components so we
can switch it back and forth real easy
important to note here whether we do two
comma four or in the case of four comma
three this has 12 elements and so
however you split it up it's got to
equal 12. so 4 times 3 equals 12 that's
pretty straightforward same thing down
here 2 times 4 equals eight if I change
this and let's say I do two comma three
let's just run that in and you'll find
we get an error because you can't split
8 up into two rows by three
you have to pick something that it can
split up and arrange it in so let's go
ahead and run that and just for fun
let's go um
reshape our B again if I can type
reshape our B again and what else goes
into eight well we could do two by two
by two
so we can take this out to three
different dimensions
and then if of course if we um because
this is going to come out you as a
variable we can just go ahead and run it
and it'll print it we can also do a
print statement on there just like we
did before and you'll see we have two
different groups of two variables of two
different dimensions so two by two by
two and let's go ahead and assign this
to a variable C equals B reshaped and
let's do something a little different
let's roll the axes roll
axes
and we'll take our C and do two comma
one
and if we go ahead and run this it's
going to print that out whoops
hit a wrong button there let's do that
one again and you roll the axis and you
can see that we now have a set of zero
one two three four five six seven we now
have the zero two one three four six
five seven
so what's going on here we're taking and
we're rolling the numbers around and
let's just simplify this we'll just do
it with C comma 1 and run that and so if
we roll a single axis you get 0 1
and then it rolled the four five up and
then we have two three six seven and if
we do two let me see what happens there
and this is one of those things you
really have to play with and start
feeling what it's doing
we've now taken 0 2 4 6 1 3 5 7. so you
can see we've now rolled by two digits
instead of rolling the one set up we now
rolled two digits up there and so if we
go back and we do the one
so we've rolled it up zero one four five
and then we're going to take the 2 in
there and we've rolled the 0 1 2 3 4 5
and 6 7. so we start rolling these
things around on here there's a lot of
different things you can do on this
what's another way to manipulate the
numbers on your numpy
and finally let's go ahead and swap
axes we'll do c and let's just go ahead
and run that it's going to error on
there
that's because it requires a multiple
arguments left out the arguments so now
we can swap them we get the zero two one
three four six five seven so you can see
everything's been swapped around
so next thing we want to go over is we
want to go over numpy arithmetic
operations
how can we take these and use these let
me just go ahead and put this cell as a
markdown there we go we'll run that so
it has a nice thing all right nice title
on there that's always helpful
and let's start by creating two arrays
we'll do a as an EP NP
range a range nine and let's reshape
this
three by three so by now you should be
saying this reshape stuff and this
should all look pretty familiar we have
our zero one two three four five six
seven eight on there and let's create a
second one B okay this time instead of
doing a range let's do NP array we'll
just create a straight up array
and we'll do an array of three objects
so it's going to be three by one and if
we go ahead and print a b out let me run
that this is actually pretty common to
have something like this where you have
a three by whatever it is in a three by
by three array when you're doing your
math you kind of have that kind of setup
on there
and what we can do is we can go
P dot add a b don't forget we can always
put a print statement on there so if we
add it you'll see that it just comes in
there and it goes okay we're adding 10
to everything and we could actually do
something more oh make it more
interesting 11 10 11 12. so let's change
B's now 10 11 12 and let's run that
and you can see that we have 10 and then
you had 1 plus 11 is 12. 2 plus 12 is 14
13 so 10 plus 3 is 13 11 plus 4 is 15
and 12 plus 5 is 17 and so on
we'll put this back since that's how the
original setup was let's do 10 by 10 by
10 and run that and run that and get the
original answer and if you're going to
add them together we need to go ahead
and subtract
a b
and we run that
we get minus 10 minus 9 minus 8 just
like you would expect so we have our
subtraction 0 minus 10 is minus ten and
so on and if you're going to add and
subtract you can guess what the next one
is we're going to multiply
and we'll multiply
a b
and this should be pretty
straightforward you should expect this
if we multiply 10 times 0 we got 0 10
times 10 is 10 and so on
and finally if you're going to multiply
let's
all odd is divide
what happens when you do divide a by B
and we run this
we're going to get 0 and this is 0
divided by 10 is 0 1 divided by 10 is
0.1 2 divided by 10 is 0.2 and so on and
so on so that math is pretty
straightforward it just makes it very
easy to do the whole setup and again if
we went this and let's say well let's
change this up up here instead of 10 we
do a hundred
and make this a thousand there we go if
we run that and then we do the add you
can see we got 10 plus 100 plus a
thousand same thing with the subtract
same thing with the multiply
then you can also see the same thing
here with the Divide so a lot of control
there with your array and your math
again let's set this back to 10 oops
it's right up here wrong section
there we go 10 and we'll just go ahead
and run these and get back to where we
were
and this brings us to our next section
which is slicing and let's put in our
just make this a cell
of course it gives us a nice looking
slicing there and slicing means we're
just going to take sections of the array
so let's create an array NP a range
let's just do 20.
and if remember if we do a we have a 0
to 19.
and then we can do a and remember we can
always print these this can always be
put in a print but because I'm in
Jupiter if you're doing a demo in
Jupiter that is it's just so great that
you have all these controls on here so
we could slice four on and this should
look familiar because this is the same
as a python and a lot of other different
scripting languages if we do four we'll
go 0 1 2 3 as the first four in the
thing and the skip sum and starts with
this one the first four are skipped then
from there on you can also do the
opposite
and go till the fourth one if we run
that we get 0 1 2 3 quite the opposite
on there we can do a single item so we
can pick object number five on the list
run that and five happens to be five
because that's the order they're in and
then this one's interesting because I
can do s equals slice
and let's create a slice here and let's
do two comma 9 comma
yeah let's leave a 2 on there so we'll
create an S Slice on here and then if we
take our array and we do array of s
we're taking our slice in there and
let's go ahead and run that and let's
take a look and see what it generated
here first off we started with two so we
have two at the beginning we're going to
end at 9 which happens to be eight so it
stops before the nine remember when
we're doing arrays in Python and then we
step two so two four six eight we could
do this as three let me run that and you
can see how that changes two five eight
and we could do this as let's leave this
at three and if we change this to 10
oops
12. there we go and we run that we have
2 5 8 11. so that's pretty
straightforward it's a very nice feature
to have on here where you can slice it
and take different parts of the series
right out of the middle so now that
we've accessed the different pieces of
our array and let's get into iterating
iteration and this is interesting
because my sister who runs a college
data science division is first question
she asks is how do you go through data
and she's asking can you do you know how
to iterate through data do you know how
to do a basic for Loop do you know how
to go through each piece of the data and
in numpy they have some cool controls
for that just sends a mark down there we
go and run it
and it's called the nditter
sure what the ND stands for but ND it or
for iterator
so before we do that though let's create
an array or something we can actually
iterate through we'll call it a equals
NP a range let's do something a little
funny here or funky
and we'll do 0 45 5. I'm not sure why
the guys in the back pick this
particular one was kind of a fun one and
if I run that we do this you can see um
we get 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40. that's
what this array looks like
and this is from our slice you could
this is just a slice that's all that is
is we created a slice of 0 45 0 to 45
step five and so we can do with this we
can also do a equals V shape let's go
ahead and take and reshape this and
since there's nine variables in there
we'll do a reshape at three by three so
if we run that oops miss something there
that is the a that really helps so if we
do the a reshape and we'll go ahead and
print that out we get 0 5 10 15 20 25 30
35 40. and then we simply do 4X in
our numpy ND enter of a
colon and we'll just go ahead and print
X and let's see what happens here when
we run through this and we print each
one of those
it goes all the way through the whole
array so it's the same thing we just saw
before we got 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40.
so it prints out each object in the
array so you can go through and view
each one of these
and certainly if you remember you could
also flatten the array and just do for a
and that also and get the same result
there's a lot of ways to do this but
this is the proper way with the ND
iterator because it'll minimize the
amount of resources needed to go through
each of the different objects in the
numpy array
and hopefully you asked this question
when I just did that
and the question is how can I change
this instead of doing each object so
first of all let's go ahead and take my
cell type Mark that down run it and so
we're going to work on iteration order C
Style
style C because it came from the C
programming and that's because it came
from the old Fortran programming so
let's give us a reminder I will do a
print a and we'll do four x n n p
iterate a but we also want to do this in
a specific order and you know what I'm a
really lazy typer so let's go back up
here
this is the ND iterator I know I'm
missing the ND part of a let's do order
equals
C we'll print X on there and let's do
that again and this time order
equals
f
let me go order equals F let's go ahead
and run this
and see what happens here and the first
thing you're going to notice our
original array 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40.
when we do order C that's the default 0
5 10 15 20 and so on and then when you
come down here
you'll see F order f is 0 15 30. so it
takes the first digit of each of the sub
arrays or the second dimension and then
it goes into the second one 520 35 10 25
40. so slightly different order for
iterating through it if you need to do
that so we've covered reshaping we
covered math we've covered iteration
we've covered a number of things the
next section we want to go ahead and go
over
is going to be joining arrays so we need
to bring them together let me go ahead
and take the cell and make it a markdown
cell type markdown there we go and run
that so let's work on joining arrays so
we can bring them together and what
different options we have
and let's do we'll do an NP array one
two comma three four
we'll go ahead and print
oops
first
these Rays aren't that big so let's just
go ahead and keep it all on one line a
if we run this first array one two three
four whoops I forgot that it
automatically wraps it when you do it
this way so we'll go ahead and keep it
separate
print a there we go and let's go ahead
and do a b
and we'll do five six seven eight and
notice I'm keeping the same shape on
these two arrays depending on what
you're doing those shapes have to match
let's go ahead and print
second array
print
B go and run that that's
missed something up there let me fix
that real quick
and I was reformatting it to go on
separate lines I messed that up there we
go run all right so we have first array
one two three four second array five six
seven eight
and we'll put a carried return on there
and the keyword we use is concatenate
and if you're familiar with Linux it
usually means you're adding it to the
end on there and we're going to do what
they call a long axis zero so we have
concatenate a b along axis zero let's go
ahead and run that and see what that
looks like
so we have one two three four five six
seven eight so now we have an array that
is four by two has a nice shape of four
by two one here
and if we're going to do it along the
axis 0
you should guess what the next one is
we're going to do it along the one axis
and let's see how those differ from each
other let's just go ahead and run that
and again all we're doing is adding in
the axes equals one so we have our
concatenate we have a b and then axis
one remember a couple things one these
are the same shape so we have a two by
two same dimensions going in there
you're going to get an error if you're
concatenating and they're not if you
have something that instead of one two
is one two three four five six with a
five six seven eight they'll give you an
error on there in fact let's take a look
and see what happens when we do that let
me just take this
one two three three four five and let's
run that and if we come down here up we
got there it says it says all the input
array Dimensions except for the
concatenation axes M must match exactly
so it will let you know if you mess up
that's always a good thing let's go
ahead and take this back here and let's
go ahead and run that
and so we have our zero axes which is
one two three four five six seven eight
and we bring them together and you'll
see a very different setup here where we
do it along the axis one we end up with
instead of four by two we end up with a
two by four one two five six three four
seven eight and this is changing which
axes we're going to go ahead and
concatenate on what I find is when
you're talking about the concatenate or
the joining arrays you really got to
play with these for a while to make sure
you understand what you mean by the axes
it looks very intuitive when you're
looking at it actually 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
axis one is then splitting in a
different way one two five six three
four seven eight
when you're actually using real data you
start to really get a feel for what this
means and what this does
so if we're going to do that let's go
ahead and look at splitting the array
and do that in a markdown and run it
there we go so you have a nice little
title there
and we'll go ahead and create an array
of nine
let's do NP split
we'll do a and we're going to split it
by three
let's just see what that looks like so
if we split it we get an array 0 1 2 3 4
5 we get three separate arrays on here
now remember we're looking at let me
just print a up here
so we're looking at zero one two three
four five six seven eight and then we
can split it into three separate arrays
and let's take this we're going to do
this right down here let's move the a
split down here instead of the three
let's do four comma five and put that in
Brackets
and so we do it this way we have zero
one two three four five six seven eight
and that's kind of interesting I wasn't
sure what to expect on that but we get
when you split an a by four comma five
you get a totally different setup on
here as far as the way it split the
array
and to understand how this works I'm
going to change the 5 to a 7. and this
will visually make this a little bit
more clear
so we had four and five I went zero one
two three four five six seven eight and
you see the markers four and five when
we do four and seven I get zero one two
three four five six seven eight and so
what you're looking at here is the first
markers this is going to go to four
so there's our first split at the four
the marker of four and then the second
split is going to be at position seven
and this is the same thing here a four
position five that's why we're splitting
it in those two sections we could also
do it seven let's just see what that
looks like run and you can see I now
have zero one two three four five six
seven eight
so we could split in all kinds of
different ways and create a different
set of multiple arrays on here and split
it all kinds of different ways and
before we get into the graphs and other
miscellaneous stuff
let's go ahead and look at resizing the
array I'm going to take the cell and
sales a markdown and run it
give us a nice title there and we'll do
an array an in Peru of one two three and
four five six here I'm just going to
just print
let's go print a DOT shape then we'll go
ahead and run that whoops hit a wrong
button there
hit the comma instead of the dot so we
have a shape of two comma three here
and this is important to note because we
start resizing it it's going to mess
with different aspects of the shape
and so we'll go ahead and do a print
scoop in for a blank line there we go
let's do b equals
NP dot resize
we're going to resize a
and let's resize it with three by two
and then we'll just go ahead and
print
B
and print the period shape not a comma
I'll run that
oops forgot the quotation marks around
the end we'll go ahead and run that and
let's just see what that looks like so
we have one two three four five six
original array with the shape of two
three
and then we want to go ahead and resize
it by three two and we end up with one
two three four five six and we end up
with the shape of three two that
shouldn't be too much of a surprise you
know we got six elements in there we can
resize it by two three was the original
one and then we're actually just
reshaping is how that kind of comes out
as when you resize it like that
but what happens if we do something a
little different
and let's go ahead and just take this
whole thing and copy it down here so we
can see what that looks like
and instead of doing three two remember
last time I did the um to reshape it I
messed with the numbers and it gave me
an error but when you resize it you
don't have to match the numbers they
don't have to be the same dimensions so
we can instead of going from a 2 3 to a
3 2 we can resize it to a three three so
let's take a look and see how it handles
that and we come down here to 3 3 we end
up with one two three four five six and
it repeats one two three
so it actually takes the data and just
adds a whole other Block in there based
on the
and repeating it
all right now at this point you know
we've been looking at tons of numbers
and moving stuff around we want to go
ahead and do is get a little visual here
because that um
certainly you can picture all the
different numbers on there but let's
look at the histogram let's put this
into a histogram let me go ahead and run
that
and to do that we're going to use the
matplot library so from matplot library
we're going to import pipelot as PLT
that's usually the notation you see for
pi plot so if you ever see PLT in a code
it's probably Pi plot in the matplot
library
and then the guys in the back did a nice
job and gals too guys and gals back
there our team over at simply learn put
together a nice array for me 2087 4 40
53 with a bunch of numbers that way we
had something to play with and what we
want to do is we want to do plot the
histogram I remember a histogram says
how many times different numbers come in
and then we're going to put them in bins
and we have been 0 to 20 to 40 to 60 to
80 to 100.
you might in here with the matplot
library they call them bins you might
hear the term buckets or they put them
in buckets as a really common term then
we want to give it a title so the way it
works is you do your plt.hist for
histogram your PLT title and your PLT
show and we're doing just a single array
in here in the numpy array of a and
let's go ahead and run this piece of
code
taking a moment to come out there says
finger size so it's generating the graph
and you can see we have and let's just
take a look at this let me go down a
size there we go okay so now we can see
we're taking a look at here so between 0
and 20 we have three values so we have a
20 here we have a four and a 11 and a
15. zero one two three it's actually
Four values but they start at zeros
remember we always count from zero up
and from 20 to 40 we got 20 this is 142.
2 3 4
5 6.
and so you can see in the histogram it
shows that the most common numbers
coming up is going to be between the 40
and 60 range least common between the 80
and 100 this looks like an age
demographics that's what this looks like
to me and you can see where they would
have put it in the buckets of different
age groups which would be a nice way of
looking at this histograms are so
important and so powerful when you're
doing demos and explaining your data so
being able to quickly put a histogram up
that shows what's common and how it's
trending is really important and using
that with a numpy is really easy and you
know what let's take the same data and I
want to show you why we do bins or why
we have buckets of data I'm used to
calling it buckets why we have bins
let's do it instead of by 20 let's do it
by tens and see what happens
and what happens when you do it by tens
is you miss out on the you can see a
nice curve here on the first one and on
the second one it looks like a ladder
going up and a plummet a letter going up
and a plummet and a ladder going down so
the first would be more indicative of an
age group and the second one would be
what she would get if you divide it
incorrectly you wouldn't see the natural
trend
I don't know what this would be maybe
how much food they eat hopefully not
because I'm in 50 so I'm right in the
middle there that which means I get a
ton of food compared to everybody else
but it's some kind of democrat maybe
it's mental maybe it's knowledge because
we we hit a certain point and we start
losing our marbles start leaking out or
something so you start off knowing
something and then as you get older you
grow more but you can see here we lose
that you lose that continuity in the
thing if you split the histogram into
too many bins or too many buckets
and if you actually plotted this by the
individual numbers it would just be a
bunch of dots on
that wouldn't mean a whole lot
and we've looked at graphs there are
turns out there are a ton of useful
functions in numpy
I'm sure there's even new ones that are
aren't going to be in here but let's
just cover some important ones you
really need to know about if you're
using the numpy framework
one of them is Lane space function this
is generating data so you have a line
space we have one three ten and when we
do that we end up with 10 numbers so if
you count them there's 10 numbers
they're between 1 and 3 and they're
evenly spaced we get 1 1.222 but these
are all there's a total of 10 here and
it's right between the one and three
range
that could be there's a lot of uses for
that but they're probably more obscure
than a lot of the other common numpy
arrays set up
but a real common one is to do summation
so we'll do summation where you do in
this case we create a numpy array of one
of
two different arrays One Two Three or
two different dimensions one two three
three four five and we're going to sum
them up under axes zero which is your
columns and if you remember correctly
columns is the one plus three two plus
four three plus five so we have three
columns and if we change this we'll just
flip this to one
we get two numbers so we get one two
three all added together which equals
six and three plus four plus five which
equals twelve
back to zero
there we go since it said it was just
looking at zero
and these probably could have been some
of these could be able to start math
section square root and standard
deviation two very important tools we
use throughout the machine learning
process and data science and simply we
take the NP array we have again the one
two three four five six three four five
I don't know I need to keep recreating
it I probably could have just kept it
but we can take the square root of a so
it goes through and it takes a square
root of all the different terms in a and
we can also take the standard deviation
how much they deviate in value on there
and there's a ravel function we can run
that
and NP array is X we're going to do x
equals a we change it from a to x x
equals Ravel and this sets it up as
columns so we have one two three four
five this is all columns on here very
similar to the flattened function
so they kind of look almost identical
but we also have the option of doing a
ravel by column and then another one is
log so you can do mathematical log on
your array in this case we have one two
three and we'll find the log base 10 for
each of those three numbers there's a
couple of them they don't you can't just
do any number here after log but there
is also log base 2. log base 10 is
pretty commonly used on here I'm going
to run that there we go
before we go let's have a little fun
let's do a little practice session here
on some more challenging questions so
you start to think how this stuff fits
together right now we just looked at all
the basics and all the basic tools you
have so let's do some numpy practice
examples and let's start by figuring out
how do you plot say a sine wave in numpy
what would that look like and so in this
project we wouldn't have to do this
because I've already run these but we'd
want to go ahead and import our numpy as
NP and import our matplot library
pipelot as PLT so we get our tools going
here and then we'll break it into two
sections because we need our x Y
coordinates in here so first off let's
create our x coordinates and our x
coordinates we're going to set to an a
range
and we want this error a range since
we're doing sine and cosine it's going
to be between 0 and 0.1
and then we use our NP and we actually
can look up numpy stores Pi see how the
option of just pulling Pi in there
directly from numpy it has a few other
variables that it stores in there that
you can pull from there but we have
numpy pi and we generate a nice range
here and let's go ahead and run this and
just out of curiosity let's see what x
looks like I always like to do that so
we have
0.1.2.3.4 so we're going 0 to in this
case 9.4 3 times numpy pi remember Pi is
like three point something something
something that makes sense it should be
about nine and we're doing intervals of
0.1 so we create a nice range of data
and then we need to create our y
variable and so Y is going to Simply
equal NP or numpy dot sine of X and then
once we have our X and Y and if we print
let's go and just print y you see all
that we'll do this let's do this so it
looks print
X print y
so we basically have two arrays of data
so we have like our X axes and our y
axes going on there
and this is simply a
plt.plot because we're going to plot the
points and we'll do X comma Y and then
we want to actually see the graph so
we'll do plot dot show and we'll go
ahead and run that and you see we get a
nice sine wave and here's our number 0
through 9 and here's our sine value
which oscillates between -1 and 1 like
we'd expect it to then for the next
challenge let's create a six by six two
dimensional array and let one and zero
be placed alternatively across the
diagonals
oh that's a little confusing so let's
think about that we're going to create a
six by six two dimensional so the shape
is six by six two dimensional array and
let one and zero be placed alternatively
across the diagonals
now if you remember from lesson one we
can fill a whole numpy array with zeros
or ones or whatever so we're going to do
NP create a note B zeros and we're going
to do a six by six and we'll go ahead
and make sure it knows it's an integer
even though it's usually the default and
just real quick let's take a look and
see what that looks like so if I run
this you can see I get six by six grid
so six by six zero zero zero zero zero
now if I understand this correctly when
they say ones and zero placed
alternatively across the diagonals they
want the center diagonal maybe that's
going to stay zero all the way down
and then the next diagonal will be ones
all the way across diagonally and then
the next one zeros the next one ones the
next one zeros and so on I hope you can
see my mouse lit up there and
highlighting it so let's take a little
piece of code here
and we'll do Z One colon colon two comma
colon colon 2 equals one and well that's
a mouthful right there so let's go ahead
and run this and see what that's doing
and so what we're doing is we're saying
hey let's look at in this case Row one
there's one and then we're going to go
every other row two so we're going to
skip a row so skip here skip here skip
here so we're going down
this way and we're going every other row
going this way it's hard to highlight
columns so you can see right here where
the that we're not touching each row is
like this row right here is not being
touched okay so we're going to start
with Row one and then we're going to
skip a row and another one and so we're
going every two rows and then in every
two rows we're looking at every two
starting with the beginning that's what
this thing blank means so we're going to
start with the beginning and we're going
to look at all of them but we're going
to skip every two so starting with Row
one
we look at all the rows but we do we do
it by two steps so we go one Skip One
you know one Skip One One skip one one
if you lift this out and do every one
this is just be ones in fact let's see
what this looks like if I go like this
and run it you can see that I guess get
ones
so this notation allows us to go down
each row row by row and we're going to
do every other row set up on there and
so if we're going to start with Row one
we also
control Z
try that there we go we'll start with
row zero again we're going to go each
row step two so we'll start with row
zero and we'll go every other row and
this time we'll start with one column
one and again we go every other one
going down
step that's what that step two is
skipping every other one we're going to
set that equal to one so let's see what
that looks like and you can see here we
get our answer we get zero one zero zero
but it has the ones going in diagonals
on every other diagonal and zero on
every other one
a little bit of a brain teaser that one
trying to get that one to work out so
you can see how you can arrange your
rows and here's your step in your
different axis on there
and then the next one is find the total
number and locations of missing values
in the array the first challenge is to
create some missing numbers so let's
create our array Z we're going to do a
numpy DOT random dot Rand 10 comma ten
and before we do the second part let me
just take the second part out
and let's just see what that looks like
so let's run that and there we go so we
have a 10 by 10 random array it randomly
is picking out numbers
and next we want to go ahead and take
our random integer size equals 5. and
then we're going to do a random random
10 size equals 5. so in the Z we're
going to select a number of random
spaces here and set them equal to null
value
now let's go ahead and run that so you
can see what that looks like and if we
look at the array
we've created one two
three four this should be a fifth one in
here my eyes may be filling me so we've
created a series of oh because zero zero
to five zero one two three four so we
got five there are different null values
in here and
this is kind of a neat notation to
notice that we can generate
random integers size equals five so this
generates five by five miniature grid
inside of this to tell it where to put
the nands at so that's kind of a cool
little thing you can do
and we want to look up and see how many
null values are in there
and this is simply just NP is net of Z
simple so if it is nand then we want to
sum it up so we're going to sum up all
of the different null values on there
now let's do one one more feature in
here which is really cool
let's go ahead and print the indexes so
NP argue where NP is
Nan of Z so we're going to create our
own another NP array and let's run this
and we'll see here that comes up with
the four indexes so we did Count four of
them up there
it tells you where they are one nine two
zero four six five four
and then let's go ahead and run this
again run run there we go this time I
got five let's go for random numbers
another fun one that I always like to do
it's very similar is we have NP is nand
z dot sum so we're summing the number of
nands and we can get the indexes and you
can reshape the indexes but you can also
just do we'll do an inds where NP is Nan
of Z
and let's just print let's print that
print inds let's see what that looks
like
and it's very similar we have we have
zero one three zero six three eight six
nine three if I have split it into two
different arrays
so we have our X and our y kind of
coordinates going there and what I can
now do is I can now do Z inds
equals and at this point you can also
instead of getting the sum you can get
the means or the well the numbers and
that kind of thing you have or the
average as it is so be one thing you
could do and you can pick up the average
that's very common in data science to
get the average and just use that for a
value
but we'll go ahead and just set it to
zero and then let's go ahead and print
our Z and run that and you can see we
come down here we have wherever there
was a null value it is now zero
and you could set this whatever you want
this is another way to replace data or
help clean data depending on what it is
you're doing
so wow we covered a lot of stuff so
quick rehash going over everything we
went into there we looked at array
manipulation changing the shape
how to switch that around we even had
the flatten down there which remember we
have another command lower that's
similar we could change the order by F
remember F stands for Fortran very
strange connotation but there's C and F
C is the standard and F switches it to a
different order
to be honest I usually have to look it
up because I almost never use f but when
you need it you're like oh my gosh it
was the other order just do a quick
Google so we talked about reshape making
sure that the dimensions are the same
you don't want to have like something
that has 12 objects in it and reshape it
to C 11 and 5 because it doesn't work it
doesn't divide into 12. we can transpose
so we can switch them so we can go from
a four by three to a three by four Oops
I did that the other way around
three by four to four by three
we covered reshaping the array we did
the roll the axes you can do some weird
things with swapping and rolling axes
and transposing the numbers
we dug a little bit into the arithmetic
so we talked about adding we talked
about subtracting multiplying dividing
and you know at this point it's so
important we just look up the numpy
mathematics and you can see here they
have just about everything your
trigonometry
uh your hyperbolic functions rounding
sums products differences there are so
many all you different miscellaneous
mathematical connotations so you know
Google it go to the main numpy page and
look at the different setups you can do
on there so we covered that and we did
slicing how to break it apart we did
iterating over the array we covered
joining arrays and how to concatenate
remember concatenate just means add-on
to it so in this case how are you adding
B onto a is how you'd read that from
Linux you should catch the concatenate
because that's used regularly there
splitting the array we talked about how
to split the array in different ways so
you can split it in Array of arrays all
kinds of different ways to split the
array up how to resize it and remember
resize does not have to have the same
shape but if you resize it it will take
the data and begin at the beginning and
add new rows on if the size is bigger if
it's smaller it truncates it it just
cuts the end off
we looked at how to do a histogram and
how to plot that
we mentioned buying buckets or bins as
they call them in pi plot and then we
covered a lot of other useful functions
in numpy talked about the line space
setup for doing
um numbers in a series how to sum the
axes up again that's part of the
mathematical formulas there that we
looked at there's a sum there's also
means and median all of those you can
compute in numpy and you can also do the
square root and standard deviation
the Ravel function very similar to the
flat
to be honest I almost always just use
the flat but you know the Revel has its
own kind of functionality that it does
and then we went into some numpy
practice examples we challenged you to
create a sine wave in numpy and how to
do that we're kind of looking for that a
range remember how we do the a range and
you can
have your beginning value your in value
which they did is three times Pi numpy
Pi and we're going to do intervals of
0.1
and then y just equals the numpy sine of
x there's our math from the math page we
were just looking at remember that's
right at the top
and finally we went down here we had
this kind of a little brain teaser how
to do diagonal zeros and Ones playing
with the different connotations of Z of
the numpy array
and then we did a random size and we
played a little bit with how to with the
null values playing with null values
if you're doing any data science you
know null values are like a headache
what do you do with them big sets of
data you get rid of them small sets of
data you have to factor something in
there like figure out the average or the
median there and then replace it with
that
pandas really is a core python module
you need for doing data science and data
processing there's so many other modules
that come off of it there's actually
sits kind of on numpy so if you've
already had our numpy array hopefully
you've already gone through the numpy
tutorial one and two So today we're
going to cover what is pandas we'll
discuss series we'll discuss basic
operations on series and then we'll get
into a data frame itself basic
operations on the data frame file
related operations on a data frame
visualization and then some practice
examples roll up our sleeves and get
some coding underneath there and let's
start with just some real general what
is pandas pandas is a tool for data
processing which helps in data analysis
it provides functions and methods to
efficiently manipulate large data sets
now this is a step down from say using
spark or Hadoop in Big Data so we're not
talking about Big Data here but we are
talking about pandas I mean there is
some connections there's like an
interface going on with that so there is
availability but you really should know
your pandas because if you're working in
Big Data you'll know there's data frames
well pandas is a data frame primarily it
has a couple different pieces we'll look
at here and if you've never worked with
data frames before a data frame is
basically like an Excel spreadsheet you
have rows and columns you can access
your data either by the row or the
column when you have an index and
different that kind of setup and we'll
dig more into that as we get deeper into
pandas but think of it as like a giant
Excel spreadsheet that's optimized to
run on larger data on your computer and
then I said it that it's a data frame so
the data structures in pandas are series
one-dimensional arrays and then we have
data frame two-dimensional array and it
really centers around the data frame the
series just happens to be part of that
data frame and here's a closer look at a
pandas series series is a
one-dimensional array with labels it can
contain any data type including integer
strings floats python objects and more
so it's very diverse if you remember
from numpy we studied they had to be all
uniform not in pandas and pandas we can
do a lot more and pandas actually kind
of sits on numpy so you really need to
know both of those if you haven't done
the numpy tutorials and you can see here
we have our index one two three four
five and then our data a b c d and e
very straightforward it's just two
columns and we have a nice index label
and a column label for the data and then
a data frame is a two-dimensional data
structure with labels we can use labels
to locate data and you can see here we
had if we go back one we had our index
one two three four five so in each one
of these series they would share the
same index over there the row index so
you have your row index DF dot index and
then you have a column index df.columbs
and this is like I said this would be
really familiar if you've done any work
with spreadsheets Excel so it kind of
resembles that this does make it a lot
easier to manipulate data and add
columns delete columns move them around
same thing with the rows so you have a
lot of control over all of this now
we're of course going to do this in our
jupyter notebook you can use any of your
python editors but I highly suggest if
you haven't installed Jupiter and
haven't worked with it it is probably
one of the best ways for easily
displaying a project you're working on I
skip between a lot of different user
interfaces or Ides for editing my Python
and it's just simply jupiter.org
j-u-p-y-t-e-r dot org and then I always
let mine sit on anaconda anaconda.com
and just real quick we'll open that up
for you oops offline mode don't show me
that again but you can see here that I
have different tools that I can actually
install in my anaconda including the
Jupiter notebook which comes by default
and then I have access to the
environments and again that's
anaconda.com named after the very large
one of the largest world's largest
snakes and then Jupiter notebook in this
case jupiter.org and when we're in our
I'm going to go in here to our Jupiter
notebook and we're going to go ahead and
just do new and a Python 3 and this will
open up a Python 3 Untitled folder so
diving right in let's go ahead and give
this a title pandas tutorial and we'll
go up to cell and we'll change the cell
type to mark down so it doesn't execute
it as actual code one of those wonderful
tools when you have jupyter notebooks
you can do demos with this and let's go
ahead and import pandas and usually
people just call it PD that's become
such a standard in the industry so we'll
go ahead and run that now we have our
pandas has been imported into our
jupyter notebook
and then oh we can go ahead and let me
do the control plus it's just Internet
Explorer I can enlarge it very easily so
you have a nice pretty view oops too big
there we go and whenever you're working
with the new modules good to check your
version of the module in pandas you just
use the in this case PD dot underscore
underscore version underscore underscore
that's actually pretty common in most of
our python modules there's different
ways to look up the version but that's
one of the more common ones and we'll go
ahead and run that we get
0.23.4 and if we go to the pandas site
we see
0.23.4 is the latest release and of
course a reminder that if you're going
to an environment you need to install it
so you'll need to do pip install pandas
if you're using the PIP installer we'll
go and close out of that
and the first thing we want to do is
we're going to work with series a lot of
the stuff you do in series you can then
do on the whole data set we need to do
what create one we need to manipulate it
take pieces of it so query query it
delete so you can delete different parts
of it so we want to do all those things
with the series and we'll start with the
series and then almost all the code in
fact all the code does transfer right
into
the actual data table so we go from a
series of a single list of one column
and then we'll take that and we'll
transfer that over to the whole table
and we'll start by creating let's put up
there we go creating a series from
list
and let's just call this ARR equals and
we'll do 0 1 2 3 4. if you remember from
our last one we could easily do R equals
range of five which would be zero to
four but we'll do R equals zero to four
and we'll call this S1 and we'll go PD
and series is capitalized this one
always throws me is which letters do you
capitalize on these modules they're
getting more and more uniform but you
got to watch that with python and we're
just going to go ahead and do ARR so
we're just going to take this python
list and we're going to turn it into a
series and then because we're in Jupiter
we don't have to put the print statement
we can just put S1 and it'll print out
this series for us now let's go ahead
and run that and take a look
and you'll see we have two rows of
numbers so the first one is the index
now it automatically creates the index
starting with zero unless you tell it to
do differently so we get 0 index row 0
is 0 1 1 2 2 3 3 4 4. and because it's a
series it doesn't need a title for the
column there's only one column so why
title it
and this also lets you know that it's a
data type of integer 64. so we print
this out this is our series our basic
series we've just created now let's do a
second series
PD and we'll use the same
data list and let's go ahead and do
order we'll give it an order equals oh
let's do it this way
let's go index equals order
and it helps if we actually give it an
order so we'll do order equals and let's
do one two three four five so instead of
starting with zero we're going to give
it an order starting with one we're
going to run that and we'll go ahead and
print it out down here S2
and we'll see that we now have an index
of one two three four five and that
represents zero one two three four in
the series and we're still data type
integer 64. and very common is you're
missing with numpy arrays is we can
import our numpy as NP remember that
from our numpy tutorials we can go ahead
and create a numpy at a random with the
random numbers of five and let's just
see what that end looks like so we can
see what our number looks like so we
have some nice random float values here
2.33 so on and this from our last
tutorial the numpy tutorial one and two
and instead of calling it order let's
call it index and we're going to set our
index equal to a b c d and e I want to
show you that the index doesn't have to
be an integer so it can be something
very different here and then let's go
ahead and create our we'll just use S2
again and here's our NP for numpy
series capital s
and N is our NP for number
PD for pandas there we go switching my
anachronisms so we have pd.series of N
and we want to do our index equals our
index we just created
and then let's go ahead and see what
that looks like S2 is a print it and
let's run that and we can see here we
have a nice Series going on a b c d and
e for our indexes so instead of it being
0 1 2 3 or 4 we can make this index
whatever we want and you can see the
numbers here going down that we randomly
generated from the numpy array so we use
numpy to create our Panda Series right
here and so continuing on with creating
our Series this one I use so often we
create a series from a dictionary so we
have our dictionary in this case we went
ahead and did a of one B is 2 C of three
D4 e of five so each one of those is a
key and then a value and then we're
going to use oh let's use S3 equals PD
for pandas
series and then we want to go ahead and
just do D in here
print out S3 here and let's go ahead and
run this and you can see we got a is one
B is 2 C is three D is four e is 5. and
it's still of integer 64 Because the
actual data is one two three four five
and it's all integers 64 type 64. and
the last thing we want to do in the
creating section of our series is to go
ahead and modify the index because we're
going to start modifying all this data
so let's start with modifying the index
of the series and if you remember let's
do a print this time S1
I'll go ahead and run this and the
reason I did print is because it only
prints out the last variable so if I put
S1 up here and we're going to do another
variable back down lower it won't print
the first one just the last one and
we're going to go ahead and take S1
the index and we're just going to set it
equal to a new index and obviously the
number of objects in our index has to
equal the number of objects in our data
and then because it's a last variable we
can go ahead and just do an S1 and let's
run that and you can see how we went
from 0 to 0 0 1 2 3 4 as our index we've
now altered it to a b c d and e so this
would be much more readable or might be
representational of a larger database
you're working with
So Cool Tools we've covered creating
database based on our basic array python
array we've showed you how to reset the
index
that we showed you how to use a numpy
array so you can put a numpy array in
there it's all the same you know
pd.series numpy array and then we can
set the index on there and the same
thing with the dictionary so it's very
versatile how it pulls in data and you
can pull in data from different sources
and different setups and create a new
series very easily in the pandas and
then we looked on changing your index so
now we have a new index on here
and then we want to go ahead and do some
selection let's do some basic
slicing most common thing you'll
probably do on here and we'll just do S1
this notation should start to look
really familiar again this is going to
put an output so I'd usually it doesn't
change S1 this just selects it so we
might do a equals S1 and then print a
and you'll see that it just looks at the
first three zero one two and we can do
the same thing by not having the a in
there I'll go ahead and take that out
but it's just a reminder that it's not
actually changing S1 it's just viewing
S1 so simple slicing on here and we can
likewise do an append oops before we do
a pin let's just do a quick kind of fun
one we'll do two minus one and you'll
see it covers everything but the E of
course you can do minus two on this side
so one another way to select it is to go
how far from the end and likewise we can
do a 2 here c d e to the end so it
starts at the second one and another way
we can do this is we can do a minus 2
over here
and that looks at just the last two in
the slice so you can see how easy it is
to slice the data and of course there's
no reason to do this but you could
select all of them if you wanted to view
all of them on there oops 32 there's not
32 so it's just going to show the first
three there we go and then we can also
append so I can take and oh let's create
another Series in a pinned one to it and
if you remember we had S3 there's our S3
and we have our S1 I'm going to do S1
and let's go ahead and do let's call it
S4
equals S1
a pin S3
so we're just going to combine those two
into S4
and if we go ahead and print S4 on here
you'll now see that we have a b c d e a
b c d e zero one two three four one two
three four five because we started the
data at one
so very easy to compend one series to
the next and if we're going to append
one series to the next we need to go
ahead and drop or delete one and drop is
a keyword for that and let's just do e
or index e and so if I run this
you'll see that it'll print it out and a
b c d there's no e and remember all
these changes if I type in S4 again
you'll see that S4 still has e in it so
this change does not affect the series
unless you tell it to so I'd have to do
like x S4 equals S4 dot drop e and
there's another way to do that which
we'll show you later on let me just cut
this one out
there we go all right so we've covered
all kinds of Cool Tools here we have
appending we have slicing we did all the
creating stuff earlier as you can see
here on the setup how easy it is to
manipulate the series
so next what we want to get into is we
want to get into
operations that happen on the series let
me go ahead and change this cell to
mark down there we go and run so series
operations what can we do with the
series and let's start by creating a
couple arrays we'll call it array one
and we'll do 0 through 7 and array two
six through six seven eight nine five I
don't know let me through the five on
the end let's go ahead and run those so
those load up into Jupiter and we'll do
this a little backwards we're going to
do S5 equals a panda series of array two
so I'm doing this in reverse and then
when we do S5 you'll see that we have
zero to four it automatically assign the
index
67895 for our series and let's go ahead
and do the same and we'll call this S6
and we'll set this equal to PD series
for our first array and if we do an S6
down here to print it out
we'll see something similar I got zero
through six zero one two three four five
seven for the data so those are two
series we just created series six five
and six
and one of the first things we can do is
we can add one series to the next so I
can do S5 dot add S6 and let's see what
that generates and just a quick thing if
you've never used pandas what do you
think is going to happen with the fact
that this only has five different values
in it and this one has seven values
so let's see what that does and we end
up with 6 8 10 12 9 and it goes oh I
can't add this there's nothing there so
it gives us a null return very different
than the numpy that would have given you
an error this instead tells you there's
no value here because we couldn't
generate one so we can easily add S5 dot
add S6 and likewise we can do S5 Dot
sub for subtract S6 and we'll run that
and on the add the subtract and you
guessed it we're going to do multiply
and divide next again you can see
there's the null values where it can't
subtract the two because there's no
values there to subtract we can also do
S5 multiply mul they're all three
letters on these that's one of the ways
to remember how they figured out the
code for this so remember these are all
three letters mole we'll go ahead and
run this and you can again you can see
how they're multiplied together and then
we can also do the S5 div three letters
again S6 and run that
and you'll see here this goes to
Infinity because we have 0 in the wrong
position so it actually gives you a
whole different answer here that's
important to notice and then in the null
values because there's no data and it
can't actually produce an answer off of
null off of missing data and since we're
in data science let's do S6
median so let's look at the median data
which is simply median sorry for those
who are following the three letters
because median is not three letters and
you can see an S6 is 3.0 and let's do a
print here and we'll do median
or average S6
and let's print Max
my S6 and just like median there's max
value and if we're going to have a max
value we should also have a minimum
value so let's pop in minimum
we'll go ahead and run this and you're
starting to see something that would be
generated like say an R where you're
starting to get your different
statistics we have a median value of
three max value of 7 and a minimum value
of zero and what it does when it hits
these null values if there is no values
in there because we could still do that
we could actually you know what let's go
up here and do
let's pick this one where we multiplied
let's go s seven equals
print the S7 just so I keep it nice and
uniform so I still have my S7 down there
and run it and then I want to take the
S7
this S7 now has null values and an
Infinity value and let's see what
happens
this is going to be interesting because
I want to see what it is with infinity
and we end up with a median of six
maximum of 27 and minimum of zero which
is correct it drops those values so when
it gets to there and it doesn't know
what to do with them it just drops those
values and then it computes it on the
remaining data on there so that's
important to know when you're making
these computations you're looking at Min
and Max in median you're not going to
know that there's no values unless you
double check your data for the null
values that's a very important thing to
note on there so just a real quick
review on there we've done our created
our PD series and we've gone ahead and
done addition subtraction multiplication
division all those are three letters so
sub Min div add and then we looked at
median maximum and minimum so we're
going to go ahead and jump into the next
big topic which is to create a data
frame so now we're going to go from
series and we're going to create a
number of series and bundle them
together to make a data frame
there we go cell type markdown and
so we have a nice title on there it's
always good to have a good title all
right so our first data frame we'll jump
in with some stuff that looks a little
complicated we'll break it down first
I'm going to create some dates and you
know what let's just go ahead and do
this I want you to see what that looks
like what I'm creating here I've created
a series of dates PD date range and
we're going to use these for the index
okay so when you look at this you'll see
that it's just basically it comes out
kind of like a basic python list or
numpy array however you want to look at
it with our different dates going down
and we've generated six of them and it's
going to have whatever time it is right
now on your on the thing for the date
for the time that's that time stamp
right there and then you'll see we have
11 19 2008 11 20 11 19 and looking into
the future there so that's all this is
is generating a series of dates that
we're going to use as our index and this
is a pandas command so we have a date
range which is nice that's one of the
tools hidden in there in the handles
that you can use and next we're going to
use numpy to go ahead and generate some
random numbers in this case we'll do the
np.random.random and six comma four you
can look at this as rows and columns as
we move it into the pandas and of course
you could reshape this if you had those
backwards on your data but we want the
six to match the rows and we have six
periods so our indexes should match
along with the rows on there and then
you know before we do the next one let's
go ahead and just print out our numpy
arrays and see what that looks like here
we have it one two three four by one two
three four five six four by six so it's
a nice little setup on there and since
working with data frames can be very
visual let's give our columns we have
four columns and we're going to give
them names A B C and D so now we have
columns on there also and then let's put
this all together in a data frame and we
can actually you know what let's do this
since I did it with everything else
let's go ahead and do columns and you
can see there's our columns on there
and we'll go ahead and do df1 equals
pandas dot data frame and note that the
D and the f are capitalized series it
was just the S and I always highlight
this because you don't know how many
times these things get retyped when you
forget what's capitalized on there it's
a minor thing you'll pick it up right
away if you do a lot of it and the first
thing we want to do is we want to go
ahead and take our numpy array because
we're going to create our data frame off
of it's a numpy array and then we want
our index equal to our dates so there's
our index in there and then we also have
columns equals columns and then finally
let's see what that looks like now
remember we had all the different data
that just looked like a jumble of data
we have our column names and everything
else our numpy array kind of just a
jumble array over there four by six you
can sort of read it but look how nice
this looks I mean this is you come into
a board meeting you're working with your
shareholders
this is pretty readable this is you know
this is our date this is our a b c d
whatever it is maybe it's one of these
dates has your leads
closures lost leads total dollar made
you know whatever it is if it's in a
business maybe it's measurements on some
scientific equipment whether searching
material you know where this is like
high of the temperature low of the day
humidity of the day whatever it is so
you can see that we can really create a
nice clear chart and it looks just like
a spreadsheet you know we have our rows
and we have our columns and we have our
data in there now this one I use all the
time if we're going to create we can
create it like you saw here with our
numpy array very easy to do that and
reshape it you can also create it with a
dictionary array so here we have some
data and let me just go down a notch so
you can see all the data on there we
have an animal in this case cat cat
snake dog dog cat snake cat dog we have
the age so we have an array of Ages we
have the number of visits and the
priority was it a high priority yes no
and then we're going to take that we're
going to create some labels we have a b
c d e f g h i and what I want you to
notice on this is we have a title animal
and then we have basically a python list
and these lists they don't necessarily
have to be equal because we can have
non-data you know np.net numpy array
null value but we want to go ahead and
create labels that are equal to the
number in the list so a the first cat B
the second cat C the snake D the dog and
so on so we'll go ahead and create our
labels which we're going to use as an
index and we'll call this DF let's do it
this way we'll call this df2
equals PD for pandas data frame and then
we have our data just like we did before
and then we have our index equals
labels
and if we're going to go from there
let's go ahead and print it out so we
can see what that looks like df2 so
let's go ahead and run that another
again you have a nice very clean chart
to look at we've gone from this mess of
data here to what looks like a very
organized spreadsheet very Visual and
easy to read animal age visits priority
and then a through J cats and all the
different animals so on and so on and
then when you do programming a lot of
times it's important to know what the
data types are so we can simply do df2
D types
and if we run that we can see that our
animal
is an object because it's just a string
but it comes in as an object age is a
float 64 integer 64 and then priority
again is just an object
and exploring this this one's very
popular let's go df2 head and if we
print that out the df2 head Returns the
first five and we can change this you
don't have to do five you might want to
just look at the top two maybe you want
to look at let's see now let's do six so
maybe we'll look at just the top six in
the database in your data frame and you
can actually this creates another data
frame so I could have a DF 3 equal to
df2 and this now takes the df2 and just
the first six values so if we do df3
run get the same answer
and if we do it the head of the data we
can also do the tell it's the same thing
DFT you can look at the last we'll just
do the tell which by default does five
the last five and of course you can just
look at the last three of those real
quick just to see what's at the end of
the data and this is the tell I love
doing the tell of one because I'll have
like the index or something like that
and it will just show me the last
whatever the last entry was looking at
stock values and I might want to look at
just the last five days of the stock
values I can do that with the data frame
tail
and some other key things to look up are
the index so we can do df2 dot index
and I want you to notice that this isn't
a call function so if I put the brackets
on the end it'll give me an error
because index is not callable it's just
an object in there so we do df2 dot
index there's also columns
so we can go ahead and Let's do let's
print this remember the first one is not
going to show unless I print it and then
df2 columns so now we can see we have
our indexes and we have our columns
listed here df2 dot columns animal age
visits priority that tells you what kind
of object it is or what kind of data
type it is and they're both object
and then finally df2 dot values and
again there's no brackets on the end of
df2.values because this is an actual
object it's not a callable function so
we'll go ahead and run that and it
creates this displays a nice array a
very easy way to convert this back to a
numpy array basically so before I go
into the next section let's just take a
quick look at what we covered so far
with the data frame we came up here we
created our data frame we did it from a
numpy array first setting the columns
and the index the index is setting it up
is the same as when we set up the series
so that should look very familiar so is
the whole format the numpy array the
index dates and the columns columns and
remember in our numpy array we're
looking at row comma column so six rows
four columns is how that reads in the
data frame
and we went ahead and also did that from
a dictionary in this case animal was the
column name with all the date data
underneath that column and then age with
that data visits that data priority that
data and then of course we added our
labels in there for our index so there's
no difference in there but it
automatically pulled the column names
important to know when you're dealing
with the data frame and importing a data
frame this way
and then we did looking up D type we
looked at head and tail looking at your
data really quick we also did index and
columns and values and note these don't
have the brackets on the end
so the next thing we want to do is go
ahead since we're dealing with data
science is we want to go ahead and
describe the data so we have
df2.describe to do that and we're going
to manipulate it in just a minute but
let's just see what this generates
and you can see right here we have age
and visits so looking at our data from
up above let me just go all the way up
here animal age business priority
and it does a nice job generating your
age versus visits which has all the data
you have your account your means your
standard deviation your minimum value 25
or in this group 50 75 and your maximum
value so this should look familiar as a
data science setup with your describe
for a quick look at your data Frame data
so let's start manipulating this data
frame moving stuff around and we'll
start with transposing and it is simply
capital T for transpose and when we run
that it flips The Columns and the
indexes so now the indexes are all
column names and the columns are all
indexes animal age visits priority so if
we had come in here with our data shaped
wrong up above where we had a four by
six we can quickly just swap it if we
had it backwards not a big deal and we
can also sort our data so something that
you can't deal which is more difficult
to do with a lot of other packages and
the data frame is really easy to do take
our data frame df2 and we're going to
sort underscore values by equals age and
so when we run this you'll see the
default is ascending so we have 0.5 to
2.53 and everything else is organized so
if you look at your indexes they've been
moved around because each index it moves
the whole row not just the one piece of
data is not being sorted so a very quick
way to sort by age are different data in
the data frame and in addition to
sorting it we can also slice the data
frame so I could do df2 and this should
look familiar from earlier we'll just do
one to three so we're going to pull out
oops it does help if I use the DF
instead of just D and we're going to
pull up just between one and three so we
have not zero which is a we have B which
is 2 or B which is one and C which is
two so one two and then it does not
include 3 which is the standard in
Python and we can even do something like
this we can combine them which is always
fun because remember this returns a data
frame so if I take df2 dot sort foreign
values and we'll do by equals age this
is just kind of fun and then I'm going
to slice it there we go double check my
typing and run it and now you should see
fa because F A are now one and two on
there
I'm seeing very quickly create a whole
string on here which narrows it you know
that you can sort it then slice it and
do all kinds of fun things with your
data frame we'll just go back to the
original one run there we go and if we
can slice it by row we can also query
the data frame so we can do df2 and this
is a little different because I'm going
to create an array within an array and
in this case we're going to look at oh
let's do age comma
visits so look at the different format
in here we have one to three so we've
done this by slicing by an integer value
and then on here I've done df2 H comma
visits in an array and when I run this
you can see that we get just these two
columns on here we get age and visits so
it's a quick way to select just two
columns or select number of columns
you're working with
and if you stop there we did the slicing
almost identical to slice is I location
which uses the integer location one
comma three there's a push in pandas to
move to this particular setup instead of
doing just a regular slice and that's
because this can be confusing when we
slice one to three and then we select
agent visits so there is a push to go
ahead and move to an eye location which
does the same thing you can see here BC
it's the same as up above there's also a
copy command so we can do df3 equals df2
copy we're just going to create a
straight copy of it
and if we do df3
that'll be the same as a df2 on there so
df3 equals df2 dot copy and then let's
do df3 dot is null so we're looking for
null values
and this will return a nice map and
you'll see that everything is false
except when you go up here under the cat
or H they had a null there and so if we
go to have a couple up here also
underneath of let's see the dog okay
there's a bunch of nulls in here there's
D up here so let's look at D down here
and you'll see false true there it is
there's our null value so we can create
a quick chart of null values you can use
this to do other things we can leverage
that null value to maybe take an average
or something and fill those null spaces
with data and we can also modify the
location so here's our df3 location
and notice this is location not I
location I location has I for integer
location uses the in this case the
variables on the left and what we can do
on here and we're going to set this
equal to 1 5 and
some I'll pick a spot let's go back up
here where we had let's do F A just
let's see what were they looking at oh
here we go let's do F and age and up
here f is set to age of 2.0 and we find
out that that's incorrect data so we go
ahead and switch to df3 equal and then
we go and print out our df3
and if we go to F and age it is now 1.5
so we're just changing the value in the
df3 and this is changing the actual data
frame remember a lot of our stuff we do
a slice and like it returns another data
frame this changes the actual data frame
and that value in the data frame
so we've covered location and I location
is null making a copy here's our I
location which is equivalent of a slice
and also selecting columns so now we
want to dive just to take a little
detour here and let's look at df3 means
and this is kind of nice because you can
do this you can either do this by as you
can select a single column here by the
way you can just add the column
selection right here like we did before
so we could have age
look up the mean that just creates a
series if I run that there's our age
but if I take that out instead of
selecting it we can do the whole setup
and it has age and visits so why doesn't
it have priority or animal well those
are not integers so it's really hard
they're non-numerical values so what is
the average I guess you could do a
histogram which probably will look at
that later on but the only two things we
can really look at is age and visits and
we have the average or the mean on the
age is 3.375 and the mean on visits is
1.9 and let's do df3
visits we'll go ahead and steal the
visits again
and remember all those different
functions we looked at for a series well
we can do those here we can do the sum
so if we run that we'll see that these
sum up to 19. we could also look up
minimum if you remember that from before
the minimum is 1 Max so all that
functionality is here so we'll just go
back to summing it up and adding it all
together so real quick we've shown you
how to take the series operations and
put them into the data frame and then we
can actually this is interesting one we
can just do df3 sum run and you'll see
the different summations on there it
just combines them I like the way it
just combines the strings on there for
priority and animal we've looked at is
null we've also looked at copying along
with the different slices which we
talked about earlier so let's talk about
strings let's dive into the string setup
on there and let's go ahead and create a
string series string equals PD series
and we just put it right in there we
have a c d a a b a c a popped in a null
value cow and Al I don't know why they
picked Cal and Al in the background
someone must like those animals and of
course we can just do string if we run
that you'll see leave the r out we'll
get an error but if we put it in there
you'll see that we have a simple series
0 a 1C 2D and it automatically indexes
it zero to eight and then we can go
string dot lower so when we're talking
about our data frame in this case or our
data series string in this case we use
the string function Str and we're going
to make it lower and we go ahead and put
the brackets on there and you'll see
that we've gone from capital a Capital C
so on to ABC and Baka CBA Cal Al they
were all lowercase already and of course
if you want to go lower you can also do
upper and we'll go ahead and run that
and you can see we now have ACD AAA
everything's capitalized except for the
null value which is still null all right
so we looked at a few basic string you
can see that string functions upper and
lower we're going to jump into a very
important topic I'm even going to give
it its own header on here because it's
such an important topic what do you do
with missing values Panda has some great
tools for that so we'll dive into those
we'll call we'll work with df4 and if
you remember the DF copy from above
we're just going to make a copy of df3
and let's just take a quick look at the
data we're working with oops df3 forgot
the three on there there we go so here
we have our cat snakes and dogs
hopefully not all in the same container
because that would be just probably mean
to all of them so we made a copy we're
going to be working with df4 and the
reason we made a copy is we want to go
ahead and fill the data and we just
simply do fill in a and then we're going
to give it the value we want to put in
there we'll go at the value 4. so I can
run in here and you'll see now that df4
now has where the N A was is filled with
the value of four same thing down here
a lot of times we'll compute the mean
first so I might do a mean page equals
df4 and then we want to go ahead and do
age
dot mean
and then I'll do something like this df4
I only want to select the age and I want
to fill that
with the mean h and I run in there and
you'll see that our df4h now has the
means in there just a quick way of
showing you how you can combine these
let me go back to our original one there
we go and run that and keeping with good
practices df5 equals df3 dot copy
a little printer df5 which should be the
original one
and then on the df5 we can now drop our
missing data
so now simply drop in a and we're going
to use how equals any so I'm going to
drop any row that has missing data in it
and you'll see we had D here with
missing data and H and then let's go
ahead and see what df5 looks like when
we do that
there we go and there it is D is gone
and so is H so we create a new data
frame off of this missing those values
now if you have a lot of data dropping
values is a good way to take care of it
because you don't miss some data if you
have not a whole lot of data you're
working with like the iris data set or
something like that or something small
you want to start trying to find a way
to fill that data in so you don't lose
your computational power of the data you
got so just a quick look at processing
null values or missing values you can
fill them usually with the means some
people use medium or the mode there's
different ways you can fill it one way
is means and we can also just drop those
rows those are the two main things we do
with missing data
here we go uh we're going to cover next
this is I so love data frames for this
file operations it saved me so much time
because they have so many different
tools for bringing data in and saving
data so we're looking at the data frame
file operations it's really streamlined
I don't know how many times I'll go on
to different data downloads and they'll
have Panda download standard on there
just because it's so widely used so
let's start with the most common file is
a CSV so we have df3 to CSV or animal
and let me just show you the folders
going into right now I have some
Untitled and a few things in here but
nothing labeled animal so we go ahead
and run this and this is now save the
animal to my hard drive and you can now
see the animal folder up here and if I
let's do edit with a notepad oh let's
open up with just a regular notepad
there we go or wordpad if I open that up
you can see it's comma separate did our
titles they don't have an index on the
categories on the top in the index comma
then all the different data is separated
by commas
standard CSV file on there and if we're
going to send it to CSV and notice the
format is dot 2 underscore CSV and it's
just the name of the file we're sending
it to you can also put the complete path
by default it's going to go whatever the
active directory this program is running
on that's why those other folders are in
there so we have our df3 to CSV and then
if we're going to put it in there we
want to also get it back out and we'll
call this one DF underscore animal
equals PD read underscore CSV I always
have to remember is two underscore CSV
and read underscore CSV I always want to
do like a capital in there and not the
underscore we're going in here again
it's the active directory so if I now do
print out my DF animal
and let's just do the head we only want
to look at the first three lines so if I
go ahead and run this we'll see the
first three lines and they should match
up here what we saved to our CSV so very
easy to save and import from our CSV
files on here
and it turns out DF 3 also has a two
Excel they actually have a lot of
different formats but you know old
school Excel is real popular for so long
still is we can go ahead and save it as
animal dot xlsx we're going to call the
sheet named sheet1 and then I can also
do DF we'll call it animal 2.
two and this one's going to come from
and the same format on here there we go
so we still have our animal xlsx
the sheet 1 that's where it's coming
from index columns equals none so we're
not going to we're going to suppress the
indexing on the columns n a values and
it'll just assign that zero one up on
your indexes so if it says index columns
equals none that's what it does and then
we've added null values because null
values in here and we want to just make
sure that they're marked as n a and
we'll go ahead and just print out the
animal animal to there we go and let's
run that let's make this let's just do
the whole thing so we'll go ahead and
run that and it probably doesn't help
that I completely forgot the read so
animal 2 equals PD dot read
Excel there we go Excel so now we go
ahead and run it and what we expect is
happening here we have the same data
frame on here and if I flick back to my
folder you can now see that we have the
animal one of these is in Excel and one
of these is a CSV on here and so there's
our two file Types on there and they
have other formats these are just the
two most common ones used and I don't
know how many times I've had stuff from
Excel I need to pull out if you've ever
played with Excel it's a nightmare on
the back end because of the way they do
the indexing
so this just makes it quick and easy to
pull in an Excel spreadsheet so we
looked at two different ways to bring
data in and save it to files we've
looked at all kinds of different ways of
manipulating our data set and slicing it
and creating it for our data frame let's
get in there put your visualization
always a big thing at the end because
one it lets you check to see what you
did make sure it looks right and then
also if you're going to show somebody
else it makes it very clear what's going
on if they see something visual so this
is where a really important part of data
science is so let's go ahead and bring
in our tools we're going to do import
numpy as NP we want to make sure we have
our Amber sign matplot library in line
this just lets Jupiter know that we're
going to print it on this page if you're
using a different IDE you don't really
necessarily need that but this does help
it displays quickly in Jupiter notebook
and if you remember for earlier we could
create a we're going to call it TS we're
going to create a pandas which are cute
cuddly creatures versus a pandem short
for pandemonium no so we have TS equals
PD series and we're just going to create
a random setup of 50. we'll do an index
we'll set it equal to the pandas date
range today periods equals 50. so the
50s should match and I want you to
notice something here I did not import
the matplot library why because it's
already in there pandas already has its
built-in connection and interface with
matplot Library so you don't have to
import it and we'll go ahead and do TS
equals TS dot cumulative sum we're going
to do the cumulative sum
it's a little reformatting there and
we'll go ahead and plot it and let's
take a look at what that looks like
so we have a nice graph here we have the
dates on the bottom we set this up so we
have a nice range between in this case
minus four to looks like about two maybe
or one minus four and one so what we've
done here we've plotted a basic series
just a single row of data when we've set
indexes on there but we can also do the
whole data frame on there and let's see
what that looks like so first let's go
ahead and create the data frame we have
here random number so we're going to do
50 by 4 and then we'll go ahead and
create columns a b X and Y just because
we can index is a ts.index on there so
we're going to use the same index as
before just to keep it nice and uniform
we've already generated the dates to go
with it and then we can do just like we
did with the series we can also do with
the data frame
DF equals DF cumulative sum so we're
going to sum the whole data frame and
then we'll do simply DF plot and this
puts that in and let's go ahead and run
this and look how easy and quick that
was to generate a nice graph with all
the different data on there so we have
our shared index we have the shared
columns and then we have the different
data from each one that we can easily
look at and compare so very quick way of
displaying data you can imagine if you
were working in oh I think I mentioned
stock earlier because I've been doing
some analysis of stock lately so you'd
have your date down here and then you
would have stock a Stock B stock X Y
whatever it is and you can put them all
on one chart and see how they what they
look like next to each other and this
isn't too far off from what some of
those graphs looks like and this is just
randomly generated so stock has a lot of
Randomness in it which is one of the
reasons I actually play with it for
doing some of my models on for testing
them out
now there are a lot of features in
pandas so we're going to show you one
more thing on here there's some of the
things like I didn't go too deep we
looked at the top two for importing data
from a CSV and from an Excel spreadsheet
showed you how to quickly plot the data
there's more settings in there you can
do we're going to do one more thing down
here and this is kind of a fun one
changes to a mark down and run that so
how would you remove repeated data using
pandas
and this is where you have a data set
that comes in and maybe it's feeding
from one location and in instead of
noting that it's repeated the date like
oh let's go back to stocks that's a good
visual we have the stocks from the 23rd
and it adds another row and it's the
same row it's importing the 23rd again
and again so now you have that data
repeated three times and you need to go
back and figure out how to get rid of it
how do you track that down so let's
start by creating a quick database our
data frame not a database I keep saying
databases the data frame and we'll just
make this data frame has using our
dictionary going in this data frame only
has one data Series in it which is fine
so if we do DF to print it out you'll
see a one two two two two four five six
seven and so on and so how would you
remove that well there is a neat feature
in data frames called shift
along with another feature that lets us
select just certain information and
we'll go with the location function put
that in Brackets remember that from
above location and then in the location
let me just spread this out a little bit
so it's really easy to read in fact I'm
going to go upscale on that since we're
doing some a little bit more complicated
here
what you can see on this on the location
is I have DFA dot shift so this is going
to shift up one by default you can
actually change this to two or three you
could even do a minus one and it shifts
the other way but it's going to shift up
by one by default that's going to say if
that does not equal DF of a then we want
that if you look down here we had one
two two two two when we run this Logic
on here and we do the shift it now gets
rid of all the duplicates so we went
from one two two two two four four five
whatever it was here it is one two two
two four four four five five five six
six six two one two four five six seven
eight and you'll see on the index it
just deletes them out of there so the
index stays the same obviously you don't
want the dates to change if you're
working with an index dated setup so it
just deletes those duplicates out of
there this is just a quick way to
introduce you to one the fact that you
can add logic gates into here and two
the I location allows you to use shift
so there's the shift function and then
the I location selects that based on
true or false
wow so we've actually covered a lot
today in pandas we've really covered
into the basics of selecting your
different series out of your column out
of your data frame how to index rows how
to slice how to plot hopefully you'll
take this beyond that and start
combining these different things and you
can create long strings and really
explore your data generate some nice
graphs if you're in Jupiter notebook
it's a great demo to show others and I
didn't know this about Jupiter notebook
you can do this in Jupiter notebook and
then you can download and I always I
never really look too closely at all the
downloads but you download as an HTML
and post it to your blog so it's got a
neat feature in there but any of this is
really powerful tool all of this is
really powerful tools for doing your
data science if you are one of the
aspiring python enthusiasts looking for
online training and graduating from the
best universities for a professional who
elicits to switch careers in Python by
learning from the experts and try giving
a short to Simply learn postgraduate
program in Ai and machine learning in
collaboration with Purdue University and
IBM the course link is mentioned in the
description box below that will navigate
you to the course page where you can
find a complete audio of the program
being offered and we're going to cover
this scikit learn tutorial which has a
lot of features and all kinds of API in
it to explore data and do your data
science with effects is probably one of
the top data science packages out there
so what is the site kit learn it's
simple and efficient tool for data
mining and data analysis it's built on
numpy scipy and matplot Library so it
interfaces very well with these other
modules and it's an open source
commercially usable BSD license BSD
originally stood for Berkeley software
distribution license but it means it's
open source with very few restrictions
as far as what you can do with it
another reason to really like the site
kit learn setup so you don't have to pay
for it as a commercial license versus
many other copyrighted platforms out
there what we can achieve using the
scikit learn we use class the two main
things or classification and regression
models classification identifying which
category an object belongs to for one
application very commonly used is Spam
detection so is it a Spam or is it not a
spam yes no in banking it might be is
this a good loan bad loan today we'll be
looking at wine is it going to be a good
wine or a bad wine and regression is
predicting an attribute associated with
an object one example is stock prices
prediction what is going to be the next
value if the stock today sold for 23
dollars and five cents a share what do
you think it's going to sell for
tomorrow and the next day and the next
day so that'd be a regression model same
thing with weather weather forecasting
any of these are regression models where
we're looking at one specific prediction
I want a tribute today we've been doing
classification like I said we're gonna
be looking at whether a wine is good or
bad but certainly the regression model
which is in many cases more useful
because you're looking for an actual
value is also a little harder to follow
sometimes so classification is a really
good place to start we can also do
clustering and model selection
clustering is taking an automatic
grouping of similar objects into sets
customer segmentation is an example so
we have these customers like this
they'll probably also like this or if
you like this particular kind of
features on your objects maybe you like
these other objects so it's a referral
is a good one especially on Amazon.com
or any of your shopping networks model
selection comparing validating and
choosing parameters and models now this
is actually a little bit deeper as far
as a site kit learn we're looking at
different models for predicting the
right course or the best course or
what's the best solution today like I
said we're looking at Wines it's going
to be how do you get the best wine out
of this so we can compare different
models and we'll look a little bit at
that and improve the model's accuracy
via different parameters and fine-tuning
now this is only part one so we're not
going to do too much tuning on the
models we're looking at but I'll Point
them out as we go two other features
dimensionality reduction and
pre-processing dimensionality reduction
is we're reducing the number of random
variables to consider this increases the
model efficiency we won't touch that in
today's tutorial but be aware if you
have you know thousands of columns of
data coming in thousands of features
some of those are going to be duplicated
or some of them you can combine to form
a new column and by reducing all those
different features into a smaller amount
you can have a you can increase the
efficiency of your model it can process
faster and in some cases you'll be less
biased because if you're weighing it on
the same feature over and over again
it's going to be biased to that feature
and pre-processing these are both
pre-processing but pre-processing is
feature extraction and normalization so
we're going to be transforming input
data such as text for use with machine
learning algorithms we'll be doing a
simple scaling in this one for our
pre-processing and I'll point that out
when we get to that and we can discuss
pre-processing at that point with that
let's go ahead and roll up our sleeves
and dive in and see what we got here now
I like to use the Jupiter notebook and I
use it out of the Anaconda Navigator so
if you install the Anaconda Navigator by
default it will come with the jupyter
notebook or you can install the jupyter
notebook by itself this code will work
in any of your python setups I believe
I'm running an environment of 3 0.7
setup on there I'd have to go in here
and environments and look it up for the
python setup but it's one of the three
x's and we go ahead and launch this and
this will open it up in a web browser so
it's kind of nice it keeps everything
separate and in this Anaconda you can
actually have different environments
different versions of python different
modules installed in each environment so
it's a very powerful tool if you're
doing a lot of development and Jupiter
notebook is just a wonderful visual
display certainly you can use I know
spider is another one which is installed
with the Anaconda I actually use a
simple notepad plus plus when I'm doing
some of my python script any of your
Ides will work fine jupyter notebook is
iron python because it's designed for
the interface but it's good to be aware
of these different tools and when I
launched the Jupiter notebook I'll open
up like I said a web page in here and
we'll go over here to New and create a
new python setup like I said I believe
this is python37 but any of the three
this the site kit learn works with any
of the three X's there's even two seven
versions so it's been around a long time
so it's very big on the development side
and then the guys in the back guys and
gals developed they went ahead and put
this together for me and let's go ahead
and import our different packages now if
you've been reading some of our other
tutorials you'll recognize pandas as PD
pandas library is pretty widely used
it's a data frame setup so it's just
like columns in rows and a spreadsheet
with a lot of different features for
looking stuff up the Seaborn sits on top
of matplot libraries this is for a
graphing and we'll see that how quick it
is to throw a graph out there to view in
the Jupiter notebook for demos and
showing people what's going on and then
we're going to use the random Forest the
SVC or support vector classifier and
also the neural network so we're going
to look at this we're actually going to
go through and look at three different
classifiers that are most common some of
the most common classifiers and let's
show how those work in the scikit learn
setup and how they're different and then
if you're going to do your setup on here
you'll want to go ahead and import some
metrics so the sklearn.metrix on here
and we're going to use the confusion
metrics and the classification report
out of that and then we're going to use
from the sklearn pre-processing the
standard scalar and label encoder
standard scalar is probably the most
commonly used pre-processing there's a
lot of different pre-processing packages
in the sklearn and then model selection
for splitting our data up it's one of
the many ways we can split data into
different sections and the last line
here is our percentage matplot library
in line some of the Seaborn and matplot
Library will go ahead and display
perfectly in line without this and some
won't it's good to always include this
when you're in the Jupiter notebook this
is Jupiter notebook so if you Syrian IDE
when you run this it will actually open
up a new window and display the graphics
that way so you only need this if you're
running it in a editor like this one
with the specifically jupyter notebook
I'm not even familiar with other editors
that are like this but I'm sure they're
out there I'm sure there's a Firefox
version or something Jupiter notebook
just happens to be the most widely used
out there and we can go ahead and hit
the Run button and this now has saved
all this underneath the packages so my
packages are now all loaded I've run
them whether you read it on top we run
it to the left and all the packages are
up there so we now have them all
available to us for our project we're
working on and I'm just going to make a
little side note on that when you're
playing with these and you delete
something out and add something in even
if I went back and deleted this cell and
just hit the scissors up here these are
still loaded in this kernel so until I
go under kernel and restart or restart
and clear or restart and run all I'll
still have access to pandas important to
know because I've done that before I've
loaded up maybe not a module here but
I've loaded up my own code and then
changed my mind and wondering why does
it keep putting out the wrong output and
then I realize it's still loaded in the
kernel and you have to restart the
kernel just a quick side note for
working with a Jupiter notebook and one
of the troubleshooting things that comes
up and we're going to go and load up our
data set we're using the pandas so if
you haven't yet go look at our pandas
tutorial a simple read the CSV with the
separation on here so let me go ahead
and run that and that's now loaded into
the variable wine and let's take a quick
look at the actual file I always like to
look at the actual data I'm working with
in this case we have wine quality Dash
red I'll just open that up I have it in
my open Office setup separated by
semicolons that's important to notice
and we open that up you'll see we have
go all the way down here it looks like
1600 lines of data minus the first one
so 15
1599 lines and we have a number of
features going across the last one is
quality and right off the bat we see the
quality is uh has different numbers in
it five six seven it's not really I'm
not sure how how high of a level it goes
but I don't see anything over a seven so
it's kind of five through seven is what
I see here five six and seven four five
six and seven looking to see if there's
any other values in there looking
through the demo to begin with I didn't
realize the setup on this so you can see
there's a different quality values in
there alcohol sulfates pH density total
sulfur dioxide and so on those are all
the features we're going to be looking
at and since this is a pandas we'll just
do wine head and that prints the first
five rolls rows of data that's of course
a pandas command and we can see that
looks very similar to what we're looking
at before we have everything across here
it's automatically assigned an index on
the left
this does if you don't give it an index
and for the column names it has assigned
the first row so we have our first row
of data pulled off the our comma
separated variable file in this case
semicolon separated and it shows the
different features going across and we
have what one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven features 12
including quality but that's the one we
want to work on and understand and then
because we're in Panda's data frame we
can also do wine dot info and let's go
ahead and run that this tells us a lot
about our variables we're working with
you'll see here that there is
1599 that's what I said from the
spreadsheet so that looks correct
non-null float 64. this is a very
important information especially the
non-nullness there's no null values in
here that can really trip us up in
pre-processing and there's a number of
ways to process non-null values one is
just to delete that data out of there so
if you have enough data in there you
might just delete your non-null values
another one is to fill that information
in with like the average or the most
common values or other such means but
we're not going to have to worry about
that but we'll look at another way
because we can also do wine is null and
sum it up and this will give us a
similar it won't tell us that these are
float values but it will give us a
summation oops there we go let me run
that it'll give us a summation on here
how many null values in each one so if
you wanted to you know from here you
would be able to say okay this is a null
value but she doesn't tell you how many
are null values this one would clearly
tell you that you have maybe five null
values here two null values here and you
might just if he had only seven null
values and all that different data you'd
probably just delete them out where if
ninety percent of the data was null
values we might rethink you there are
different data collection setup
or find a different way to deal with the
null values we'll talk about that just a
little bit in the models too because the
models themselves have some built-in
features especially the forest model
which we're going to look at this point
we need to make a choice and to keep it
simple we're going to do a little
pre-processing of the data and we're
going to create some bins and bins we're
going to do is 2 comma 6.5 comma 8. what
this means is that we're going to take
those values if you remember up here let
me just scroll back up here we had our
quality the quality comes out between
two and eight basically or one and eight
we have five five six you can see just
in the just in the first five lines of
variation in quality we're going to
separate that into just two bins of
quality and so we've decided to create
two bins and we have bad and good it's
going to be the labels on those two bins
we have a spread of 6.5 and an exact
index of eight the exact index is
because we're doing 0 to 8 on there the
6.5 we can change we can actually make
this smaller or greater but we're only
looking for the really good wind we're
not looking for the zero one two three
four five six we're looking for wines
with seven or eight on us so high
quality you know like this is what I
want to put on my dinner table at night
I'm gonna taste the good wine not the
semi-good wine or mediocre wine and then
this is a panda so PD remember stands
for pandas pandas cut means we're
cutting out the wine quality and we're
replacing it and then we have our bins
equals bins that's the command bins is
the actual command and then our variable
bins to comma 6.58 so two different bins
and our labels bad and good and we can
also do let me just do it this way wine
quality since that's what we're working
on and let's look at unique another
pandas command and we'll run this and I
get this lovely error why did I get an
error well because I replaced wine
quality and I did this cut here which
changes things on here I'm sorry I
literally altered one of the variables
is saved in the memory so we'll go up
here to the kernel restart and run all
it starts it from the very beginning and
we can see here that that fixes the
error because I'm not cutting something
that's already been cut we have our wine
quality unique and the wine quality
unique is a bad or good so we have two
qualities objects bad is less than good
bad is going to be zero and good is
going to be one and to make that happen
we need to actually encode it so we'll
use the label quality equals label
encoder and the label encoder let me
just go back there so this is part of
sklearn that was one of the things we
imported was a label encoder you can see
that right here from the
sklearn.processing import standard
scalar which we're going to use in a
minute and label encoder and that's what
tells it to use that equals 0 and good
equals one and we'll go ahead and run
that and then we need to apply it to the
data and when we do that we take our
wine quality that we had before and
we're going to set that equal to label
quality which is our encoder and let's
look at this line right here we have dot
fit transform and you'll see this in the
pre-processing these are the most common
used is fit transform and fit transform
because they're so often that you're
also transferring the data when you fit
it they just combine them into one
command and we're just going to take the
wine quality feed it back into there and
put that back in our wine quality setup
and run that and now when we do the wine
and the head of the first five values
and we go ahead and run this you can see
right here underneath quality zero zero
zero I have to go down a little further
to look at the better wines
let's see if we have some that are ones
yeah there we go there's some ones down
here so when you look at 10 of them you
can see all the way down to zero or one
that's our quality and again we're
looking at high quality we're looking at
the seven and the eights or six point
five and up and let's go ahead and grab
our or was it here we go wine quality
and let's take another look at what else
more information about the wine quality
itself and we can do a simple pandas
thing value counts hopefully I type that
in there correctly and we can see that
we only have 217 of our wines which are
going to be the higher quality so 217
and the rest of them fall into the bad
bucket the zero which is uh 1382 so
again we're just looking for the top
percentage of these the top what is that
it's probably about a little a little
under 20 percent on there so we're
looking for our top wines our seven and
eights and let's use our let's plot this
on a graph so we take a look at this and
the SNS if you remember correctly that
is let me just back at the top that's
our Seaborn Seaborn sits on top of
matplot Library it has a lot of added
features plus all the features of the
matplot library and also makes it quick
and easy to put out a graph we'll do a
simple bar graph and they actually call
it count plot and then we want to just
do count plot the wine quality so let's
put our wine quality in there and let's
go ahead and run this and see what that
looks like and nice in line remember
this is why we did the inline so make
sure it appears in here and you can see
the blue space or the first space
represents low quality wine and our
second bar is a high quality line and
you can see that we're just looking at
the top quality wine here Mimosa wine we
want to just give it away to the
neighbors and maybe if you don't like
your neighbors maybe give them the good
quality wine and I don't know what you
do with the bad quality wine I guess use
it for cooking there we go but you can
see here it forms a nice little graph
for us with the Seaborn on there and you
can see our setup on that so now we've
looked at we've done some pre-processing
we've described our data a little bit we
have a picture of how much of the wine
what we expect it to be high quality low
quality checked out the fact that
there's none we don't have any null
values to contend with or any odd values
some of the other things you sometimes
look at these is if you have like some
values that are just way off the chart
so the measurement might be off or
miscalibrated equipment fear in the
scientific field so the next step we
want to go ahead and do is we want to go
ahead and separate our data set or
reformat our data set and we usually use
capital x and that denotes the features
we're working with and we usually use a
lowercase y that denotes what in this
case quality what we're looking for and
we can take this we can go wine it's
going to be our full thing of wine
dropping what are we dropping we're
dropping the quality so these are all
the features minus quality I'll make
sure we have our axes equals one if you
left it out it would still come out
correctly just because of the way it
processes on the defaults and then our y
if we're going to remove quality for our
X that's just going to be 1 and it is
just the quality that we're looking at
for y so we put that in there and we'll
go ahead and run this so now we've
separated the features that we want to
use to predict the quality of the wine
and the quality itself the next step is
if you're going to create a data set in
a model we got to know how good our
model is so we're going to split the
data train and test splitting data and
this is one of the packages we imported
from sklearn and the actual package was
train test split and we're going to do X
Y test size 0.2 random State 42 and this
returns four variables and most common
you'll see is capital x train so we're
going to train our set with capital X
test that's the data we're going to keep
on the side to test it with why train
why remember stands for the quality or
the answer we're looking for so when we
train it we're going to use x train and
Y train and then why test to see how
good our X test does and the train test
split let me just go back up to the top
I was part of the sklearn model
selection import train test split there
is a lot of ways to split data up this
is when you're first starting you do
your first model you probably start with
the basics on here you have one test for
training one for test our test size is
0.2 or 20 percent and random State just
means we just start with a it's like a
random seed number so that's not too
important back there we're randomly
selecting which ones we're going to use
since this is the most common way this
is what we're going to use today there
is and it's not even an sklearn package
yet so someone's still putting it in
there one of the new things they do is
they split the data into thirds and then
they'll run the model on each of they
combine each of those thirds into
two-thirds for training and one for
testing so you actually go through all
the data and you come up with three
different test results from it which is
pretty cool that's a pretty cool way of
doing it you could actually do that with
this by just splitting this into thirds
and then or you have a test site one
test set third and then split the
training set also into thirds and also
do that and get three different data
sets this works fine for most projects
especially when you're starting out it
works great so we have our X train our X
test our y train and our y test and then
we need to go ahead and do the scalar
and let's talk about this because this
is really important some models do not
need to have scaling going on most
models do and so we create our scalar
variable we'll call it SC standard
scalar and if you remember correctly we
imported that here wrong with the label
encoder the standard scalar setup so
there's our scalar and this is going to
convert the values instead of having
some values that go from zero if you
remember up here we had some values are
54 60 40 59 102. so our total sulfur
dioxide would have these huge values
coming into our model and some models
would look at that and they'd become
very biased to sulfur dioxide it'd have
the hugest impact and then a value that
had
0.076.098 our chlorides would have very
little impact because it's such a small
number so when we take the scalar we
kind of level the playing field and
depending on our scalar it sets it up
between 0 and 1 a lot of times is what
it does let's go ahead and take a look
at that and we'll go ahead and start
with our X train and our X train equals
SC fit transform we talked about that
earlier that's an sklearn setup it's
going to both fit and transform our X
train into our X train variable and if
we have an X train we also need to do
that to our test and this is important
because you need to note that you don't
want to refit the data we want to use
the same fit we used on the training as
on the testing otherwise you get
different results and so we'll do just
oops not fit
form we're only going to transform the
test side of the data so here's our X
test that we want to transform and let's
go ahead and run that and just so we
have an idea let's go ahead and take and
just print out our X train oh let's do
first 10 variables very similar to the
way you do with the head on a data frame
you can see here our variables are now
much more uniform and they've scaled
them to the same scale so they're
between certain numbers and with the
basic scalar you can fine tune it I just
let it do its defaults on this and
that's fine for what we're doing in most
cases you don't really need to mess with
it too much it does look like it goes
between like minus probably minus two to
two or something like that that's just
looking at the train variable I'm going
to cut that one out of there so before
we actually build the models and start
discussing the SK learn models we're
going to use we covered a lot of ground
here most of when you're working with
these models you put a lot of work into
pre prepping the data so we looked at
the data data notice that it's separated
loaded it up we went in there we found
out there's no null values it's hard to
say no no values we have there's none
there's none nobody I can't say it
and of course we sum it up if you had a
lot of null values this would be really
important coming in here so is there a
null summary we looked at pre-processing
the data as far as the quality and we're
looking at the bins so this would be
something you might start playing with
maybe you don't want super fine wine you
don't want the seven and eights maybe
you want to split this differently so
certainly you can play with the bins and
get different values and make the bins
smaller or lean more towards the lower
quality so you then have like medium to
high quality and we went ahead and gave
it labels again this is all pandas we're
doing in here setting up with unique
labels and group names bad good bad is
lesson good that could be so important
you don't know how many times people go
through these models and they have them
reversed or something and then they go
back and they're like why is this data
not looking correct so it's important to
remember what you're doing up here and
double check it and we used our label
encoder so that was to set that up as
equality zero one good in this case we
have bad good zero one I think we just
double check that to make sure that's
what came up in the quality there and
then we threw it into a graph because
people like to see graphs I don't know
about you but you start looking at all
these numbers and all this text and you
get down here and you say oh yes you
know here this is how much of the wine
we're going to label as subpar not good
and this is how much we're going to
label as good and then we got down here
to finally separating out our data so
it's ready to go into the models and the
models take X and A Y in this case X is
all of our features minus the one we're
looking for and then Y is the features
we're looking for so in this case we
dropped quality and in the Y case we
added quality and then because we need
to have a training set and a test set so
we can see how good our models do we
went ahead and split the models up X
train X test y train y test and that's
using the train test split which is part
of the sklearn package and we did as far
as our testing size 0.2 or 20 percent
the default is 25 so if you leave that
out it'll do default setup and we did a
random State equals 42. if you leave
that out it'll use a random State I
believe it's default one I'd have to
look that back up and then finally we
scaled the data this is so important to
scale the data going back up to here if
you have something that's coming out as
a hundred it's going to really outweigh
something that's 0.071 that's not in all
the models different models handle it
differently and as we look at the
different models I'll talk a little bit
about that we're going to only look at
three models today three of the top
models used for this and see how they
compare and how the numbers come out
between them so we're going to look at
three different setups let me change my
cell here to mark down there we go and
we're going to start with the random
Forest classifier so the three sets
we're looking at is the random Forest
classifier support vector classifier and
then a neural network now we start with
the random Forest classifier because it
has the least amount of Parts moving
parts to fine-tune and let's go ahead
and put this in here so we're going to
call it RFC for random force classifier
and if you remember we imported that so
let me go back up here to the top real
quick and we did an import of the random
fourth classifier from SK learn Ensemble
and then we'll all we also let me just
point this out here's our svm where we
inputted our support Vector classifier
so svm is support Vector model support
vector classifier and then we also have
our neural network and we're going to
from there the multi-layered precipitron
classifier kind of a mouthful for the P
percepatron don't worry too much about
that name it's just it's a neural
there's a lot of different options on
there and setups which is where they
came up with the precipitron but so we
have our three different models we're
going to go through one here and then
we're going to weigh them here's our
metrics we're going to use a confusion
Matrix also from the SK learn package to
see how good our model does with our
split so let's go back down there and
take a look at that and we have our RFS
equals random forest classifier and we
have n estimators equals 200. this is
the only value you play with with a
random Force classifier how many forests
do you need or how many trees in the
forest so how many models are in here
that makes it pretty good as a startup
model because you're only playing with
one number and it's pretty clear what it
is and you can lower this number or
raise it usually start up with a higher
number and then bring it down to see if
it keeps the same value so you have less
you know the smaller the model the
better the fit and it's easier to send
out to somebody else if you're going to
distribute it now the random 4 is
classify fire everything I read says
it's used for kind of a medium-sized
data set so you can run it in on Big
Data you can run it on smaller data
obviously but tends to work best in the
mid-range and we'll go ahead and take
our RFC and I just copied this from the
other side dot fit X train comma y train
so we're sending it our features and
then the quality in the Y train what we
want to predict in there and we just do
a simple fit now remember this is
sklearn so everything is fit or
transform another one is predict which
we'll do in just a second here if I just
do that now predict
FC equals and it's our RFC model predict
and what are we predicting on well we
trained it with our train values so now
we need our test our X test so this has
done it this is going to do this is the
three lanes of code we need to create
our random Forest variable fit our
training data to it so we're programming
it to fit in this case it's got 200
different trees it's going to build and
then we're going to predict on here let
me go ahead and just run that and we can
actually do something like oh let's do
predict
RFC just real quick we'll look at the
first 20 variables of it let's go ahead
and run that and in our first 20
variables we have three wines that make
the cut and the other 17 don't so the
other 17 are bad quality and three of
them are good quality in our predicted
values and if you can remember correctly
we'll go ahead and take this out of here
this is based on our test so these are
the first 20 values in our test and this
has as you can see all the different
features listed in there and they've
been scaled so when you look at these
they're a little bit confusing to look
at and hard to read but we have there's
a minus 01 so this is 0.36 minus so one
so 0.164 minus 0.09 or no it's still
minus one so minus 0.9 all between 0 and
1 on here I think I was confused earlier
and I said 0 between 2 negative two but
it's between minus one and one which is
what it should be in the scale and we'll
go ahead and just cut that out of there
run this we have our setup button here
so now that we've run the prediction and
we have predicted values well one you
could publish them but what do we do
with them well we want to do with them
is we want to see how well our model
model performed that's the whole reason
for splitting it between a training and
testing model and for that remember we
imported the classification report
that was again from the SK learn there's
our confusion Matrix and classification
report and the classification report
actually sits on the confusion Matrix so
it uses that information and our
classification report we want to know
how good our y test that's the actual
values versus our predicted RFC so we'll
go ahead and print this report out and
let's take a look and we can see here we
have a Precision out of the zero we had
about 0.92 that were labeled as a bad
that were actually bad and out of
precision for the quality wines we're
running about 78 percent so you kind of
give us an overall 90 percent and you
can see our F1 score our support set up
on there a recall you could also do the
confusion Matrix sign here which gives
you a little bit more information but
for this this is going to be good enough
for right now we're just going to look
at how good this model was because we
want to compare the random force
classifier with the other two models and
you know what let's go ahead and put in
the confusion Matrix just so you can see
see that on there with Y test and
prediction RFC so in the confusion
Matrix we can see here that we had
266 correct and seven wrong these are
the missed labels for bad wine and we
had a lot of mislabels for good wine so
our quality labels aren't that good
we're good at predicting bad wine not so
good at predicting whether it's a good
quality wine important to note on there
so that is our basic random forest
classifier and let me go ahead of cell
and change cell type to mark down and
run that so we have a nice label let's
look at our svm classifier our support
Vector model and this would look
familiar we have our clf we're going to
create what's it we'll call it just like
we call this an RFC and then we'll have
our clf DOT fit and this should be
identical to up above X
train comma y train and just like we did
before let's go ahead and do the
prediction and here is our clf predict
and it's going to equal the clf dot
predict and we want to go ahead and use
x underscore test and right about now
you can realize that you can create
these different models and actually just
create a loop to go through your
different models and put the data in and
that's how they designed it they
designed it to have that ability let's
go ahead and run this and then let's go
ahead and do our classification report
and I'm just going to copy this right
off of here
they say you shouldn't copy and paste
your code and the reason is is when you
go in here and edit it
you invariably will miss something we
only have two lines so I think I'm safe
to do it today and let's go ahead and
run this
and let's take a look how the svm
classifier came out so up here we had a
90 percent and down here we're running
about an 86 percent so it's not doing as
good now remember we randomly split the
data so if I run this a bunch of times
you'll see some changes down here so
these numbers this size of data if I
read it 100 times it would probably be
within plus or minus three or four on
here in fact if I ran this 100 times
you'd probably see these come out almost
the same as far as how well they do in
classification and then on the confusion
Matrix let's take a look at this one
this had 22 by 25 this one has 35 by 12.
so it's doing not quite as good that
shows up here 71 percent versus 78
percent and then if we're going to do a
svm classifier we also want to show you
one more and before I do that I'll kind
of tease you a little bit here before we
jump into neural networks the big save
all deep learning because everything
else must be shallow learning that's a
joke let's just talk a little bit about
the svm versus the random Forest
classifier the svm tends to work better
on smaller numbers it also works really
good on because a lot of times you
convert things into numbers and bins and
things like that the random Forest tends
to do better with those at least that's
my brief experience with it where if you
have just a lot of raw data coming in
the svm is usually the fastest and
easiest to apply model on there so they
each have their own benefits you'll find
that again that when you run these like
a hundred times difference between these
two on a data set like this is going to
just go away there's Randomness involved
depending on which data we took and how
they classify them the big one is the
neural networks and this is what makes
the neural networks nice is they can do
they can look into huge amounts of data
so for a project like this you probably
don't need a neural network on this but
it's important to see how they work
differently and how they come up
differently so you can work with huge
amounts of data you can also many
respects they work really good with text
analysis especially if it's time
sensitive more and more you have an
order of text and they've just come out
with different ways of feeding that data
in where the series and the Order of the
words is really important same thing
with starting to predict in the stock
market if you have tons of data coming
in from different sources the neural
network can really process that in a
powerful way to pull up things that
aren't seen before when I say lots of
data coming in I'm not talking about
just the high lows that you can run an
svm on real easily I'm talking about the
data that comes in where you have maybe
you pulled off the Twitter feeds and
have word counts going on and you've
pulled off the the different news feeds
the business are looking at and the
different releases when they release the
different reports so you have all this
different data coming in and the neural
network does really good with that
pictures picture processing Now is
really moving heavily into the neural
network if you have a pixel 2 or pixel 3
phone put out by Google it has a neural
network for doing it's kind of goofy but
you can put Little Star Wars Androids
dancing around your pictures and things
things like that that's all done with
the neural network so it has a lot of
different uses but it's also requires a
lot of data and as heavy-handed for
something like this and this should now
look familiar because we've done it
twice before we have our multi-layered
precipitron classifier we'll call it an
mlpc and it's this is what we imported
mlpc classifier there's a lot of
settings in here the first one is the
hidden layers you have to have the
hidden layers in there we're going to do
three layers of 11 each so that's how
many nodes are in each layer as it comes
in and that was based on the fact we
have 11 features coming in then I went
ahead and just did three layers probably
get by with a lot less on this but yeah
I didn't want to sit and play with it
all afternoon again this is one of those
things you play with a lot because the
more hidden layers you have the more
resources you're using you can also run
into problems with overfitting with too
many layers and you also have to run
higher iterations the max iteration we
have is set to 500. the default's 200
because I use three layers of 11 each
which is by the way kind of a default I
use I realized that usually you have
about three layers going down and the
number of features going across you'll
see that it's pretty common for the
first classifier when you're working in
neural networks but it also means you
have to do higher iterations so we up
the iterations to 500 so that means it's
going through the data 500 times to
program those different layers and
carefully adjust them and we do have a
full tutorials you can go look up on
neural networks and understand the
neural network settings a lot more and
of course we have you're looking over
here where we had our previous model
where we fit it same thing here mlpc fit
X train y train and then we're going to
create our prediction so let's do our
predict and mlpc and it's going to equal
the mlpc and we'll just take the same
thing here predict X test let's just put
that down here dot predict test and if I
run that we've now programmed it we now
have our prediction here same as before
and we'll go ahead and do the copy print
again always be careful with the copy
paste because you always run the chance
of missing one of these variables so if
you're doing a lot of coding you might
want to skip that copy and paste and
just type in and let's go ahead and run
this and see what that looks like and we
came up with an 88 percent we're going
to compare that with the 86 from our
tree our svm classifier and our 90 from
the random forest classifier and keep in
mind random Forest classifiers they do
good on mid-size data the SPM on smaller
amounts of data although to be honest I
don't think that's initially the split
between the two and these things will
actually come together if you ran them a
number of times and we can see down here
the noun of good wines mislabeled with
the setup on there it's on par with our
random Forest so it had 22 25 should be
a surprise it's identical it just didn't
do as good with the bad wines labeling
what's a bad one and what's not let's
see yeah because they had 266 and 7 we
head down here 260 and 13. so mislabeled
a couple of the bad ones as good wines
so we've explored three of these basic
classifiers these are probably the three
most widely used news right now I might
even throw in the random tree if we open
up their website we go under supervised
learning there's a linear model we
didn't do that almost most of data
usually just start with a linear model
because it's going to process the
quickest I'm going to use the least
amount of resources but you can see they
have linear quadratic they have kernel
Ridge there's our support Vector
stochastic gradient nearest neighbors
nearest neighbors is another common one
that's used a lot very similar to the
svm gaussian process cross decomposition
naive Bayes this is more of an
intellectual one that I don't see used a
lot but it's like the basis of a lot of
other things decision tree there's
another one that's used a lot Ensemble
methods not as much multi-class and
multi-label algorithms feature selection
neural networks that's the other one we
use down here and of course the forest
so you can see there's a in SK learn
there are so many different options and
they've just developed them over the
years we covered three of the most
commonly used ones in here and went over
a little bit over why they're different
neural network just because it's fun to
work in deep learning and not in Shallow
learning as I told you it doesn't mean
that the svm is actually shallow it does
a lot of it covers a lot of things and
same thing with the decision for the
random forest classifier and we notice
that there's a number of other different
classifier options in there these are
just the three most common ones and I'd
probably throw the nearest neighbor in
there and the decision tree which is
usually part of the decision for us
depending on what the back end you're
using and since as human beings if I was
in the shareholders office I wouldn't
want to leave them with a confusion
Matrix they need that information for
making decisions but we want to give
them just one particular score and so I
would go ahead and we have our sklearn
metrics we're going to import the
accuracy score and I'm just going to do
this on the random four since that was
our best model and we have our CM
accuracy score and I forgot to print it
if you remember in Jupiter notebook we
can just do the last variable we leave
out there it'll print and so our CM
accurate score we get is 90 and that
matches up here we should already see
that up here in Precision so you can
either quote that but a lot of times
people like to see it highlighted at the
very end this is our Precision on this
model and then the final stage is we
would like to use this for future so
let's go ahead and take our wine if you
remember correctly we'll do one head of
10. we'll run that remember our original
data set we've gone through so many
steps then we're going to go back to
original data and we can see here we
have our top 10 our top 10 on the list
only two of them make it as having high
enough quality wine for us to be
interested in them and then let's go
ahead and create some data here we'll
call it X Nu equals and this is
important this data has to be we just
kind of randomly selected some data
looks an awful lot like some of the
other numbers on here which is what it
should look like and so we have our X Nu
equals
7.3.58 and so on and then it is so
important this is where people forget
this step X new equals SC remember SC
that was our standard scalar variable we
created if we go right back up here
before we did anything else we created
an sc we fit it and we transformed it
and then we need to do what transform
the data we're going to feed in
so we're going to go back down here and
we're going to transform our X new and
then we're going to go ahead and use the
where are we at here we go our random
forest and if you remember all it is is
our RFC predict model right there let's
go ahead and just grab that down here
and so our y Nu equals here's our rafc
predict and we're going to do our X new
in and then it's kind of nice to know
what it actually puts out so according
to this it should print out what our
prediction is for this wine and oh it's
a bad wine okay so we didn't pick out a
good wine for our X new and that should
be expected most of wine if you remember
correctly only a small percentage of the
wine met our quality requirements so we
can look at this and say oh we'll have
to try another wine out which is fine by
me because I like to try out new wines
and I certainly have a collection of old
wine bottles and very few of them match
but you can see here we've gone through
the whole process just a quick rehash we
had our Imports we touched a lot on the
SK learn our random Forest our svm and
our MLP classifier so we had our support
vector classifier we had our random
forests and we have our neural network
three of the top used classifiers in the
sklearn system and we also have our
confusion Matrix and our classification
report which we used our standard scalar
for scaling it and our label encoder and
of course we need to go ahead and split
our data up in our implot line train and
we explored the data in here for null
values we set up our quality into bins
we took a look at the data and what we
actually have and put a nice little plot
to show our quality what we're looking
at and then we went through our three
different models and it's always
interesting because you spend so much
time getting to these models and then
you kind of go through the models and
play with them until you get the best
training on there without becoming
biased that's always a challenge is to
not over train your data to the point
where you're training it to fit the test
value and finally we went ahead and
actually used it and applied it to a new
wine which unfortunately didn't make the
cut it's going to be the one that we
drink a glass out of and save the rest
for cooking of course that's according
to the random Forest on there because we
use the best model that it came up with
if you are one of the aspiring python
enthusiasts looking for online training
and graduating from the best
universities for a professional who
elicits to switch careers in Python by
learning from the experts and try giving
a show to Simply learn's postgraduate
program in Ai and machine learning in
collaboration with Purdue University and
IBM the course link is mentioned in the
description box below that will navigate
you to the course page where you can
find a complete audio of the program
being offered in this video on Pi game
we will teach you how to develop games
using the python module called by game
so let's get started
before we dive into the video let's get
a general overview of what you can
expect to learn from it what's in it for
you and what will you know by the end of
this video
the first thing that we will teach you
is what exactly is Spy game you will
understand what exactly the pi game
module is and the various ways that you
can use it to develop games
next we will teach you how to install Pi
game on your system
then we will take a look at the basic
components of Pi game and finally we
will be using the pi game module and
Python Programming to develop a Flappy
Bird game which you can play in real
life on your own system
so let's get started
so what exactly is Spy game
pie game is a cross-platform python
software which was made specifically for
video game designing it includes
Graphics visuals and sounds which can be
used to enhance the game which is being
designed by you
officially written by Pete shiners to
replace Pi sdl Pi game is suitable to
create client-side applications that can
be potentially wrapped in a standalone
executable
to learn Pi game it is required to have
a basic knowledge of python
now how do you go about installing
pygame on your system
to install Pi game you can use the
standard pip install command in your
command prompt then you can import it
into your program with the import
command prompt in Python itself
before installing Pi game python should
be installed in the system it is good to
have python
3.6.1 or above versions because it is
much friendlier to beginners and
additionally runs way faster
now what are the basic components of Pi
game
the first and most important component
of Pi game is the pygame dot init module
this is used to initialize all imported
by game modules using this you can call
all Pi game modules at once into your
program
before you can do much with buy game you
need to initialize it the most common
way to do this is to use spygame dot
init this will initialize all the
modules and buy game with just one
single command
not all Pi game modules need to be
initialized but this will automatically
initialize the ones that are important
and the ones that have to be initialized
you can also easily initialize Each pie
game module by hand
the next thing that you need to know
about is the display surface the display
surface is a black screen which acts as
a canvas for you to design your games on
all the game components will appear on
this very screen
now buy game has a single display
surface that is either contained in a
window or runs full screen once you
create the display you can cheat it as a
regular surface
changes are not immediately visible on
screen
you must choose one of the two flipping
functions to update the actual display
the pi game display can actually be
initialized by one of several modes by
default the display is a basic software
driven frame buffer you can request
special modules like Hardware
acceleration and opengl support now Pi
game can only have a single display
active at any time
creating a new display will close the
previous display
once the display surface is created the
functions from this module affect the
single existing display the surface
becomes invalid if the module is
uninitialized if a new display mode is
set the existing surface will
automatically switch to operate on the
new display
the next concept is the game Loop the
game Loop is a piece of code that does
three things it will handle events
update game events and draw game state
to the screen
the game Loop will basically run until a
condition is met or until the game ends
and finally you have bygame.quit
the pygame.quit function does the
opposite of the init function and
completely deactivates the pi game
Library
it will automatically uninitialize all
Pi game modules that have previously
been initialized
when the python interpreter shuts down
this method is called regardless so your
program does not always need it except
when it wants to terminate its buy game
resources and continue
it is safe to call this function more
than once as repeated calls have no
effect whatsoever
now please do note that calling pygame
dot quit will not exit your program
consider letting a program end in the
same way a normal Python program will
end it will just help you break out of
the game Loop
now let's see how we can create a Flappy
Bird game with the help of the Python Pi
game module so the first thing that
you're going to need is to call all of
your required modules
so over here we have imported the random
and this is module we've imported the pi
game module and we've also imported all
the modules which are present in
buygame.locals
so let's run this so all the modules get
imported into our program
there we go the all of our pie game
modules have been imported
now the first thing that we're doing is
that we're setting Global variables for
the game the window width and the window
height basically determine how big our
surface is going to be
after that we're going to display our
window now you can call or create a
window by using
buygame.display.set mode and within set
mode you set your window parameters so
you set your window width and your
window height
so here we will be creating a window of
width 600 and a fight 499.
the elevation will basically tell you
how far up from the bottom of your
screen the window is going to be
we're going to be creating an NT Tuple
of your game images and we're gonna be
having an FPS of 32.
you can obviously change your FPS speed
now all of these images that we're
importing have already been downloaded
onto your system
so all of these images are already here
and they're in the same folder that
we've stored a Flappy Bird game in which
is why to call them you simply have to
write the name of the image
and initialize it to a variable
so because we're creating Flappy Bird
we're going to have a pipe image a
background image a bird and obviously a
base which is going to be a C Level and
which you have to prevent the bird from
touching so let's run this and create
nothing but a pygame window
so here as you can see a new window has
come up this so far is just a pi game
window nothing has been shown on it
because we haven't initialized any of
these parameters into a window as of yet
so far the only thing we've done is
create a basic window which doesn't have
any of the parameters on it with the
width of 600 and height of 499
now here we are going to be coming into
our python game Loop
so the first thing that we talk about in
our python game is that you have to have
some initialized variables right
and you have to create some important
components of the game so the first
thing that you have is the Flappy game
which is the game itself
the next thing that we have here is to
check if our game is over this is going
to happen under two conditions one is
that the bird hits the pipe and the
second condition is that the bird falls
into the sea
and finally we will have a module to
create pipes of random height as and
when a bird goes further into the screen
so basically the pipes will be created
as the user keeps going and not
beforehand
and finally here we have our main game
Loop which is going to be calling all of
these various functions that we've
created I'm just going to terminate
their run time the second that the game
gets over
and then following this we're going to
be exiting the Flappy Bird game
quit as you can see as we've already
told you will close all of the pie game
modules that you've already initialized
in your program and will uninitialize
all of these modules while sys.exit will
exit the program itself now as we said
the pygame dot quit doesn't quit the
program it only uninitializes all the pi
game modules which is exactly why we're
using sys.exist to close a window and
exit our program
now the first thing that we're going to
be looking at is the Flappy Bird game
itself
the main things that are happening in a
flappy game is first of all for
initializing variables and creating two
pipes by calling the create pipe
function
so at any given point we know that we
want our bird to fly in between two
pipes
that is the main challenge here which is
exactly why we're initializing two pipes
here the first pipe and the second pipe
and this is done by calling the create
pipe function now after this we're going
to be creating two lists one is of the
lower pipes and the other is of the
upper pipes now as we already talked
about we are going to have two pipes
consecutively yeah the first pipe is
going to be on top and the second pipe
is going to be at the bottom
so that's exactly what these two lists
contain they contain the height at which
the down pipes and the up pipes are
going to be or basically they contain
the coordinates at which these down
pipes and up pipes will be displayed at
now pipe well X is basically defining
the pipe velocity along your x-axis and
the bird velocity which is along the
y-axis is defined over here
so basically your bird is going to have
two different parameters one is that
it's going to move up and down which is
its velocity along the y axis and
another is it's going to move across
which is its velocity across the x-axis
now at the same time the pipes also have
to keep moving
and they have to exit this Frame
so that's what this all of this is
defined by the bird acceleration is
defined over here this is the parameter
that you're going to be using to Define
your bird acceleration along the y-axis
that is basically going to happen when
you stop clicking and the bird starts
falling downwards
now the velocity while flapping or the
x-axis velocity for the bird is defined
over here now the bird is only going to
be flapping when you are going to be
pressing the key so that's basically
what you're going to be checking here
if your event takes place which
basically means that
if you have key events and that's
exactly what pygame dot event.get is
doing it's going to be getting all the
key functions that are taking place on
your keyboard simultaneously
so for event in pygame.even dot get will
basically help you get the keystrokes
which are happening if event type is
equal to quit or event type is equal to
key down and event dot key is equal to K
dot Escape you're going to quit your
game and you're going to close down your
program
so there are two ways that you can quit
your game you can either press quit or
you can press key down and Escape
now if your event type is equal to key
down and
your event dot key is equal to space or
k up so this is basically what you're
going to be using to make sure that your
bird is moving there are two main Keys
which are going to be coming into play
over here you are you can press the key
down as well as the space key or the key
down and the up key
so over here this is gonna move your
bird
vertically and it's also going to make
sure that your bird flaps its wings
which is where the bird velocity which
are all these parameters will come into
play
so this will basically help your bird
move forward so basically what is
happening here is that we're going to be
getting the keys that the user has
pressed and if they've pressed the quit
key we're going to quit the program and
if they've pressed key down and space or
key down and the up key we're going to
make sure that the bird starts moving in
the y-axis as well as it starts flapping
its wings and moving along in the x-axis
now this is the function
that checks for whether your bird has
crashed into pipes or not this is
basically also going to define whether
your game is over or not right because
once the bird touches a pipe the game is
basically finished so game over here is
is game over which is another
function that we are defining here
so basically what's happening over here
is that you're going to be checking if
the game is over by checking the
horizontal and vertical position of the
bird
and the positions of the up and down
pipes if the game is over then you will
return over here and you will basically
quit the whole game
now after this we need to keep track of
the score of the player now how that can
be done is that you get your position of
your bird and the position of your pipe
and if the bird has crossed the pipe
then you basically increase your score
by one if the current velocity of your
bird
is less than the maximum velocity and
the bird has not flapped or you haven't
pressed your key in that case the bird
is basically going to be tumbling
downwards now another thing that you
have to consider is
that the user has stopped pressing the
key right so the bird is not going to be
flapping its wings if this is the case
then the bird has to Free Fall towards
the C basically so this is how we're
gonna be checking it if the velocity of
the bird is less than the max velocity
and the bird has not flapped its wings
what we're going to be doing is we're
going to be increasing the present
velocity of the bird
in increments with an acceleration speed
that we've already defined over here
so if the bird starts flapping its wings
the velocity will steadily increase with
this acceleration
now if the bird has flapped its wings
after that we need to set the bird flap
function to false again
otherwise it will continue being true
which is not the case so we have to keep
switching it right the bird flap will
only be true when the user has pressed
the key after that it immediately has to
go back to a false variable so that is
basically what we're doing here we're
going to change the bird flap to false
immediately after it has become true
now after this your pipes will keep
moving to the left uh in this game the
pipes are the ones that are moving
horizontally the bird is not moving
horizontally the bird is only moving
vertically
so basically what we're going to be
doing is we're going to be increasing
the x coordinate of our pipe and the
pipe is not going to randomly start
increasing in height right so we're not
going to be touching the Y coordinates
of the pipe of the upper and the lower
pipe we're going to slowly increment the
x coordinate by the velocity factor that
we've already initialized previously so
the pipes will slowly keep moving by
this velocity Factor towards the left
hand side of the screen
huh
a new pipe will be added when the first
is about to cross the leftmost part of
the screen
so basically each pipe is covering about
five points on the x-axis and once it is
less than five but still greater than
zero we're going to create a new pipe
and we're gonna append it to our up
pipes list
and we'll also be creating another pipe
and we're gonna append it to our down
pipes list
now if the pipe is out of the screen we
basically have to remove it and this
we're going to do by popping out the
pipe from the up pipe list
so far we've looked at how we can
generate pipes for a bit uh for our
window the velocity of the bird when it
is flapping its wings and what is going
to happen when it stops flapping its
wings
handling uh the key pressing events that
the user is inputting
uh checking whether a bird has crashed
or not updating our score moving the
pipes to the left and creating new pipes
once the previous pipe has left the
screen
now
the only thing that's left to do is
build a game image window because we've
dealt with almost all the game logic
that we need
so now we're basically going to start
building our PI game window
uh so first we're going to be putting
the image all throughout this screen uh
we're going to be rendering the up pipe
and down pipe at the respective
positions on the screen
and then we're going to be putting the
sea level and the bird on the screen
another thing that you need to do is
fetch the digits of this score and
display them on your screen so the
digits again all of the images have
already been included in our Flappy Bird
folder and all you have to do is just
play them onto the screen
to do this all that we have to do is
Loop through our numbers list and
display this scoreboard images on the
side of our window
and this is a position at which they'll
be displayed
so here we're just displaying the images
on the screen
uh the offset is again just a variable
that we've created here and that's the
variable at which we'll be displaying
the images
now every time this code changes you're
going to have to update the game window
so that is exactly what you're doing
here you're just updating your display
game window
and as we talked about every time your
display changes
you can't have two displays open at once
so the game will move on to this new
display window
and again we're just over here we're
just setting the frames per second
and that brings us to the end of
everything that we need to do this is
the basic game logic that we're going to
be needing so this whole function just
defines your game logic let's finish
running this
and your game logic has been initialized
into your program now
now the next thing that we have to do is
check if our bird is above sea level or
if it has hit any of the pipes so this
is what you use the is game over
function for
so there is game over function will have
four different parameters as input so
the is game over function has four
parameters you're going to be giving the
horizontal and the vertical height of
the bird and the height and position of
the up pipes and the downpipes now there
are basically three conditions which
lead to a situation of the game being
over if the difference between a
elevation and a certain height is less
than the vertical it means that the bird
has crossed its boundaries and that is
why the game is over which is where you
return true
though another thing is that the bird
hits either the up pipes or one of the
downpipes and that's what we're checking
here either the elevation of the bird
has decreased
and does know whether it can rise up
again and hence a game will be over or
the bird has hit one of the pipes on top
of one of the bottom pipes
so that's basically what we're doing
here we're getting the height of the up
pipe and we're checking if the vertical
height of the bird is less than the pipe
height plus the pipe width so basically
it can hit the pipe anywhere right so if
this vertical height is less than this
parameter as well as if the bird doesn't
hit
the pipe horizontally so that's what
we're basically checking here
we're checking to see if the bird has
hit the pipe horizontally or vertically
then you will return true and the same
thing will happen for the down pipes you
will check if the bird has hit the pipe
horizontally or vertically at any point
so let's run this game over function
the next thing that you have to do is
the create pipe function
now creating pipes is actually quite
easy all we have to do is fetch the
height of the pipe using the get height
function and after that generate a
random number
between 0 to any number such that the
height of the pipe should be adjustable
to a window height so there's only a
certain amount where you know you can
have the pipe visible and that has to be
above sea level so we're going to be
generating you know like a random number
between
0 and this number you know like 0 and
the width of your screen from height to
just above the sea level
and then we're going to be subtracting
it by 1.2 into offset because there's a
huge chance that we get like a pipe
which covers the entire screen so to
prevent that we're going to decrease the
height of the pipes a little
and then after that all we have to do is
push our pipes into a dictionary along
with their x-axis and y-axis coordinates
so this is basically what your pipe list
is going to look like it's going to be a
dictionary which consists of an upper
pipe and a lower pipe
and along with their coordinate values
so let's run this
now this is basically
the game Loop that we're going to be
using
um this is going to call our various
functions again and again
until the game basically gets over which
is defined over here
so this function is going to run or this
is your basic game start it's going to
keep running until a certain condition
is met and let's see what that condition
is
so over here the different things that
we're doing initially is that we're
initializing our program using pygame
dot init we're basically calling all the
modules of the pi game Library
then after that we're just setting the
frames per second
displaying the title of the game on top
of the game window by game.display.set
caption
um so far we only have a pi game window
right this is basically going to
initialize the background images and
everything onto this window
we're gonna start loading all of our
different images into our game so we
have different images for the scores the
Flappy Bird image sea level background
and pipe image and we're going to
convert it into a form suitable to
display onto our window
this is basically done using the
image.load
dot convert Alpha function
so over here you're basically going to
be loading your image and converting it
into a form which is suitable to be
displayed onto your screen
after that we basically be doing a
couple of basic startup things such as
printing welcome to Flappy Bird game and
press space or enter to start the game
and the second you see this you know
that this has started running properly
now this is where you have the main game
starting
so where you're basically going to be
setting the position of the bird and
horizontally we're going to be setting
it at one fifth of the window width you
can basically set the bird wherever you
want to
then after that we're going to be adding
the sea level and over here we've
initialized ground as zero
while true for event in pygame.event dot
get basically while we keep getting a
key stroke from the user
this whole Loop is going to keep running
and what exactly is happening in this
Loop over here basically we are running
the program until the user stops or
exists the game
otherwise we have basically created an
infinite while loop over here
so if the event type is equal to quit
we're going to quit the game and exit
the program if the event type is key
down then we are going to be calling
Flappy game so this is basically us
initializing the game start conditions
if the second
after the game starts the user clicks on
quit then we're going to quit the game
and exit the program otherwise if the
user has pressed the key down the space
key or the key up then we're going to be
calling a flappy game function
if the user hasn't pressed any key and
nothing has happened then we're just
going to have a basic game display and
we're going to be displaying the
background image the Flappy Bird and the
C Level onto our screen
this is just to keep refreshing the
screen and this is basically to set the
frame rate of our screen so let's run
this
now if we look at our Flappy Bird game
you can see that we have
all of the parameters initialized we
have a background we have a C Level and
we have our bird over here we've typed
Flappy Bird game on top and I'm gonna
press enter key to start
so far as you can see our pipes have
appeared here so we already know the
function behind this we keep getting our
pipes and the second that the bird
crosses a pipe the screen gets refreshed
and our score gets updated
so if you notice here clearly
if I go slow enough and if you notice
the second I did this the display window
actually got refreshed and the second
the pipe goes out of screen you as you
can see it gets erased and a new pipe
enter so the second this one pipe goes
out a new pipe gets created
now
as we've talked about there are three
basic conditions one is you hit the
bottom pipe and the game ends
another is you hit the
top pipe anywhere in the game ends and
the next one is your bird falls below a
certain level and the game ends so these
conditions are working so far our
scoreboard also keeps getting
initialized
another condition that you might want to
check for
oh yeah and as you can see another thing
that you notice is the velocity right so
the bird is technically not moving the
bird's position relative to where it
started from remains exactly the same as
you can see here the only thing that is
moving is its position on the y-axis
apart from this the pipes are moving and
do you remember the acceleration
parameter that we have this is where you
can see it come into the into play
so I stopped and this the way the Bird
Free Falls all of this is because of the
acceleration parameter that we set
so this is basically how you can use Pi
game to you know create a game
now let us quit the game
I press the Escape key and the entire
game has quit so over here
system exit took place as you can see
so this is all the logic that we've used
behind creating a Flappy Bird game
and as you can see we've used the pi
game module to create it with that we
have reached the end of this python
library's full course if you have any
questions please feel free to comment
and we'll have it answered for you as
soon as possible until next time thank
you for watching stay safe keep learning
and get ahead staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here